ASSEMBLY NATURAL RESOURCES
COMMITTEE OF A FEW REMINDERS
WERE PRACTICING PHYSICAL
DISTANCE SEEN HERE IN THE
HEARING ROOM AND THROUGHOUT THE
CAPITAL MASKS ARE REQUIRED AT
ALL TIMES HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM THROUGHOUT THE CAPITAL.
AND AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION OUTSIDE. TESTIMONY CAN
PRE CAN BE PROVIDED IN PERSON.
AT THE REMOTE TESTIMONY STATION
LOCATED OUTSIDE THE CAPITAL
NEAR THE NORTH STEPS AND- AND
ALSO BY PHONE THE NUMBER FOR
PHONE TESTIMONY IS. EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN SIX NINE TWO EIGHT NINE
FIVE SEVEN. THE NUMBER IS
POSTED ON THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AND ALSO APPEARS ON THE
VIDEO FEED. ONCE THE PRIMARY
SUPPORT AND OPPOSITION
WITNESSES HAVE TESTIFIED I WILL
CALL FOR PHONE TESTIMONY TO
REDUCE DELAYS SUPPORTED
OPPOSITION WILL BE COMBINED
INTO A SINGLE Q. TESTIMONY WILL
BE LIMITED AS FOLLOWS. EACH
PRIMARY SUPPORT IN OPPOSITION
WITNESS WILL BE GIVEN TWO
MINUTES. ADDITIONAL MEAT TO
TESTIMONY WILL BE LIMITED TO A
TOTAL OF FIVE MINUTES. ALL
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY OF ANY
LENGTH MAY BE SUBMITTED TO THE
COMMITTEE VIA OUR WEBSITE AT A.
N. T. R. DOT ASSEMBLY DOT CA
DOT G. O. V. PLEASE NOTE THAT
THE HEARING WILL ADJOURN BEFORE
ONE PM AS THE ROOM MUST BE
CLEARED BY ONE PM FOR ANOTHER
COMMITTEE. LET'S SEE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM YET BUT WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND START AS
A SUBCOMMITTEE- AND I'D LIKE TO
INVITE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER AWARD.
TO PRESENT AB FIVE HUNDRED.
MORNING THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS WE KNOW THAT
CALIFORNIA CONTINUES TO
EXPERIENCE A SEVERE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING CRISIS WITH THE
DEFICIENCY OF THREE MILLION
HOMES AND GROWING THIS ISSUE IS
EXACERBATED IN THE RESIDENTIAL
AREAS OF THE COASTAL ZONE WHERE
DEVELOPMENTS FACE SERIOUS
CHALLENGES NOW EIGHTY USE AND
SUPPORT HOUSING CAN PROVIDE
SOLUTIONS TO HELP THE CURRENT
HOUSING CRISIS FOR MIDDLE AND
LOWER INCOME CALIFORNIANS. YET
THEY ARE UNDER UTILIZED IN THE
COASTAL ZONE IN PART DUE TO THE
TIME INTENSIVE COASTAL
DEVELOPMENT PERMIT PROCESS AT
THE LEGISLATURE HAS IN RECENT
YEARS PASS LAWS TO STREAMLINE
THE DEVELOPMENT PROCESS HE'S
FOR EIGHTY YEARS IN SUPPORT OF
HOUSING HOWEVER WHILE DOES HELP
CITIES THEY DID NOT EXTEND TO
THE CD P. PROCESS WHICH ARE A
STATE PROCESS THIS BILL
ADDRESSES THAT. THE CALIFORNIA
COASTAL COMMISSION HAS TAKEN
STEPS TO CLARIFY THE REGULATORY
PROCESS FOR LOCAL JURISDICTIONS
TO ADOPT HOWEVER IT IS NOT
EXPRESSLY WITHIN THE COMMISSION
SCOPE TO PROMOTE SOLUTIONS IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE WITH
OPPOSITION FROM THE COMMISSION
THE LEGISLATURE AMENDED THE
COASTAL ACT TO REMOVE LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME HOUSING
POLICIES FROM ITS JURISDICTION
SO AB FIVE HUNDRED WILL
REINSTATE THE COASTAL ACT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING POLICIES
THAT WERE REPEALED FORTY YEARS
AGO. AND GIVE THE COMMISSION
THE AUTHORITY TO PROTECT
EXISTING AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND
ENSURE THAT NEW AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS CONSISTENT WITH
COASTAL ACT POLICIES THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS TO UPDATE AND
STREAMLINE THE REGULATORY C. P.
PROCESS FOR EDUS JUNIOR EIGHTY
USE AND SUPPORT OF HOUSING
WITHIN THE COASTAL ZONE. I'M
WORKING WITH THE COMMISSION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE REQUIREMENT
ITSELF A SIMPLE AN EXPEDITIOUS
THE BILL RETAIN SUPPORT FOR THE
EVALUATION PROTECTION OF
SENSITIVE NATURAL RESOURCES IN
THE COASTAL TOWN WHILE REMOVING
BARRIERS FOR EIGHTY YEARS IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING ALONG
COASTAL COMMUNITIES SO BY
APPROVING AB FIVE HUNDRED
COASTAL COMMUNITIES WILL HAVE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO PARTNER WITH
THE COMMISSION TO PROVIDE NEW
HOUSING SOLUTIONS. AND TO
ENSURE THAT NOT JUST VISITORS
SERVING ACCOMMODATIONS BUT ALSO
RESIDENTIAL ACCESS TO THE COAST
IS BETTER AFFORDED TO ALL
CALIFORNIANS I'D LIKE TO
PRESENT MY WITNESS IN SUPPORT.
OF THE BILL SIR CHRISTIE WHO IS
IN THE- THE COMMITTEE ROOM TO
AIMED. AT LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE CALIFORNIA COMMISSION
AND BILL PRINCE LUCKY EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR PEOPLE ORGANIZED
FOR WESTSIDE RENEWAL OR POWER
WHO IS ON THE LINE. THANK YOU
WILL GO AHEAD AND START WITH
SERRA CHRISTIE. GOOD MORNING
CHAIRED MEMBERS I'M SURE
CHRISTY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION'S LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR AND I'M HERE TODAY
REPRESENTING THE COMMISSION'S
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT OF AB FIVE
HUNDRED YOU'RE ALL VERY AWARE
OF COSTA LACK POLICIES
PROTECTING PUBLIC ACCESS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES SUCH AS
WETLANDS AND SENSITIVE HABITAT
BUT YOU MAY NOT KNOW THAT WHEN
THE COASTAL ACT WAS ORIGINALLY
PASSED IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX
IT ALSO CONTAINED A POLICY.
PROTECTING AND PROVIDED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. FOR THE FIRST
FIVE YEARS OF THE PROGRAM THE
COMMISSION AUTHORIZED THE
CONSTRUCTION OF OVER FIVE
THOUSAND DEED RESTRICTED
AFFORDABLE UNITS WITHIN MARKET
RATE SUBDIVISIONS THAT WERE
SPRINGING UP ALONG THE
CALIFORNIA COAST FROM MISSION
VIEJO TO SANTA CRUZ. THE
COMMISSION ALSO PREVENTED THE
DEMOLITION OF OVER ELEVEN
HUNDRED EXISTING UNITS. AND
COLLECTED TWO MILLION DOLLARS
IN IN LIEU FEES. BUT AFFORDABLE
HOUSING WAS AS CONTROVERSIAL
THEN AS IT IS TODAY SO IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY ONE THE
LEGISLATURE PASSED A BILL
REPEALING THE COMMISSION'S
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AUTHORITY.
AND EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZING LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO DEMOLISH
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL ZONE. IT PROHIBITED THE
COMMISSION FROM ACQUIRING
HOUSING PROGRAMS IN L. C. PEAS
AND IT AUTHORIZED DEVELOPERS
WITH EXISTING PERMIT CONDITIONS
TO GET OUT OF THEIR OBLIGATIONS
TO PROVIDE AFFORDABLE UNITS. AS
A RESULT ONLY THIRTEEN HUNDRED
OF THOSE FIVE THOUSAND
INCLUSIONARY UNITS WERE EVER
BUILT. IMAGINE WHAT CALIFORNIA
WOULD LOOK LIKE TODAY IF THE
COMMISSION HAD BEEN ABLE TO
CONTINUE PROMOTING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THE COASTAL ZONE FOR
THE LAST FORTY YEARS. AB FIVE
HUNDRED WOULD RESTORE THE COSTA
LACKS AFFORDABLE HOUSING
POLICIES AND REPEAL THE
PROHIBITION ON LC PEAS. IT
WOULD ALSO ALLOW THE COMMISSION
TO PROVIDE FOR GREATER
RESIDENTIAL DENSITY IN AREAS
WITH ADEQUATE TRANSIT THAT ARE
NOT SUBJECT TO SEA LEVEL RISE.
FINALLY IT WOULD REQUIRE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO UPDATE L. C.
PIECE TO REFLECT REAP RECENT
CHANGES TO EIGHTY YOU IN
SUPPORT OF HOUSING LAWS.
SOMETHING THE COMMISSION HAS
BEEN RECOMMENDING SINCE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN. MEMBERS THIS IS AN
OPPORTUNITY TO UNDO THE
MISTAKES OF THE PAST. AND
RESTORE THE COSTA LACKS
ORIGINAL INTENT OF A COASTLINE
THAT IS NOT ONLY ACCESSIBLE TO
ALL. BUT LIVABLE AS WELL. THANK
YOU ALL REMAIN AVAILABLE FOR
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISS
CHRISTY- BEFORE WE MOVE ON I
BELIEVE WE HAVE A QUORUM. I'M
MAD LIKE TO HAVE THE SECRETARY
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE. MEMBERS
RIVAS HI I MEAN HERE RIVAS HERE
FLOOR. ALREADY FLORES- CHAU
CHAU HERE FRIEDMAN GARCIA
MATHIS MCCARTY WROTE TO G. THEY
ARE STILL HERE CERTO HERE
STONE. STONE HERE WOULD HERE
WOULD HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM
THANK YOU SO NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. BELIEVE HE'S ON THE
PHONE. HELLO YES MY NAME IS
BILL PERSON LOOKING- THANK YOU
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE FOR
ALLOWING ME TO SPEAK TODAY- OUR
ORGANIZATION PEOPLE ORGANIZED
FOR WESTSIDE RENEWAL ARE OFTEN
NUMBER ACRONYM POWER WAS
FOUNDED IN NINETEEN NINETY NINE
TO USE COMMUNITY ORGANIZING TO
IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE FOR
LOW AND MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE
IN OUR COMMUNITY- AS YOU MIGHT
BE ABLE TO TELL FROM THE NAME
WE WERE FOUNDED IN THE WEST
SIDE OF LOS ANGELES AND THE
COMMUNITIES OF SANTA MONICA.
VENICE MARINA DEL REY AND SO WE
HAVE BEEN WORKING BASICALLY OUR
ENTIRE EXISTENCE- IN THE
COASTAL ZONE WITH LOW INCOME
AND MODERATE INCOME PEOPLE WHO
ARE FIGHTING PRIMARILY AGAINST
THE GENTRIFICATION AND THE
NEGATIVE IMPACTS ON LOW AND
MODERATE INCOME FAMILIES
BECAUSE OF THAT. BOB CINNAMON
ON IN THE COASTAL ZONE. THE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZING THAT WHAT
WE DO IS WE TRAIN EVERYDAY.
COMMUNITY MEMBERS TO
PARTICIPATE MORE DIRECTLY IN
THE DECISIONS THAT IMPACT THEIR
COMMUNITY TO UNDERSTAND WHO
MAKES THE DECISIONS AND TO TRY
TO MAKE INTERVENTIONS THAT ARE
STRATEGIC. AND ALLOW PEOPLE TO
SPEAK IN THEIR OWN VOICE AND
ADVOCATE ON BEHALF OF
THEMSELVES. IN THE PROCESS OF
SITING AROUND A LOT OF ISSUES
TO CREATE AND PRESERVE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING IN THE
COASTAL TOWN. ONE OF THE PLACES
THAT ARE MEMBERS OFTEN TESTIFY.
IS AT THE COASTAL COMMISSION
AND I CAN NOT. IMPRESSED ENOUGH
UPON YOU- YOU HAVE TO REALLY
SEE IT FOR YOURSELVES
UNDERSTAND. THAT KAFKA ESQUE
ABSURDITY OF PEOPLE WHO KNOW
THAT THE REASON THAT THEY'RE-
PRESENTING THEIR TESTIMONY ON A
SPECIFIC LAND USE APPEAL. THEY
CAN'T ACTUALLY SPEAK ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING OR IF
THEY DO SPEAK ABOUT
AFFORDABILITY OF HOUSING. THAT
THE COMMISSION ISN'T
TECHNICALLY ALLOWED TO LISTEN
TO THAT BECAUSE OF SECTION
THREE OH FIVE OH OH POINT ONE
SURE YOU HAVE THIRTY SECONDS
WELCOME. TO ROUND UP PLEASE. IT
YES. THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW- OUR
MEMBERS TO ACTUALLY SPEAK
DIRECTLY TO THE COMMISSION-
ABOUT THE ISSUES THAT ARE THE
MOST IMPORTANT TO THEM AND
MOTHER BECAUSE THE
COMMISSIONERS HAVE ALWAYS BEEN
RECEPTIVE TO OUR MEMBERS. AND
THE COMMUNITY- IT IS REALLY
IMPORTANT THAT PEOPLE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK DIRECTLY
TO THE ISSUES- THAT MOST OF
THAT MOST IMPACT THEIR LIVES
AND IN THIS PARTICULAR CASE
THIS BILL WOULD ALLOW THEM TO
DO THAT MORE OFTEN. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU- WE DO NOT HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION SO WE
WILL OPEN. ON THE PHONE LINES
FOR WITNESSES. IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- AND JUST WANT TO
REMIND EVERYONE CALLING IN TO
JUST PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THIS BILL- WE WILL LEAVE THIS
OPEN FOR FIVE MINUTES.
MODERATOR QUEUE PLEASE QUEUE
APPLIANCE. THANK YOU LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO WISH TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AND
WE WILL GO TO LINE NUMBER SIXTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
AGAIN LINE SIXTY NINE YOUR LINE
IS OPEN. WILL MOVE TO THE NEXT
LINE ONE MOMENT. NINE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
CYNTHIA REPLICA FROM OCEANIA IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE MOMENT.
NINE FIFTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING BLOODY FELLOW
MORALIS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR WITH
THE CENTRAL COAST ALLIANCE
UNITED FOR A SUSTAINABLE
ECONOMY LOCATED INVENTOR IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY IN SUPPORT
OF AB FIVE HUNDRED AND ALSO A
FORMER. MAYOR OF THE CITY APART
WHEN YOU NEED A COASTAL
COMMUNITY SH IN SUPPORT OF
EIGHTY FIVE HUNDRED THANK YOU.
MY NUMBER THIRTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS DEBBIE
MITCHELL WITH THE HARBORING
EACH COMMUNITY ALLIANCE OF
OXNARD AND VENTURA COUNTY AND
WE COMPORT AB FIVE HUNDRED.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ROBIN RUSSO I'M
A COASTAL ADVOCATE AND
PROTECTOR FOR TEN YEARS NOW I'M
A MEMBER OF SEVERAL LOCAL
ORGANIZATIONS INCLUDING POWER
CITIZENS PRESERVING VENICE AND
I'M AN ELECTED NEIGHBORHOOD
COUNCIL REPRESENTATIVE LOS
ANGELES BENEFIT MP GROW PLEASE
SUPPORT THIS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT BILL SO THAT THE
COASTAL COMMISSION CAN PROTECT
THIS COASTAL RESOURCE.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THANK YOU.
THANK YOU LINE EIGHTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THAT WAS LINE
EIGHTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
THANK YOU. SIMON LALONG ONE.
THANK YOU ONE MOMENT. NINE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS ANNA CHRISTENSEN
TODAY I'M REPRESENTING BECAUSE
OF THE WETLANDS PROTECTORS DOWN
HERE IN LONG BEACH- YOU JUST
HAVE A FEW CONCERNS ABOUT THIS
BILL- WHILE OF COURSE MA'AM DO
YOU NEED FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING
TAKE ANY NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. FOR ALL
CALL AND WE'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
DAY WHY I'M NOT NOT AT THIS
TIME. WHAT WILL WE BE ABLE TO
DO THAT LATER IN THIS HEARING-
WE ALREADY HAD WITNESSES THAT
TESTIFIED THAT REGISTERED AHEAD
OF TIME BUT AT THIS MOMENT
WE'RE TAKING- OF TESTIMONY AND
ONLY ACCEPTING NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL YOU'RE WELCOME TO DO THAT
ALL RIGHT WELL AT AT THIS POINT
DUE TO THE FACT THAT THE BILL.
ALLOWS PROJECT TO BE BUILT
WITHOUT COMMENTING ON CHAPTER
THREE POLICIES WE CANNOT
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE MOMENT. NINE
THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
THERE ARE NO OTHER LINES IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT THANK YOU
DO WE HAVE ANY THANK YOU
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE ANY WITNESSES THAT THE
REMOTE TESTIMONY I DON'T SEE
ANY- ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. MR STONE
THANK YOU THINK YOU RESTORED
FOR BRINGING THIS I THINK ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT PEOPLE DON'T
QUITE UNDERSTAND YOU TOUCHED ON.
IS THAT BECAUSE ONCE THE
ABILITY TO TALK ABOUT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING WAS REMOVED
FROM THE ACT. THEN AS
JURISDICTIONS ARE TRYING TO
DEAL WITH SHORT TERM RENTALS
WITH ANY OTHER WARDENS THE
COMMISSION IS ONLY LOOKING AT
THOSE POTENTIAL ORDINANCES
THROUGH THE LENS. OF ACCESS AND
VISITOR SERVING ACCOMMODATIONS
AND CANNOT BALANCE THE NEED FOR
LOCAL HOUSING. THIS IS WHAT.
THIS IS THE RIGHT APPROACH TO
GET THE COMMISSION TO
APPROPRIATELY CONSIDER. THE
IMPACT OF HOUSING ON A LOT OF
THE OTHER DECISIONS THAT THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS ARE MAKING.
IT WAS TOO BAD THAT THIS WAS
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM. BECAUSE
THAT THAT IMBALANCES REALLY
SHOWED OVER THE YEARS AS LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE TYING TO
PROTECT NEIGHBORHOODS TRY TO
PROTECT HOUSING. AND ESTABLISH
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING SO I
APPRECIATE THAT YOU BROUGHT
THIS I THINK IT'S ABSOLUTELY
THE RIGHT WAY TO GO. THANK YOU
SOME NUMBERS THAT I WITNESSED
AS WELL TOO WHEN I SERVED ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT THE LAST FOUR
YEARS AND- AND SO THIS IS AN
AUTHOR SPONSORED BILL I SEE TO
CORRECT THAT. THANK YOU FOR THE
TO MOVE WILL. THANK YOU. HAVE A
QUESTION. SMITH THANK YOU HAVE
A CERTAIN TRYING TO GET A GREAT
ON SOME OF THE MAYBE THE
COLLATERAL DAMAGE FROM HAVING
ANOTHER LAYER OF APPROVAL
PROCESS. AND MR STONE BROUGHT
UP A GOOD POINT IN THAT'S THE
COASTAL ACCESS POINT. OF I
GUESS MY QUESTION IS SO. IS
THIS BILL MEANT TO ALLOW THE
COASTAL COMMISSION TO SAVE THAT
TO THE BUNGALOWS THAT ARE ON
THE SIDE YOU KNOW ON YOU KNOW
IN EXISTING NEIGHBORHOODS.
BECAUSE THOSE BUNGALOWS EVEN
THOUGH THEY'RE SMALL IN
STATURE- THEY COME WITH A
MIGHTY PRICE TAG. SO NINETY
PRICE TAG IS UP YOU KNOW
SOMEBODY OWNS THAT AND ALTHOUGH
IT LOOKS LIKE IT COULD BE A-
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND DOLLARS
JACKETS ACTUALLY IF IT'S ON THE
STRAND IN MANHATTAN BEACH IT'S
A SIX MILLION DOLLAR PIECE OF
PROPERTY. AND WOULD THIS
RESTRICT THEM. WITH THIS MAKE
THEM HAVE TO GO THROUGH AND
PROVE THAT THEY'RE DOING SOME
OF THESE TO BE ABLE TO UTILIZE
THEIR LAND OR SELL THEIR LAND
IN LETTER DEVELOPER BUILD WHAT
THEY'RE GONNA BUILD THERE
BECAUSE- ALSO LAND ITSELF. IS
WHERE THE- THAT THAT'S WHERE
THE COST IS YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY
RIGHT AS A MEMBER C. R. DOES SO
THE ANSWERS ARE YES AND NO- IT
DOESN'T. SO NATURALLY OCCURRING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING SOME OF THE
OLDER STRUCTURES THAT ARE THERE
MIGHT STILL. BE AVAILABLE FOR
SLIGHTLY CHEAPER RENT BUT SO
SHOULD SOMEBODY WANT TO
REDEVELOP THE PROPERTY- THEY
THEY PROBABLY GOING TO BE DOING
SOMETHING THAT'S A LITTLE MORE
LUXURY LITTLE MORE HIGH VALUE.
WHAT THIS COULD ALLOW FOR IS
THAT CONVERSATION WITH THE
COASTAL COMMISSION IN ADDITION
TO THE LOCAL JURISDICTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE NET NUMBER
OF UNITS THAT WERE THERE THE
NATURALLY CURL FOR LOWER INCOME
OR LOWER RENTAL. PROPERTIES ARE
SOMEHOW RETAINED. I'M I JUST
FEAR THAT THE- PRICES AT THE
BEACH OUR OUR ON THE COASTAL.
SECTION OF THE STATE ARE ARE
SIMPLY OUT OF THE CONTROL OF
GOVERNMENT I THINK IT'S MORE OF
A MARKETING ISSUE- I DON'T
THINK THERE'S ANY WAY TO MAKE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AT IN THE
COAST AREA AND SO I'M NOT QUITE
SURE WHAT ADDING THIS LAYER- OF
PROCESS TO. MAKE EXISTING
DEVELOPMENT DOWN THERE IT'S
GOING TO HELP YOU KNOW THIS
SUBSIDY BUILDING AFFORDABLE
PROJECT DOWN THERE THERE'S GOT
TO BE HUGE. AND THEN WHEN YOU
GET PAST THE BUILDING COSTS AS
SOON AS THE THINGS THAT. YOU
KNOW THAT PROPERTY IS WORTH WAY
MORE THAN YOU BOUGHT IT EVEN IF
YOU DEED RESTRICTED I AGREE
WITH YOU THERE'S A LOT OF
MARKET BASED- CONSIDERATIONS
THAT GO INTO THE HOUSING-
HOUSING PRICING- BUT IT'S NOT
ALWAYS A SUBSIDY RELATED
SOLUTIONS THIS ALSO CAN BE ABLE
TO PROMOTE. SOME CONVERSATIONS
THAT OFFER INCENTIVE BASED
SOLUTIONS TO BE ABLE TO RETAIN
OR EVEN DEVELOP MORE MIXED
INCOME MIXED AFFORDABLE
HOUSING- IN ADDITION TO MARKET
RATE HOUSING. WELL THEY THEY
TAXPAYERS THAT SUBSIDIZE THAT
NEED TO GET THE BANG FOR THEIR
BUCK AND THEY'RE NOT GOING TO
GET AT THE COAST THAT'S WHAT
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT I SEE THE
WITNESS HAS. A POTENTIAL.
QUESTION ANSWERS TO MY QUESTION
WITH WITH THE CHAIR IN THE
AUTHOR'S PERMISSION ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SEATTLE. I'M THE AUTHOR
WOULD YOU LIKE HER TO CONTEST
THANK YOU WANT TO COME AND GO
HEAD ASSEMBLY MEMBER I WOULD I
WOULD LIKE TO NOTE THAT THE
COMMISSION IN ITS FIFTY YEAR
HISTORY HAS NEVER DENIED AN
AFFORDABLE HOUSING PROJECT. SO
I JUST WANT TO GET THAT ON
THERE FOR THE RECORD. BUT WE'RE
WE'RE THIS BILL. IF THE CALLS
ON IS PRIMARILY BUILT OUT NOW
IS. RECOGNIZE AND THERE'S A LOT
OF EXPENSIVE HOUSING THERE.
WHERE THIS BILL WOULD ACTUALLY
HAVE THE MOST BENEFIT TODAY IS
THAT IN THE LOCAL COASTAL
PROGRAMS THAT ARE PREPARED BY
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS THAT HAVE TO
BE CERTIFIED BY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. WHEN THEY'RE BEING
PREPARED OR WEIRD WHEN THEY'RE
BEING AMENDED. THOSE ARE THE
INSTRUMENTS THAT- DESIGNATE THE
ZONING AREAS THE DENSITY THAT
TYPE OF DEVELOPMENT THE VARIOUS
PROCESSES THAT HAVE TO BE- GONE
THROUGH IN ORDER TO GET YOUR
PERMITS. AT THAT STAGE RIGHT
NOW THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS
NO AUTHORITY. TO WORK WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO INCREASE
THAT AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR MAKE
THAT PROCESS MORE ACCESSIBLE TO
PEOPLE. BECAUSE WERE
SPECIFICALLY PROHIBITED FROM
EVEN CONSIDERING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IN THESE LAND USE PLANS
WHICH IS ABSURD. BECAUSE THE
COST LOOKS STATE OF CALIFORNIA
HAS MOVED FAR FAR BEYOND WHERE
THE COASTAL COMMISSION HAS BEEN
REQUIRED TO STAY. THIS WOULD
GIVE US ADDITIONAL SEAT AT THE
TABLE ADDITIONAL LEVERAGE IF
YOU WILL FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
THAT MAY NOT BE QUITE AS
COMMITTED AS WE WOULD LIKE THEM
TO BE TO PROVIDING AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. TO GET BETTER LAND USE
PLANS TO GET BETTER ZONING MAPS
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL. BECAUSE AT
THIS POINT IN CALIFORNIA. MOST
OF THE STATE MOST OF THE
COASTAL ZONE IS OPERATING UNDER
CERTIFIED LCP WE'RE NOT ISSUING
THE PERMITS ANYMORE. SO IT
WOULDN'T BE ANOTHER LAYER OF
BUREAUCRACY FOR APPROVAL IT
WOULD SIMPLY BE MAKING SURE
THAT THE NEW DEVELOPMENT THAT'S
GOING FORWARD. ACTUALLY REFER
REFLECTS THE LEGISLATURE'S
PRIORITY TO PROVIDE FOR MORE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. IN SOME OF
THESE LEAST AFFORDABLE AREAS I
BETWEEN LOCAL GOVERNMENT WHO-
THERE'D THERE OFFICIALS ARE
DIRECT OR- FOR THE PEOPLE TO
THE PEOPLE THAT LIVE THERE. IN
IN THEIR DISTRICT. AND BUT I
THINK THAT VOICE IS BETTER
HEARD BY THE PEOPLE THEY
REPRESENT THAT COMMUNITY. AND I
THINK THERE IS A LIMITED
ABILITY I USED TO LIVE DOWN AND
IN THE BEACH AREA THAT'S WHY
KNOW ABOUT MANHATTAN BEACH- BUT
THAT WAS WHEN I WAS YOUNG AND
SINGLE- I HAD MOVED INLAND. IF
I COULD AFFORD TO LIVE DOWN
THERE AND I NEVER DREAMED THAT
I'D BE ABLE TO AFFORD I DON'T I
CAN'T STILL. SO ANYWAY. THAT'S
A LIFESTYLE CHANGE YOU MAKE
BECAUSE OF THE IN AFFORDABILITY
OF BEING AT THE BEACH I DON'T
SEE HOW WE'RE GOING TO MAKE IT
MORE AFFORDABLE. AND I THINK
CITY COUNCILS NEED TO BE ABLE
TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT- IF
THEY'RE GOING TO I JUST DON'T
UNDERSTAND HOW THE COASTAL
COMMISSION. AND THE STATE
ENTERING INTO CITY COUNCIL
COASTAL CITIES ARE GOING TO
HELP FIX THAT WE'RE LOSING
DENSITY IN THE COASTAL ZONE
BECAUSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ARE
APPROVING DEVELOPMENT PROPOSALS
THAT ARE. THAT ARE DEMOLISHING
EXISTING DUPLEXES TRIPLEXES AND
FOUR PLEXUS THEY MAY NOT BE
CHEAP. BUT IN THE COASTAL ZONE
THEY ARE THE MOST AFFORDABLE
HOUSING THAT IS CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AND LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE APPROVING THEIR DEMOLITION.
AND REPLACING THEM WITH GIANT
STATEMENT HOMES SO WE'RE
ACTUALLY LOSING RESIDENTIAL
UNITS IN THE COASTAL ZONE
BECAUSE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS. CAN
APPROVE THAT UNDER THE MELLOW
ACT FROM FORTY YEARS AGO THERE
EXPRESSLY AUTHORIZED. TO
APPROVE THE DEMOLITION OF
EXISTING AFFORDABLE UNITS AND-
TAKE THEM OUT OF THE COASTAL
ZONE. THIS BILL WOULD ENABLE
THE COMMISSION TO STOP AT LEAST
TO STOP THAT FROM HAPPENING I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THERE ARE NO
EXISTING AFFORDABLE UNITS
ANYWHERE IN THE BAY AREA. AND
AND I ALSO ARGUED THAT IF WE'RE
LOSING A LITTLE BIT OF DENSITY
IN THOSE AREAS THAT WOULD HELP
TRAFFIC A WHOLE LOT. BECAUSE
THERE'S H. EXTREME AMOUNT OF
TRAFFIC IN THOSE AREAS. IT'LL
TAKE YOU THREE HOURS TO GET
FROM SANTA MONICA DOWN. TO
REDONDO BEACH SO. ANYWAY- I
I'VE I'VE HEARD IT REFERRED
WHAT I NEED TO HEAR AND I. YOUR
EFFORTS THANKS. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS MR STONE YEAH I
WOULD JUST LIKE TO CLARIFY THIS
IS ACTUALLY A MAJOR TOOL FOR
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE
TO DEAL WITH AFFORDABLE HOUSING
IN THEIR LOCAL COASTAL PROGRAM.
BECAUSE ONCE AT THE L. C. P. IS
TO GO TO WITH THE COMMISSION IT
BECOMES THE STANDARD OF REVIEW.
IF THE L. C. P. AND THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS CANNOT ACCOUNT
FOR AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND DO
THE THINGS IT NEEDS TO DO
DEALING WITH. WITH THE SHORT
TERM RENTALS DEALING WITH A
MYRIAD OF THINGS THAT LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS ARE DEALING WITH
ALONG THE COAST MY JURISDICTION
CASE IN POINT WE DO HAVE SOME
AFFORDABILITY. WHEN PEBBLE
BEACH VERY VERY HIGH END WANTED
TO BUILD SOME. SOME HOUSING
THERE WAS A DESPERATE NEED FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT WAS
ACTUALLY BUILT IT TO THAT
PARTICULAR PROJECT SO THAT
BECAUSE OF THE WILLINGNESS OF
PEBBLE BEACH AND THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY REALLY PUSHING ON IT
THIS BILL WILL FACILITATE
EXACTLY THAT CONVERSATION SO
WE'RE REALLY MISSING THE POINT
HERE. IF WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
HOW THE COMMISSION INTERACTS
WITH LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HOW
ELSE HE PEES ARE CREATED. AND
THAT THE AMOUNT OF CONTROL THAT
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS HAVE OVER
THOSE DECISIONS THIS IS A BILL
THAT GIVES THEM. THE BREADTH OF
THAT CONTROL DEALING WITH
HOUSING AND DEVELOPMENT THAT
WILL IMPACT HOUSING IN THEIR
JURISDICTIONS THAT'S WHY THIS
IS A GREAT BILL. WORKFORCE
HOUSING AND COAST ARMENIAN
AREAS THAT ARE MORE-
RECREATIONAL- AND TOURIST-
DRIVEN- IS A LITTLE DIFFERENT
FROM AFFORDABLE HOUSING FOR YOU
AND ME. AND LIVING IN ASSEMBLY
BELIEVE HE'S ONLY I UNDERSTAND
THAT YEAH I KNOW AND I KNOW YOU
DO IT I. FEEL THAT'S WHY THIS
BILL IS SO IMPORTANT. FOR
COASTAL JURISDICTIONS LIKE MY
RIGHT AND CITY SHOULD BE ABLE
TO GRAPPLE WITH THAT
RESPONSIBILITY I THINK THAT
THIS IS NOT SOMETHING YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THIS
ALLOWS THEM TO DO THAT. OKAY
THANK YOU. I OTHER. FROM
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE MY STORE MANAGER
AND STAFF THANK YOU FOR
SCHEDULING THIS BILL FOR
HEARING TODAY- I WANNA ALSO
KNOWLEDGE FOR THE- THE- THE
CALLER FROM LONG BEACH OR
ANYBODY ELSE THAT HAS QUESTIONS
OR CONCERN ABOUT THIS BILL
THEY'RE WALKING TO CALL MY
OFFICE I'M HAPPY TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THOSE CONCERNS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST- I DON'T.
THANK YOU I'M WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MR STONE. WE NEED A SECOND
FROM MISTER WOULD- SECRETARY Q.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T
WANT AB FIVE HUNDRED BY MEMBER
BOARD. THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFER TO HOUSING AND COMMUNITY
DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE. MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVAS FIVE FLORA. CHAU
CHAU I FRIEDMAN GARCIA MATHIS
MCCARTY WROTE TO G. SAY OUR
TOTAL. THERE ARE NO STONE STONE
I WOULD. I FOR ONE K. FOUR ONE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I'M NEXT UP WE HAVE-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER ARAMBULA
PRESENTING AB. THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
PROGRAMS HAVE BEEN ESSENTIAL IN
REDUCING HIV HEPATITIS C. AND
OTHER INFECTIOUS DISEASES IN
CALIFORNIA FOR DECADES. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL
PROTECT THESE VITAL SERVICES BY
PROVIDING THESE PROGRAMS AND
EXEMPTION FROM SEQUEL
REQUIREMENTS. WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED A RISE IN DRUG
RELATED HARMS INCLUDING
OVERDOSE DEATHS HEPATITIS C.
DIAGNOSIS RATES AND INCREASED
RATES OF POTENTIAL HIV
TRANSMISSION IN CALIFORNIA AND
THE REST OF THE UNITED STATES.
ACCESS TO STERILE SYRINGES
REDUCES HIV AND VIRAL HEPATITIS
INFECTIONS WHILE BEING SAFE
EFFECTIVE AND COST SAVINGS.
CALIFORNIA SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS PROVIDE A WIDE RANGE
OF SERVICES IN ADDITION TO
SYRINGE ACCESS AND DISPOSAL
INCLUDING HIV AND HEPATITIS
TESTING OVERDOSE PREVENTION
TRAINING AND REFERRALS TO DRUG
TREATMENT HOUSING AND MENTAL
HEALTH SERVICES. THESE SERVICES
HAVE HELPED TO GARNER THE TRUST
IN PEOPLE WHO WOULD NOT
OTHERWISE SEEK OUT HARM
REDUCTION SERVICES. BUT
RECENTLY UNEXPECTED LEGAL
CHALLENGES HAVE ARISEN. DESPITE
THE CLEAR LANGUAGE OF THE
STATUTE THAT THIS SECTION IS TO
OPERATE NOTWITHSTANDING ANY
OTHER LAW ONE COURT IN ORANGE
COUNTY HAS AN INTERPRETED
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS AS
PROJECTS SUBJECT TO THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL
QUALITY ACT. BECAUSE THE
PROGRAM COULD NOT DEMONSTRATE
THAT I COLLECTED ALL THE
SYRINGES THAT IT DISTRIBUTED
SUBSEQUENTLY. THE PROGRAM WAS
FORCED TO SHUT DOWN. ANOTHER
PROGRAM IN BUTTE COUNTY HAS
BEEN FORCED TO RESEND IT CDPH
APPROVED APPLICATION IN THE
FACE OF SIMILAR LITIGATION.
ADDITIONALLY A SIMILAR LAWSUIT
HAS BEEN FILED AGAINST A
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAM IN
SANTA CRUZ AND EARLY TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. WE MUST BE REMINDED
THAT THERE IS AN URGENT NEED TO
EXPAND SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS IN OUR STATE IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS OUR LOOMING OPIOID
PUBLIC HEALTH EMERGENCY. DURING
THE PANDEMIC THERE HAS BEEN A
SHARP INCREASE IN OVERDOSE
DEATHS AS EVIDENCED BY THE CDC.
THE NEED FOR ACCESS TO SYRINGES
AND OTHER SERVICES PROVIDED BY
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS IS
NOW GREATER THAN EVER. THESE
TYPES OF SUITS ARE AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW REQUIRING SEACOR REVIEW
OF PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAMS
IMPROPERLY PLACES DISEASE
PREVENTION AND ENVIRONMENTAL
PROTECTION AT ALL IT'S- WITHOUT
A MEDIA LEGISLATIVE ACTION THE
PUBLIC HEALTH PREVENTION
SERVICES PROVIDED BY THE
SYRINGE EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
DIRECTLY AUTHORIZED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH WILL BE CURTAILED. AND
NEW PROGRAMS WILL BE DETERRED
AT THE PRECISE TIME WHEN THE
NEED FOR THEM IS INCREASING. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WILL HELP
PROTECT CALIFORNIANS FROM THE
RAPID SPREAD OF HIV. HEPATITIS
OR ANY OTHER POTENTIALLY DEADLY
OR DISABLING INFECTIONS THAT
ARE SPREAD THROUGH THE SHARING
OF USED NEEDLES AND SYRINGES BY
PROTECTING THESE VALUABLE
COMMUNITY BASED SYRINGE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS. I AM JOINED
TODAYBY WITNESS MERRY SEE
ALLAH SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
THE DRUG POLICY ALLIANCE AND DR
PETER DAVIDSON A UC SAN DIEGO
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR OF
INFECTIOUS DISEASE AND GLOBAL
PUBLIC HEALTH. THANK YOU
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE PHONE LINES FAR WITNESSES
WILL START WISHING MERRY SILVA.
HI THANK YOU CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES AND I JUST WANT TO REMIND
YOU THAT- YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO PROVIDE YOUR TESTIMONY. YEAH
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERRY FELLOW AND SENIOR STAFF
ATTORNEY AT THE DRUG POLICY
ALLIANCE. I'M HERE TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR ON BEHALF OF THE CO
SPONSORS OF THE BILL THE DRUG
POLICY ALLIANCE THE NATIONAL
HARM REDUCTION COALITION. AND
ASSEMBLY BILL GATES FOUNDATION.
WE COME TOGETHER TO SPONSOR THE
BILL TO PROTECT HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAMS WHICH ARE FUNDAMENTAL
STEVEN OVERDOSE PREVENTION IN
CALIFORNIA. I HE GROUP VIEW
PUBLIC PRODUCTS THANK YOU SB.
I'M NOT. PLACES DID YOU PREVENT.
AND ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION
ADALAT. URGE YOU TO PROTECT THE
INTEGRITY OF THE CLOCK AND
STOPPING NEAT USED TO ATTACK
PUBLIC HEALTH PROGRAM. BY
PASSING AB THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE I'M HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THE
COMMITTEE EMBERS MAY HAVE.
ABOUT THE LEGAL OR PUBLIC
HEALTH PRACTICUM BENCHES
TECHNICAL SUPPORT. THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT
WITNESS. GOOD MORNING I'M
DOCTOR DAVIDSON I'M AN
ASSOCIATE PROFESSOR IN THE
DEPARTMENT OF MEDICINE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA SAN
DIEGO. I'VE BEEN CONDUCTING
PUBLIC HEALTH RESEARCH ON HANDS
TO FUNCTION IN THE DRUGS FOR
ALMOST TWENTY FIVE YEARS
ORIGINALLY ANNA STRATTON SINCE
TWO THOUSAND HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
NEEDLE EXCHANGES A
CONTROVERSIAL IDEA WHEN IT WAS
FIRST PROPOSED TO THE PUBLIC
HEALTH RESPONSE TO HIV BACK IN
THE EIGHTIES. AND SO IN THE
DECADE SINCE WE'VE CONDUCTED AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF RESEARCH TO
TEST WHETHER IT TOO CHEAP TO
CONTEND THE NAMES. AND TO
ENSURE THAT IT WASN'T PRODUCING
UNINTENDED NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES TO THE GO TO
COMMUNITY. BECAUSE OF ALL THIS
RESEARCH WE NOW KNOW THAT
NEEDLE EXCHANGE DOES REDUCE HIV
HEPATITIS AND OTHER BLOOD BORNE
VIRUSES. I KNOW THE PEOPLE WHO
USE DRUGS WHO HAVE ACCESS TO
NEEDLE EXCHANGE INTO DRUG
TREATMENT SOONER THAN PEOPLE
INTERNET ACCESS NEEDLE EXCHANGE
AND ENSURE THE DRUGGIES AD
CORREA'S. WE KNOW THAT LAW
ENFORCEMENT AND COMMUNITIES
WITH NEEDLE EXCHANGE HAVE LOWER
RATES OF NEEDLE STICK INJURIES.
WE KNOW THAT NEEDLE EXCHANGES
OF THE MOST EFFECTIVE WAY TO
DISTRIBUTE NALOXONE THE PEOPLE
USE DRUGS AND THAT DOING SOIS
ASSOCIATED. WITH REDUCTIONS IN
OVERDOSE DEATHS. AND
PARTICULARLY TO THIS COMMUNITY
YEAH COMMITTEE AND SEE
EXTENSIVE RESEARCH CONDUCTED TO
SEE WITH THE NEEDLE EXCHANGE IS
ASSOCIATED WITH INCREASES ON
STREET JUST GOT A NEEDLE. WE
NOW HAVE DECADES OF RESEARCH
WHICH IS BEING DONE HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. ACROSS THE UNITED
STATES AND AROUND THE WORLD
WHICH CONSISTENTLY SHOWS THAT
NEEDLE EXCHANGES STATISTICALLY
ASSOCIATED WITH REDUCTIONS IN
THE STREET DISCARDED NEEDLES.
NOT INCREASE ITS- NEEDLE
EXCHANGE AS PART OF THE
SOLUTION TO ST THIS. COULD HAVE
MAILED NOT PART OF THE PROBLEM.
TO GIVE THIS REASON EXAM FROM
THE LITERATURE THE TWENTY
ELEVEN STUDY COMPARING MIAMI
AND FLORIDA WHICH DID NOT HAVE
NEEDLE EXCHANGE WITH SAN
FRANCISCO HERE IN CALIFORNIA
WHICH HAS COMPREHENSIVE NEEDLE
EXCHANGE. SO THAT THEY WERE
EIGHT TIMES THE NUMBER OF
STREET DISCARDED NEEDLES THE
THOUSAND CENSUS BLOCKS IN MIAMI
COMPARED TO SAN FRANCISCO. WHEN
PEOPLE USE DRUGS DO NOT HAVE
ACCESS TO NEEDLE EXCHANGE AND
REDUCE SINEAD O'CONNOR OFTEN
AND WHEN THEY DISCOUNT OF MY DO
SO IMPROPERLY. THEY ARE JUST
MENTION RENTALS. ON THIRTY
SECONDS THANK YOU TO WRAP UP.
YES IN THIS STUDY I JUST
MENTIONED 95% OF PEOPLE USE
DRUGS IN MIAMI WITH ANOTHER
NEEDLE EXCHANGES RECORDED
DESCRIBING THE LAST NAY LED
USED ON THE STREET RIGHT THIRTY
FOUR TIMES HIGHER THAN IN SAN
FRANCISCO. DECADES OF EVIDENCE
SHOWS THAT NEEDLE EXCHANGES AND
EFFECTIVE WAY TO REDUCE ST
DISCOUNTED NEEDLES I HAVE NO
NEGATIVE IMPACT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT AND THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD STREAM SUPPORT
STREAMLINING THE PROCESS OF
THEIR AUTHORIZATION ESPECIALLY
IN A LOT OF THE WORK STRUGGLING
WITH US CRISIS NOT STATE'S
HISTORY. THANK YOU THANK YOU
SIR- NEXT WE HAVE TO WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. I HAVE BOB TIED
KIMMEL SHOE BUTTE COUNTY
SUPERVISOR. AND ROBERT BERRY
FROM ROB BERRY LAW. HE JUST
TAUGHT HIM SHE CAN YOU HEAR ME
YES PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY THANK
YOU VERY MUCH- GOOD MORNING
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I WOULD LIKE TO REFER
YOU TO A LETTER FROM BUTTE
COUNTY. AS OF MARCH TWENTY
THIRD TWENTY TWENTY ONE BUTTE
COUNTY OPPOSES ASSEMBLYBILL
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR WHICH SEEKS
TO EXEMPT CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH AUTHORIZED TO
REMAIN FIXED. EXCHANGE PROGRAMS
FROM THE CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL QUALITY ACT SEE
WHAT IT WAS MORE THE ONLY TOOLS
THAT CITIZENS HAVE TO SEEK- IT
BERMAN BY MENTAL HARM AND IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT THE CD P. H.
RECOGNIZED THE HARM. ONCE THE
SYINGES USED. TO INJECT
ILLICIT DRUGS THAT IS
IMMEDIATELY BECOME PROHIBITED
PARAPHERNALIA KNOWING THAT'S
MANY USERS IMMEDIATELY DISCARD
THEIR SYRINGES AFTER THEIR USE
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE WORK
THE SUPPLY OF NEW SYRINGES. IS
UNLIMITED AND FREE NEEDLE
LITTER IS AN UNAVOIDABLE
CONSEQUENCE OF LOOSELY
REGULATED DRUG PARAPHERNALIA
DISTRIBUTION PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY THOSE WHICH HAVE NO
REQUIREMENT TO POOR EXCHANGE
USED NEEDLES FOR CLEAN ONES.
WELL CDPH SEEKS. TO EXEMPT
THEMSELVES FROM THE
CONSEQUENCES THE DANGER TO THE
PUBLIC REMAINS FAMILIES WITH
YOUNG CHILDREN MUST NOW WORRY
ABOUT THE DANGERS OF POTENTIAL
NEEDLE STICKS WHEN VISITING
PLAYGROUNDS PARKS AND
WATERWAYS. ONE OF MY ONE OF THE
MOST SOLEMN OBLIGATIONS OF
GOVERNMENT AT EVERY LEVEL IS TO
PROTECT THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
OF ITS CITIZENS. AND TO ENSURE
THE ENVIRONMENT REMAINS
PRISTINE AND LITTER FREE AS
POSSIBLE. AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR WE BELIEVE IS UNWISE ON
CONTRARY TO THE WIDELY HELD
TRADITIONAL PUTTING
ENVIRONMENTAL PROTECTION AT THE
FOREFRONT. OF WISE PUBLIC
POLICY FOR THOSE REASONS BUTTE
COUNTY URGES YOU TO VOTE NO ON
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR AND AGAIN JUST. TO
REITERATE DISCARDED NEEDLES ARE
BARTON APARTMENT. WE NEED AND
SYRINGES ARE LEADERS
DISTRIBUTED IN EASY TO OBTAIN
THEIR DISCARDED THOSE ITEMS
NEEDLES AND SYRINGES END UP IN
PARKS WATERWAYS PLAYGROUNDS IN
OUR STREETS WORKING THROUGH THE
STATE I THINK WHAT. WHAT PART
THAT. KEEP UP YES I WILL THANK
YOU WORKING TO SEE WHAT
PROGRESS. OR- FOR ANYONE WHO
WANTS TO DISTRIBUTE NEEDLES IS
OUR ONLY PROTECTION THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO-
PARTICIPATE TODAY. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS. MY NAME IS
BRADBURY AND I'M ONE OF THE
ATTORNEYS THAT BROUGHT THE
LAWSUIT AND BUTTE COUNTY THAT
WAS REFERRED TO EARLIER. THE
INTENDED PURPOSE OF THE ACCORDS
EQUAL LEGISLATION IS TO
FACILITATE INFORMED LAND USE
DECISIONS BY IDENTIFYING
ANALYZING AND MITIGATING
DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS OF PROJECTS
ON THE ENVIRONMENT. WHEN A
STATE AGENCY CAN IGNORE SEQUEL
ENTIRELY AS WAS THE CASE IN
CHICO. NEARLY SUFFERS THE REBEL
HARM TO THE ENVIRONMENT AND
THEIR SAFETY. AS A RESULT OF
THIS DISREGARD FOR THE
INTERESTS OF THE GENERAL PUBLIC
COMMUNITIES WE ACTUALLY AGAINST
THESE PROGRAMS AS DID DID SHE
GO SERVICE. INSTEAD OF WORKING
WITH COMMUNITIES TO MITIGATE
THEIR CONCERNS THE STATE
PRECEDED UNMOVED BY PUBLIC
SENTIMENT. IN RESPONSE OUR
STUDENTS TO ISSUED AND THEN
SETTLEMENT. DEPARTMENT PUBLIC
HEALTH RELUCTANTLY AGREED TO
WITHDRAW THEIR PROGRAM APPROVAL
AND IN A BINDING SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT CONCEDED THEY MUST
COMPLY WITH SEQUEL FOR ALL AND
ANY PROGRAMS APPROVED IN THE
FUTURE. EVEN WITH THAT PROMISE
EVERY CITY AND TOWNSHIP IN
BUTTE COUNTY HAS NOW ENACTED
LOCAL ORDINANCES WHICH BANNED
SUCH PROGRAMS OUTRIGHT BY USING
THEIR LAND USE POWERS TO
DISALLOW THE USE AND TO DECLARE
SUCH PROGRAMS A PUBLIC
NUISANCE. SUCH A STRONG
REACTION FROM CITIZENS IS IT
REFLECTIVE OF THE HARMS THAT
THEY SUFFERED. OTHER THAN WORK
WITH COMMUNITIES TO MITIGATE
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS AS REQUIRED
UNDER SPEAK WHERE THEY NOW SEEK
TO PERMANENTLY OVER POWER THE
WILL OF LOCAL JURISDICTIONS BY
PURSUING EXEMPTIONS FOR
THEMSELVES FOR THE VERY LAWS
THIS LEGISLATURE HAS PASSED. TO
PROTECT THE ENVIRONMENT NOW AND
FOR FUTURE GENERATIONS. THE
ONLY WAY TO ESTABLISH
SUSTAINABLE THIS IS SYRINGE
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS IN LOCAL
COMMUNITIES IS TO ENSURE THAT
SUCH PROGRAMS ANY AGENCIES
WHICH APPROVED THEM REMAIN
ACCOUNTABLE TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE PUBLIC FOR
PRESENT AND POTENTIAL FUTURE
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS. THIS IS
COMPLETELY CONSISTENT WITH THE
FUNDAMENTAL PURPOSE OF SEQUELS.
AND FOR THESE REASONS AND MORE
WE OPPOSE THIS AMENDMENT
ENTIRELY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU. I'M NEXT WE WILL-
TAKE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES-
PLEASE JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL- WE ARE ACCEPTING
ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY OF ANY
LANE- VIA OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE
AT A. N. T. R. DOT ASSEMBLY.
DOT CA DOT GOV AND WE WILL HAVE
THE PHONE LINES OPEN- FOR UP TO
FIVE MINUTES. MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINES. YES
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION OR SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. ALL START
WITH LINE NINETY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LINE NINETY EIGHT
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NO RESPONSE.
THE NEXT LINE IS. SEVENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR TO BATON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF EMERGENCY PHYSICIANS IN
SUPPORT. ONE MOMENT PLEASE.
NINE ONE SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
THINK MANY ROBERT HARRIS ON
BEHALF FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SOCIETY OF ADDICTION MEDICINE
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. FIND ONE HUNDRED AND
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE CHEN
MEMBERS IMPACT FROM THE ACLU OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
TURN OFF OTHER LINES IN SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE CONTINUE
THANK YOU. I DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
YES OKAY PLEASE GO AHEAD PLEASE
STATE NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL SIR. A
RECOVERING ADDICT WITH SIXTEEN
YEARS CLEAN IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN THE-
VIDEO CONFERENCING K. C. NINE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MR STONE THANK
YOU THIS ARAMBULA NEW WE WE'VE
CHATTED ABOUT THIS IT'S-
ALTHOUGH PART OF ME SHOULD BE
HEARTENED WITH THE SUPPORT
WE'RE HEARING FOR SEQUEL- THE
PROBLEM IS WHAT THE UNDERLYING.
AND NOW THIS REALLY IS THE
PROJECT AND I HAVE NOT
SUPPORTED SECRET EXEMPTIONS
I'VE TALKED TO MY- LOCAL
ADVOCATES ABOUT THIS I'M NOT
GOING TO SUPPORT THE SEQUENCE
AND CHANGE EITHER BECAUSE TO ME
IT'S NOT ABOUT THE UNDERLYING
PROJECT. IT'S ABOUT
UNDERMINING. THE LAW THAT THAT
WE HAVE PUT IN IN PLACE AND I
THINK THERE. OUR OTHER WAYS FOR
FACILITATING NEW EXCHANGE
PROGRAMS IN OUR COMMUNITIES
WHICH ARE VERY VERY IMPORTANT I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU ON
THAT. SO I'M SORRY BUT I'M NOT
SUPPORTING IT TODAY BUT THAT'S
WHY. MISTER WHAT THANK YOU
DOCTOR REGULAR I KNOW WE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THIS A LOT- I JUST
YOU KNOW I I'M A BIG SUPPORTER
OF SEQUENCE WELL BUT I DO TAKE
OFFENSE THAT SEEK WAS BEING
USED TO UNDERMINE PROJECTS LIKE
THIS I THINK THAT ARE IMPORTANT
I WILL NOTE FOR AND- THAT
LEAGUE OF CITIES REMOVED THEIR
OPPOSITION R. C. R. C. REMOVED
THEIR OPPOSITION- IT I JUST
THINK THAT THERE ARE TIMES WHEN
CITIES ARE THERE DO YOU DOING
THIS TO ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATE
NEEDLE EXCHANGE PROGRAM TONIGHT
I THINK THAT'S WRONG. SO I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD. MR MCCARTY. YEAH I
THINK YOU- AT FIRST I WALKED IN
I THOUGHT DOCTOR WOULD THAT NOT
A WE HAVE HELPED ME TO GET. IS
THIS IS THIS IS A HEALTH- TOPIC
I KNOW WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
IN PART HELPED ME IN. AND LIKE
IN SACRAMENTO I REMEMBER WE
JUST I WAS ON THE IS IT WAS
VERY CONTROVERSIAL AND IT IT
IT'S BEEN WORKED OUT FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH BUT ACROSS THE STREET
LEVEL IN THE COUNTY THAT THEY
WON'T ADOPT LITTLEST CHANGE AND
IT'S NOT BECAUSE OF SEE BECAUSE
BECAUSE OF THEIR CONSERVATIVE.
POLITICS SO I APOLOGIZE TO THE
CHERUB MISSED THE FIRST FEW
MINUTES OF THIS PRESENTATION
ARE THERE DID YOU GIVE EXAMPLES
OF JURISDICTIONS THAT THAT
DENIED A NEEDLE EXCHANGE
FACILITY AND YOU CAN WE CAN
POINT THAT SICK ONE WAS WAS WAS
WAS THE ISSUE. WE HAD MENTIONED
EARLIER THAT CURRENTLY ORANGE
COUNTY HAD BROUGHT A LAWSUIT
FOR SEACOR WE HAD MENTIONED AS
WELL ABOUT BUTTE COUNTY AND HOW
SANTA CRUZ HAS A LAWSUIT WHICH.
BEGAN IN EARLY TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. SO ON THE JURIST. THE THAT
THE CITY OR THE COUNTY APPROVED
A NEEDLE EXCHANGE FACILITY AND
IT WAS BLOCKED BECAUSE OF THE
SEQUEL LAWSON. IN THOSE
JURISDICTIONS THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH HAD
APPROVED THE- SYRINGE EXCHANGE
PROGRAM IN THOSE LOCAL
MUNICIPALITIES- WEAPONIZED
SEACOR- AND ALSO HAD IF I COULD
ADD A LAYER REGARDING SINCE-
EARLIER WE HEARD FROM THE
BUTTE. COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS REGARDING THEIR
MARCH TWENTY THIRD LETTER BUT
IT DID NOT COMMENT ON THE
AMENDMENTS. THAT WE TOOK ON
APRIL EIGHTH WITHIN COMMITTEE
THAT BIFURCATED THIS BILL AND-
ALLOWED FOR THE NUISANCE
PROVISIONS TO CONTINUE AND US
WE HEARD THEIR TESTIMONY STATE
THAT IT WAS THE- ONLY TOOL THAT
WAS AVAILABLE AND IN REALITY I
BELIEVE THEY- STILL HAVE
LITIGATION AND OPPORTUNITIES
TO. PURSUE WHAT THE LOCALS ARE
SEEKING RIGHT NOW. OKAY THANKS.
MR TELL. ARE JUST A FOUGHT JUST
FOLLOW UP QUESTION TO MR
MCCARTHY'S THE LINE OF
QUESTIONING- THE PROGRAM HAS
BEEN AROUND FOR SO LONG HOW WE
JUST SEEN THESE LAWSUITS- IN
THE LAST COUPLE YEARS. THAT'S
CORRECT. SHE WAS ABLE TO FIX.
GIPSON OKAY. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH THAT'S OKAY- WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THIS ROOM THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE OKAY. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MR WEBB SECONDED BY MR
MCCARTY. SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I DON'T TO AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR BY MEMBER
ARAMBULA MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA NO CHAU
CHOW I FRIEDMAN. GARCIA MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY MCCARTY I
MURATSUCHI SAY ARCHER. STONE
STONE NOW WOULD WOOD I. FOUR
THREE FOUR THREE I WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN THANK YOU MR ARAMBULA
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR NEXT UP
WE HAVE- ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
PRESENTING AB. THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX DUREX CARB TO REQUIRE ZERO
EMISSIONS FROM NEW SMALL OFF
ROAD ENGINES. SOLD IN
CALIFORNIA ON OR AFTER TWENTY
TWENTY FOUR. SMALL OFF ROAD
ENGINES OTHERWISE NOT A SORE
OUR ENGINES THAT PRODUCE TWENTY
FIVE HORSEPOWER LESS. THEY'RE
MAINLY USED IN LAWN AND GARDEN
EQUIPMENT SUCH AS LEAF BLOWERS
AND LAWN MOWERS. AND OTHER
OUTDOOR POWER EQUIPMENT. GALLON
FOR GALLON THAT THESE ENGINES
POLLUTE AT A SUBSTANTIALLY
HIGHER RATE THAN OTHER
EQUIPMENT AND VEHICLES.
OPERATING A COMMERCIAL LEAF
BLOWER FOR ONE HOUR IMAGE
POLLUTION COMPARABLE TO DRIVING
A TWO THOUSAND SEVEN TOYOTA
CAMRY ONE THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
MILES. TO PUT THAT IN ANOTHER
WAY ONE HOUR OF A COMMERCIAL
THE FLOOR EMITS AS MUCH
POLLUTION AS DRIVING A TWENTY
SEVENTEEN CAMERI FROM
SACRAMENTO. ACROSS NEVADA AND
UTAH TO DENVER COLORADO. IN
FACT IN TWENTY TWENTY ONE DALY
EMISSIONS FROM SMALL ENGINES
ARE PROJECTED TO SURPASS THOSE
FROM PASSENGER CARS. BY TWENTY
THIRTY ONE EMISSIONS FROM SORE
WILL BE MORE THAN TWICE THOSE
FROM PASSENGER CARS. THESE
EMISSIONS WORSEN AIR QUALITY IN
BECAUSE DIRECT NEGATIVE HEALTH
IMPACTS INCLUDING ASTHMA AND
LUNG DISEASE. JUST THINK ABOUT
THE HEALTH IMPACTS ON
LANDSCAPING PROFESSIONALS WHO
BREATHE IN THESE FUMES DAY IN
AND DAY OUT. THE GOOD NEWS IS
THAT ZERO EMISSION VERSIONS ARE
AVAILABLE FOR ALL OF THE
EQUIPMENT IN THE SMALL ENGINE
CATEGORY CURRENTLY REGULATED BY
THE CALIFORNIA AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. THE CARD IS REGULATED
EMISSIONS FROM THIS CATEGORY
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY. THIS
BILL BRINGS THE EMISSION
STANDARD TO WHERE IT NEEDS TO
BE ZERO. IT'S IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT APPLY
TO ACQUIT MINORITY IN USE SO IF
YOU HAVE A GAS POWERED LEAF
BLOWER YOU CAN KEEP USING IT.
IT ONLY BANS THE SALE OF NEW
GAS POWERED STORE ON OR AFTER
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. I ALSO WANT
TO KNOW THAT FARMING
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT ARE
PREEMPTED UNDER THE FEDERAL
CLEAN AIR ACT AND NOT SUBJECT
TO THIS BILL OR CARD
REGULATIONS. ABOUT HALF OF
HOUSEHOLDS HAVE ALREADY
SWITCHED TO ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT. BUT IT WILL TAKE
MORE TO TRANSITION COMMERCIAL
OPERATORS TO ZERO EMISSIONS. TO
THAT END AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
REQUIRES CARP TO MAKE FUNDING
AVAILABLE FOR LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS TO OFFER COMMERCIAL
REBATES. TO HELP LANDSCAPERS
PURCHASE ZERO EMISSION
EQUIPMENT. SEVERAL AIR
DISTRICTS LIKE SOUTH COAST IN
VALLEY AIR ALREADY OFFERS SUCH
REBATE PROGRAMS. AND
INSTITUTIONS LIKE THE CITY OF
SOUTH. PASADENA HAS
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION TO
FULLY ZERO EMISSION LANDSCAPING.
ZERO MISSION EQUIPMENT IS IN
THE SAME PRICE RANGE AS GAS
EQUIPMENT AND WILL ACTUALLY
SAVE MONEY OVER THE LIFE OF ITS
USE. THAT DOESN'T REQUIRE THE
PURCHASE OF GAS RICH FUEL IT'S
QUIET AND MOST IMPORTANTLY IT
DOESN'T EMIT OZONE FORMING
POLLUTANTS THAT ADVERSELY
AFFECT HUMAN HEALTH. THE
COUNTRY TO CLIMATE CHANGE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE ON AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX.
AND- WITH ME ARE BILL MCGOVERN
WITH THE COALITION FOR CLEAN
AIR AND WILLIAM BEAR IT WITH
THE AMERICAN LUNG ASSOCIATION.
TESTIFYING VIA PHONE. THANK
YOU. OUR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
OUR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
SLICKNESS IS TRYING TO. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
BILL MCGAVIN WITH THE COALITION
FOR CLEAN AIR IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. SMALL
GASOLINE POWERED ENGINES LIKE
LAWN MOWERS AND LEAF BLOWERS
AND SMALL GENERATORS. HAVE BEEN
REGULATED FOR YEARS BY THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD- BUT THOSE
REGULATIONS ARE NOW OUTDATED.
AND SAID YOU HEARD FROM MR
BERMAN AND I'LL REPEAT THIS
BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A STUNNING
FACT. HE EMISSIONS FROM THESE
SMALL OFF ROAD ENGINES WELL
ACTUALLY SURPASSED ALL THE SMOG
FORMING EMISSIONS FROM CARS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THIS
YEAR. AND THAT SHOWS HOW
IMPORTANT THIS BILL IS THE- IT
EXISTING ENGINES HAVE ALSO
SHOWN HIGH FAILURE RATES IN
EVAPORATIVE EMISSIONS TEST.
WHICH PREVENTS THE PREVIOUSLY
CLAIMED EMISSION REDUCTIONS
FROM BEING REALIZED SO IT'S
TIME TO MOVE THE SALES OF NEW
EQUIPMENT IN THIS CATEGORY TWO
ZERO MISSION AND THERE ARE MANY
ZERO EMISSION PRODUCTS
AVAILABLE THAT USE EITHER
BATTERIES. OR THEY CAN PLUG IN.
THE BILL IS CRAFTED TO WORK
WITH THE ALREADY ONGOING
REGULATORY PROCESS- WHICH I'VE
BEEN PARTICIPATING AND I AND I
CAN VOUCH THAT THAT PROCESS
ALLOWS FOR EXTENSIVE PUBLIC
PARTICIPATION. AND
DELIBERATION- SO YOU MIGHT ASK
THE REGULATORY PROCESS IS
ALREADY GOING ON WHY DO WE NEED
TO FILL. WELL EXPERIENCE SHOWS
THAT HAVING A STATUTORY MANDATE
BRING CERTAINTY TO RULEMAKING
AND- WE'VE SEEN SUCCESSES MANY
TIMES OVER THE YEARS WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE HAS DIRECTED YEAR
RESOURCES BOARD. TO ENACT WILL
MAKING IN A CERTAIN AREA AND
GIVES THEM A STATUTORY
DEADLINE. AND AT THE SAME TIME
DELEGATES TO THE BOARD THE
FLEXIBILITY TO SETTLE THE
DETAILS AND EXAMINE THE
TECHNOLOGICAL FEASIBILITY OF
THE RULE. SO WE THANK THE
AUTHOR AND ASKED THE COMMITTEE
TO APPROVE THE BILL THIS
MORNING. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
NEXT WITH US IN SUPPORT PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING I'M WILL BARRETT
ON THE DIRECTOR. ALSO SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT THIS MORNING. THE
MISSION OF THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IS TO SAVE LIVES BY
IMPROVING LUNG HEALTH AND
REDUCING LUNG DISEASE THE SMALL
OFF ROAD ENGINE CATEGORY IS
PROJECTED TO HAVE AN
INCREASINGLY LARGE ROLE IN REAL
WORLD LONG HEALTH IMPACTS AND
THAT THIS IMPACT WILL CONTINUE
TO GROW OVER THE COMING DECADE.
WITHOUT ACTIONS LIKE THAT
BUSINESS BILL. AMONG SUCH
PATIENTS TWENTY TWENTY ONE
STATED AIR REPORT. RELEASED
LAST WEEK FOUND THAT SEVEN OF
THE TEN MOST OZONE POLLUTED
CITIES. IN THE UNITED STATES OR
IN CALIFORNIA. RESIDENTS IN
NEED COMMUNITIES CAN EXPERIENCE
NEARLY A MONTH TO OVER FIVE
MONTHS OF UNHEALTHY AIR ON AN
ANNUAL BASIS. EXPOSURE TO AIR
POLLUTION CAN HAVE A WIDE RANGE
OF NEGATIVE HEALTH OUTCOMES
INCLUDING ASTHMA ATTACKS. HEART
ATTACKS AND STROKES LUNG CANCER
AND PREMATURE DEATH. CHILDREN
OLDER ADULTS AND PEOPLE LIVING
WITH CHRONIC CONDITIONS-
ESPECIALLY HEART AND LUNG
DISEASES. ARE MORE SUSCEPTIBLE
TO THE HEALTH IMPACTS OF AIR
POLLUTION. OUTDOOR WORKERS LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES PEOPLE OF
COLOR ALSO FACE GREATER RISKS
AND OFTEN FACE DISPROPORTIONATE
EXPOSURES TO UNHEALTHY AIR. AND
THEIR ASSOCIATED NEGATIVE-HEALTH OUTCOMES. THAT
CALIFORNIA'S POLICIES HAVE
REALLY SUCCEEDED IN DRIVING
DOWN REGIONAL AIR POLLUTION. WE
KNOW THAT THE INVENTORY OF
POLLUTION SOURCES WILL CONTINUE
TO SHIFT. THAT THOSE HARD
FOUGHT POLICIES- HAVE TAKEN
EFFECT. AND CLEAN UP OTHER
SECTORS. AT- EIGHT THIRTY FORTY
SIX REALLY READ. THE GROWING OF
THE SORT. WHAT A LONG HELD AND
RECALL CAR TO DIE- THE TOP COST.
AND FEASIBLE REGULATE. REALLY
REFLECTING THE WIDESPREAD
AVAILABILITY AND ZERO EMISSION
TECHNOLOGIES TODAY. AND THEN-
TO YOU KNOW MOVES FORWARD AND
MAKING SURE THAT- CARBS
IDENTIFYING AND THAT RING TO
MAKE FUNDING AVAILABLE TO
SUPPORT THIS CRITICAL
TRANSITION. FOR NEW ENGINES TO
MOVE TO ZERO EMISSIONS AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE. THE
LEGISLATION BEFORE YOU
ADDRESSES THE GROWING THREAT TO
LONG HEALTH AND WE URGE DR
BODEN THANK THE AUTHOR. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINES.
WOULD YOU LIKE ME TO GIVE
INSTRUCTIONS ON THE PHONE YES
PLEASE ANYONE ELSE'S SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES PLEASE. IF YOU
ARE IN SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND ZERO WE'LL GO TO LINE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
NIKITA CROWDY WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. MY NUMBER
ONE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI LAUREN COMMON HAVE A
SPHERICAL CAL CORNER SUPPORT OF
THE THIRTY FORTY THANK. IN
SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
THIS IS BILL MURPHY ON BEHALF
OF THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY
IN ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE SIXTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING SHARON MEMBERS AARON
RODRIGUEZ TO THE UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE ONE
FORTY TO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MORNING SHARE MEMBERS PRISCILLA
CHAOS ON BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
ACTION COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THERE ARE NO FURTHER LINES
AND IN SUPPORT PLEASE CONSIDER
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WAS LIKE WE
HAVE ONE INDIVIDUAL IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE
LANCASTER GREG NOT. GOOD
MORNING MY NAME'S GREG ADAM
WITH THE OUTDOOR POWER
EQUIPMENT INSTITUTE OPI IS
INTERNATIONAL TRADE ASSOCIATION
REPRESENTING MORE THAN ONE
HUNDRED MANUFACTURERS AND THEIR
SUPPLIERS OF GAS AND ELECTRIC
POWERED OUTDOOR POWER
EQUIPMENT. OPI MEMBERS PRODUCTS
ARE UBIQUITOUS IN CALIFORNIA
HOUSEHOLDS AND BUSINESSES
INCLUDING EQUIPMENT SUCH AS
LAWNMOWERS CHAINSAWS AND
PORTABLE GENERATORS. OPI AND
ITS MEMBERS HAVE BEEN COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH LEGISLATORS AND
REGULATORS TO DEVELOP
REASONABLE REGULATORY LANDSCAPE
FOR MORE THAN THREE DECADES. AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SECOND CARDS
RECENT PARALLEL POTENTIAL RULE
POSE NUMEROUS TECHNOLOGY
FEASIBILITY ECONOMIC AND
IMPLEMENTATION CHALLENGES FOR
INDUSTRY STAKEHOLDERS
COLLECTIVELY THESE CHALLENGES
ARE INSURMOUNTABLE AND WILL
RESULT IN SIGNIFICANT HARDSHIPS
FOR MANUFACTURERS RETAILERS AND
END USERS CULMINATING IN EARLY
MARKETS SHORTFALL OF PRODUCTS
WITH HIGH CONSUMER AND
COMMERCIAL NEED AND DEMAND. AS
A RESULT INDUSTRY GROUPS OPPOSE
BOTH AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX AND
CARBS POTENTIAL WILL. CONCLUDE
WITH OPI APRIL TWENTY SEVEN
COMMA COMMISSION ARE COMMENTS
MADE BY MULTIPLE STATE INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDER GROUPS IN
OPPOSITION TO CARB. REACHED
RECENT PROPOSAL INCLUDING THE
TRUCK AND ENGINE MANUFACTURERS.
PORTABLE GENERATOR
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION AT
ALL NATIONAL LANDSCAPE
PROFESSIONALS ASSOCIATION TREE
CARE INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION IN
CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR CALL.
IT INDUSTRY CONCERNS CULTURE
FREE BE THIRTEEN FORTY SIX
WHICH CLOSELY NEAR CARBS THREE
SUPER BOWL. SPECIFIC INDUSTRY I
DON'T MANY WITH BOTH CAR STAFF
ONE HE BEAT THEIR. FORTY CARBS
OR MODELING SIGNET- ASK THIS
THE CONTRA. AS A RELATES TO A
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX OPI BELIEVE
SECTION ONE. ONE POINT TWO
WHICH IS SHOWS THAT WILL. A KEY
CARD THIS YEAR IS ANYTHING
ACCURATE. SORT WITHOUT OR OF
THE SORE MISSIONS IN. PRICKLES
THE BAND SAW ARBOR. AND BY THE
FEDERAL AIR ACT WHICH CAL REAL
ON A DOCTOR THE COMMISSION'S
REGULAR. SECOND CORPS RECORD
NAY ABOUT HIM ZERO EMISSIONS
FOR. USE AND STAFF APRIL
APPEALING MARC TWENTY FOUR
POINT. ONE PER. REGULATIONS TO
ACHIEVE NEEDED EMISSIONS
REDUCTION POWER HE BE THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX IN THE ABSENCE OF AN
ACTOR CONDITIONS REFLECTION
CONTRIBUTION AND WITHOUT MARK
IMPROVED MARKET PROVEN
SOLUTIONS ACROSS THE WIDE RANGE
OF TODAY'S SOLAR POWER
EQUIPMENT END USE TYPE. IS AN
ARBITRARY APPROACH AS A RESULT
OPI OPPOSES AB THIRTEEN FORTY
SIX THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH WE'RE GONNA GO BACK TO
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM I FORGOT TO
ASK THERE'S A MILLION CHAMBER
THAT WAS GONNA SUPPORT. AB AT
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX C. NINE. SEE
NOBODY IN SUPPORT OF VIDEO
TESTIMONY WILL GO BACK
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM ANYBODY
IN OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX. IN THE CHAMBER.
SCENE NINE SEE KNOWN IN
OPPOSITE- WE'LL SEE NO
OPPOSITION IN THE COMMITTEE
ROOMS WILL BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE. I WAS REGARDING THE
MISTER WOULD. THANK YOU THAT
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO MAKE A
MOTION ON THIS BILL. I JUST
WANT TO- TALK TO THE AUTHOR I
KNOW THAT HE'S THOUGHT ABOUT
THIS AND WAS VERY DELIBERATE
AND THOUGHTFUL ABOUT THIS
ISSUE. AND THAT THIS WAS A VERY
CONTROVERSIAL WHEN I WHEN THIS
WAS PROPOSED TWENTY FIVE YEARS
AGO I REMEMBER THAT. IT WAS
THAT A DEBATE WERE ON THE FLOOR
OF ONE OF THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S
OF THE TIME MISTER CAR DOES NOT
CONGRESS MEMBER I REMEMBER HE
BROKE DOWN IN TEARS. TALKING
ABOUT HOW HIS DAD- WAS A- A
GARDENER AND HE WAS GONNA HAVE
HIS TOOLS ESSENTIALLY TAKEN
AWAY FROM HIM BECAUSE THAT
WOULD HAVE BANNED THEM. ON DAY
ONE AND SO WHAT YOU'RE
PROPOSING HERE IS VERY
DIFFERENT AND MORE IMPORTANTLY.
THE INDUSTRY HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY IN THE LAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS- SO I DON'T THINK
THIS IS THAT AND REASONABLE I
KNOW THERE WAS LATE OPPOSITION
THAT CAME I THINK JUST TWO DAYS
AGO YESTERDAY SO- WE HAVEN'T
REALLY HEARD FROM PEOPLE THE
OUTCRY LIKE WE DID TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO. AND JUST THIS
WEEKEND I WAS IN THE HOME DEPOT
STORE AND I KNEW ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I WAS LOOKING ON THE
SHELF. AND THE PRICE OF THESE-
ELECTRIC BLOWERS HAS GONE DOWN
AND WE'RE MAINLY TALKING ABOUT
BLOWERS I KNOW. THERE'S
CHAINSAWS AND LAWNMOWERS AND
OPENNESS TO WOOD TALKS ABOUT
CHAINSAWS A LOT UP IN CERTAIN
PARTS OF THE STATE WHICH ARE
NEEDED BECAUSE OF OTHER ISSUES
BUT- THE BIGGEST ISSUE WE FACE
IN OUR COMMUNITIES ARE THE LEAF
BLOWERS IN THE NEIGHBORHOODS
AN THAT'S WHAT IMPACTS. AND
NEIGHBORHOODS THE QUALITY OF
LIFE BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY. THE
HEALTH OF THE WORKERS. THEY TWO
THINGS. ONE I SAW THIS ON THE
SHELF IN IN HOME DEPOT THE
POWER OF THESE LEAF BLOWERS HAS
GONE UP TREATMENT YOU'RE
TREMENDOUSLY I THINK IT'S THE
CF AT WHATEVER THE HORSEPOWER
WHAT HAVE YOU. AND I AND I I'M
A ROBOT ONE ABOUT A YEAR AGO
WAS LIKE WELL THIS IS ALMOST
LIKE A GAS CARD ONE AND- THE
PRICE WAS NOT THAT MUCH WHAT'S
THE PRICE IS MUCH LOWER THAN A
GAS WANTS TO BE LOOK AT BUYING
ONE OF THESE PLUS BUYING AN
EXTRA BATTERY PACK OR TWO. IT'S
ALMOST THE EQUIVALENT OF THE
COST FOR- AND- I GUESS ONE AND
YOU WANT WITH THE GAS ONE
YOU'RE PAYING GAS OF COURSE
HERE YOU'RE NOT PAYING FOR GAS
YOU SAVE MONEY AND HAVE THE
ELECTRIC BUT I DON'T THINK IT
WOULD HAVE A TREMENDOUS IMPACT
ON THE QUALITY AND I'M
UNDERSTANDING IS YOU'RE GOING
TO HAVE THERE IS SOME TYPE OF A
REBATE PROGRAM THAT CARP YOU
TALK ABOUT THAT ONE YET SO WHAT
WHAT WE DO- WHAT THE BILL DOES
IS- THE ME FIND THE DETAILS- SO
REQUIRED. CARD TO MAKE FUNDING
OF A- SO DISTRICTS RAMP UP
COMMERCIAL REBATE PROGRAMS TO
HELP BUSINESSES TRANSITION TO
ZERO EMISSION EQUIPMENT- AND
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT'S- IN THE
BILL THAT ISN'T. IN CARBS
PROPOSED REGULATION SO THAT'S
SOMETHING UNIQUE TO THE BILL
AND WHY THE BILL IS SO
IMPORTANT- AND WHAT THAT IS
UPDATING SOME OF THE- REBATE
PROGRAMS THAT CARD HAS. TO
ALLOW FOR MORE USES INCLUDING A
LOT OF THESE GAS. ELECTRIC
POWERED STORE. EQUIPMENT THAT
CURRENTLY ISN'T. IT DOESN'T
QUALIFY FOR CERTAIN REBATE
PROGRAMS AND THE CALL MORE YOUR
PROGRAM- UNDER CARBS SO.
SOMEWHERE DISTRICTS IN THE
BIGGEST OR DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE. CENTRAL VALLEY- THE LA
THE SOUTH THE SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA- DISTRICT ALREADY
PROVIDE STRONG REBATE PROGRAMS
FOR COMMERCIAL USE. AS WELL AS
RESIDENTIAL USE WE WANT THEM
ALL. TO PROVIDE A STRONG REBATE
PROGRAMS FOR COMMERCIAL USE AND
SO THAT'S THE FOCUS OF THE
BILL. YEAH BUT THAT I THINK ALL
THE ELEMENTS ARE THERE- TO
ADDRESS WE'RE AT TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO I THINK IT'S TIME SO
THANK YOU. PRESIDENT THANK YOU.
.ORG THANK YOU- APPRECIATE
APPRECIATE THE INTENSE LOOK I
HAVE A- ELECTRIC LAWNMOWER HAVE
AN ELECTRIC LEAF BLOWER HAVE AN
ELECTRIC CAR SO- CLEARLY I
UNDERSTAND- THE CONCERN AROUND
EMISSIONS- I DO- WONDER. THESE
REBATE PROGRAMS THAT YOU'RE
ASKING FOR. I GUESS YOU'RE THE
BILL'S GOING TO COMMAND- CARD
TO DO THIS- WILL THAT BE HOW
THOSE BE DONE WILL THAT BE
SUBJECT TO- THE ENVIRO SKIN.
WHERE WHERE PEOPLE IN MY
DISTRICT WHERE WE HAVE GOOD AIR
QUALITY DON'T QUALIFY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS- OR- OR IS THIS GOING
TO BE. A STATEWIDE PROGRAM. AND
WILL THERE BE LIMITED FUNDING.
OVER THE B. A LOT OF FUNDING.
BECAUSE I WORRY- BUT IN IN MY
DISTRICT- CHAINSAWS ARE REALLY
IMPORTANT WAY OF LIFE FOR A LOT
OF FOLKS WE'RE WE'RE MANDATING-
WE'RE NOT MANDATING WORSE WE'RE
TRYING TO ENCOURAGE PEOPLE TO
DO MORE HOME HARDENING- AND-
TAKE CARE. THAT DEPRESSION
VEGETATION THEIR HOME AND- I
WILL SAY THAT WELL I DO ENJOY
MY ELECTRIC LAWN MORE MY
LOGICALLY BLOWER- THE CHALLENGE
IN SOME AREAS IS GOING TO BE RE
CHARGING THOSE. BATTERIES
ESPECIALLY IF YOU'RE A
COMMERCIAL OPERATOR I DON'T
KNOW WHERE YOU RECHARGE YOUR
BATTERIES AND THE DAY UNLESS
YOU HAVE. YOU KNOW A BUNCH OF
BATTERIES- TO BE ABLE TO DO
THIS SO. SO FIRST QUESTION IS.
WILL WILL OF THESE REBATES BE
AVAILABLE STATEWIDE FOR- NOT
JUST COMMERCIAL BUT-
CONSUMERS'S WELL. WHEN WILL
THEY BE SUBJECTED TO THE ENVIRO
CARE- AND THEN SECONDLY- ARE
THERE ARE YOU LOOKING AT WOULD
YOU CONSIDER ANY SORT. OF-
RURAL CO CONSIDER. FOR THIS I
UNDER LOOK I AROUND THE CAPITAL
HERE IN THE MORNINGS AND- AND I
HATE THOSE LEAF BLOWERS MAN I
JUST HATE THEM I HATE THE DUST
THEY PUT UP AND I HATE THE
EMISSIONS AND I THINK. I WORRY
ABOUT THE WORKERS. BUT I LIVE
IN A DIFFERENT WORLD. SO I HAVE
TO GET BACK ON THE CALAVERAS
SCREEN COMPONENT BECAUSE I'M
NOT I'M NOT THAT INTIMATELY
FAMILIAR WITH WITH WHETHER YOU
KNOW IT IS THE APPLICATION OF
THAT IS MY UNDERSTANDING IS
THAT MOST THESE REBATE PROGRAMS
FALL UNDER THE DIFFERENT AIR
QUALITY DISTRICTS- THE
DIFFERENT REGIONAL AIR QUALITY
DISTRICTS SO- BUT AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX MAKES INCENTIVE
FUNDING AVAILABLE BY REQUIRING
CARP TO UPDATE FUNDING
GUIDELINES. FOR APPLICABLE
PROGRAMS TO SEVERAL LOCAL AIR
DISTRICTS OFFER ROBUST
COMMERCIAL AND RESIDENTIAL
REBATE PROGRAMS FOR LANDSCAPING
EQUIPMENT BUT WE WANT TO BUILD
ON THAT PROGRESS BY REMOVING
BARRIERS THAT RESTRICT LOCAL
AIR DISTRICTS ABILITY TO FIND
INCENTIVE PROGRAM SO LIKE I
MENTIONED A SECOND AGO. THE
CARL MOYER PROGRAM FUNDING
GUIDELINES ARE RESTRICTIVE AND
OUTDATED CURRENTLY ONLY LAWN
MOWERS FOR RESIDENTIAL USE ARE
ELIGIBLE FOR FUNDING IT'S ABOUT
REQUIRING CARD TO UPDATE THESE
GUIDELINES TO INCLUDE
COMMERCIAL APPLICATIONS FOR
SMALL FOR SORE. THIS WILL FREE
UP FUNDING FOR AIR DISTRICTS TO
OFFER AND EXPAND COMMERCIAL
REBATE PROGRAMS. TO HELP
LANDSCAPING PROFESSIONALS. THIS
IS YOUR OMISSION. SO I CAN GET
YOU A LOT MORE INFORMATION.
KIND OF. POST POST HEARING ON
EXACTLY WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE
AND WHETHER OR NOT. CALAVERAS
CAN APPLIES I'D SIMILAR YOU
HAVE. CONCERNS ABOUT CALAVERAS
SCREEN. AND ITS IMPACT IN MY
DISTRICT- BUT- YEAH THIS IS
THIS REALLY DOES. YOU WITH THE
WE BELIEVE THAT THIS ONE LOOK A
LOT MORE FUNDING FOR THESE
REBATE REBATE PROGRAMS
ESPECIALLY ON THE COMMERCIAL
SIDE A LOT OF- YOUR DISTRICTS
ALREADY HAVE THE FUNDING ON THE
RESIDENTIAL SIDE- THE REBATE
PROGRAMS ON THE RESIDENTIAL
SIDE. AND THEN I DON'T KNOW IF
I ANSWERED ALL YOUR QUESTION I
GUESS AND THEN JUST THE ONE
ABOUT ONE OTHER ONE AND LOOK
I'M I'M I'M NOT GONNA I'M NOT
GONNA BE ABLE TO SUPPORT YOUR
BILL TODAY WITHOUT THAT BECAUSE
OF BECAUSE OF THAT LACK OF
INFORMATION BUT- BUT ALSO- WE
HAVE A LARGE- ROBUST TIMBER
INDUSTRY IN MY DISTRICT AND
THEY RELY ON THESE MOTORS TO-
FOR LARGE SCALE- FOR LARGE
SCALE CHAINSAWS AS PART OF. NOT
JUST TO CUT THE TREES DOWN BUT
ALSO TO LIMB THEM UP AND SO ON
SO- I EIGHT IF YOU'RE OUT IN
THE IF YOU'RE OUT IN THE FOREST
WHICH MIGHT BE TEN MILES OFF OF
A ROAD SOMEWHERE- DOES THIS
BILL APPLY TO THOSE THOSE-
THOSE BUSINESSES AS WELL IT
WILL IT FOR CHAINSAWS-
CHAINSAWS OVER OR FORTY FIVE CC
ARE. PREEMPTED AND SO I THINK A
LOT OF THE CHAIN SAWS ARE USED
IN THE TIMBER INDUSTRY OR MUCH
MORE HEAVY DUTY. CHAIN SAWS
WHERE THIS WOULD NOT APPLY TO
THEM FOR THE SMALLER CHAIN SAWS
IT IT WOULD- AND YOU KNOW WHAT
WITH IF YOU BUY AN ELECTRIC
CHAINSAW PLUS ADDITIONAL
BATTERIES TO GET YOU THROUGH
THE DAY. OVER THE LONG RUN
YOU'RE GOING TO SAVE MONEY ON
BUYING A GAS POWERED CHAINSAW
HAVING TO USE GAS CONSTANTLY
THOSE CHAINS AUGUST MARCHING
SILVA THE END AND GUESTS
ARTICLE IN BREAK DOWN MORE
OFTEN. YOU HAVE TO YOU KNOW THE
MAINTENANCE ON THEM- SO YEAH IT
WOULD APPLY TO CHAIN SAWS UNDER
FORTY FIVE CC THE SMALLER
CHAINSAWS NOT FOR AND I KNOW
YOU AND I HAVE TALKED ABOUT
THIS BEFORE. NOT FOR
FIREFIGHTING EQUIPMENT. THAT IS
ALL COMPLETELY EXEMPTED- BUT
FOR THE TIMBER INDUSTRY WHAT-
SO ALL. SIX EQUIPMENT LIKE LIKE
LIKE YOU KNOW CAL- FOLKS HAVE
TO REMOVE TREES AFTER A STORM
THOSE KINDS OF THINGS AS WELL.
OR JUST FIRE FIGHTING- YEAH I
DO MY NOTES SAY FOR SAFETY
PURPOSES- BY GROUPS LIKE
CALIFORNIA'S ALL TO CHECK IN ON
CALTRANS AND OTHER YOUNG YEAH
THE DEPARTMENT- BUT LIKE I SAID
I COMPLETELY APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO FOR SURE ALSO
ALSO WILL SAY WE ALSO POWER
SAFETY SHUT OFF PROBLEMS IN MY
DISTRICT SO THAT'S A PROBLEM TO
RECHARGE YOUR BATTERIES WHEN
YOU DON'T HAVE POWER AS A MUCH
BIGGER BILL I'M LOOKING FOR TO
SUPPORTING YOUR BILL WHEN YOU
WHEN YOU TACKLE THAT THANK YOU
MR BERMAN THINGS DOCTOR WOULD.
MISTER THANK YOU MR CHAIR-
EIGHT I UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO GO WITH THIS BUT- ON
ME. THANK YOU ANA A LITTLE
HISTORY TRIP OF A LUXURY NOT MY
GROWING UP BRIGITTE THAT SO I
GREW UP THE PICTURES IN IN THE
MOUNTAINS WELL FOUR THOUSAND
FEET MY FIRST JOB WAS PUTTING
UP THE A SIGN ON THE MAILBOX
SAYING YOU KNOW ALL ALL HELP
CLEAR PROPERTIES WILL CUT FIRE
LINES WILL DO THIS SO. MY FIRST
JOB WAS USING THIS EQUIPMENT. A
LITTLE HONDA ONE TEN THREE
WHEELER WITH A TRAILER ON THE
BACK. WITH WITH MY BLOWER AND
MY CHAIN SAW IN THE WEEDEATER
AND MEANING TOOLS AND
EVERYTHING YOU CAN THINK OF
THEY THE YOU WOULD NEED. TO BE
OUT ON THE COUNTRY SIDE CLEAR
FIRE LINE. TO TAKE CARE OF A
FARMER RANCH WITH WHATEVER. I
CAN DO TO MAKE A BUCK THIS IS A
TEENAGER. THERE IS NO WAY. THAT
I WOULD BE ABLE TO DO THAT.
UNDER YOUR BILL. I WOULD HAVE
TO CARRY A GENERATOR AROUND
WITH ME TO CONSTANTLY CHARGE
THESE BATTERIES IS IT AS I WENT
ALONG. BECAUSE YOU'RE YOU'RE
NOT GONNA BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO
BUY ALL THESE PLUS AS THEY SET
OUT IN THE SUN THE BATTERIES
WEAR OUT ANYWAY. SO YOU HAVE
THAT. MY OTHER CONCERN ON ON ON
THE NATIONAL RESOURCES IN ON
THIS IN AN EXPRESSION OF OUR-
MIDDLING. WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO
WITH ALL THESE. EXTRA ADDED
BATTERIES IS THE DEPLETE NAGEL
THAT. WHAT ARE WE GONNA DO WITH.
THE THIS EQUIPMENT BECAUSE THE
LIFESPAN ON A BATTERY OPERATED
ANYTHING- THEY THEY TEND TO
BURN OUT QUICKER THEY DON'T
LAST AS LONG I STILL HAVE SOME
OF THE WE TWO YEARS I HAD.
TWENTY YEARS AGO. THAT ARE UP
AND RUNNING. SO THEY'RE NOT
ENDING UP IN A IN A LANDFILL OR
DUMP OR SOMEWHERE ELSE
SOMEWHERE. THAT THEY'RE STILL
UP AND RUNNING. SO I UNDERSTAND
THE SHORT LIFESPAN. ISSUE WITH
THE FEW AMENDMENTS AND WHERE
YOU'RE GOING WITH THAT BUT WE
CAN'T JUST LOOK AT THE SHORE
SIDEDNESS OF THESE THINGS.
ESPECIALLY ON ENVIRONMENTAL
CONCERN WE HAVE TO LOOK AT THE
LIFESPAN. HOW LONG IS THIS
PRODUCT GOING TO LAST. IS IT A
FIVE YEAR PRODUCT IN THIS IS
BURNED OUT I GOTTA GO BUY
ANOTHER ONE. AND ANOTHER ONE
AND ANOTHER ONE AND ANOTHER ONE
IN THE IN THESE GUYS OVER HERE
GET RICH. SELLING GREEN ENERGY
BLOWERS. OR DO I BUY THAT
HEARTY. TWO STROKE THIS GOING
TO LAST ME THIRTY YEARS. IN IN
IN I KNOW THAT PRODUCT'S GOING
TO LAST I KNOW IT'S GOING TO DO
THE JOB AND I KNOW I'M NOT
GOING TO BRING THE ENGINE SO
THAT THOSE ARE CONCERNS THAT I
HAVE I HAVE TO A LOT OF THE
SAME CONCERNS AS DR WHAT'S-
WITH MY RURAL COMMUNITIES WHO
GET THE POWER OUTAGES TO GET
THE ROLLING BLACKOUTS WHO DON'T
HAVE ACCESS TO THESE OTHER
THINGS. NOW THIS FOR THIS
PROGRAM MY WORK GREAT IN THE
CITY. BUT THE AIR QUALITY IS
ALSO DIFFERENT IN IN YOUR BILL-
TO DIVE A LITTLE MORE INTO
DOCTOR WHICH QUESTIONS. IF YOUR
AIR DISTRICTS GOOD YOUR PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO QUALIFY FOR THESE
PROGRAMS. AND FRANKLY A LOT OF
THE PROGRAMS THAT WE HAVE
THINGS THAT YOU'VE ALREADY
MENTIONED LIKE KARL MOYER IN
THESE OTHER THINGS I KNOW VERY
FAMILIAR WITH BECAUSE I WORKED
WITH GOVERNOR BROWN. WHEN WE RE
DID CAP AND TRADE TO ENSURE
FUNDING FOR KARL MOYER IN THESE
OTHER PROGRAMS. THOSE ARE
ALREADY SHORT ON FUNDS. SO WE
HAVE THESE BIGGER MORE LARGE
SCALE THINGS THAT ARE ACTUALLY
GONNA CARRY MORE WEIGHT. IN
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL GOOD WITH OUR
CARBON.NEUTRAL GOALS. IN
FRANKLY I. GET WHERE YOU'RE
TRYING TO GO MAN. BUT BUT I
THINK THIS IS JUST IT'S NOT A
BIG ENOUGH THING. IT'S GOING TO
CAUSE A LOT OF EXTRA
ADMINISTRATIVE WORK. OF AND
SUCK UP A LOT MORE FUNDS THAN
IT'S GOING TO BE WORTH. I THINK
WE NEED TO LOOK AT BIGGER
PICTURE THANKS IF WE'RE GONNA
GET OUR STATE TO MORE CARBON
NEUTRAL AREA. IN IN WE'VE GOT A
LOOK AT THE LIFESPAN OF THESE
THINGS BECAUSE IT'S REALLY EASY
TO THINK LIKE OKAY WE'RE GONNA.
TAKE ALL THESE LITTLE ENGINES
OUT. COOL WHERE DID THEY GET IN
UP IN A LANDFILL AND THEY'RE
GONNA DEEPLY THE GROUNDWATER
AND WE'RE GONNA HAVE OTHER
PROBLEMS. SO INTEL WE CAN. LOOK
AT ALL OF THOSE AND LOOK AT
SOMETHING BIGGER PICTURE THAN
JUST A SMALL ENGINE I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS. BUT IT BUT I DO
APPRECIATE YOUR WORK THANK YOU
THANK YOU MISTER MATHIS I
REGRET NOT HAVING TAKING NOTES-
LET ME TRY TO. ADDRESS A COUPLE
OF THOSE POINTS OF VERSES AS
MUCH AS YOU AND I. LIKE TO FEEL
LIKE WE'RE VERY YOUNG- WE GOT A
LITTLE BIT OLDER. AND THE
TECHNOLOGIES CHANGED SINCE YOU
WERE OUT THERE ON THE RIDGE-
WITH YOUR WITH YOUR THREE
WHEELER AND THE TRAILER WITH
THIS EQUIPMENT AND THE
EQUIPMENT IS CHANGE
DRAMATICALLY- AND MISTER BERMAN
I'M I'M FAMILIAR WITH THAT
BECAUSE I'M ALSO ONE OF TWO
MEMBERS OF THE HUNDRED TWENTY
THAT TOOK THE TIME. TO GO TO
THE DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY SCHOOL
FOR LEGISLATORS. AND I HAVEN'T
SEEN YOU ON THAT LIST SO I'M
VERY FAMILIAR WITH THE
TECHNOLOGY AND- I APPLAUD YOU
FOR THAT COMMITMENT MY FRIEND.
THANK YOU FOR DOING THAT ON
BEHALF OF THE OTHER HUNDRED AND
EIGHTEEN OF US. THE IT'S
IMPORTANT TO NOTE THAT. THE
FARM EQUIPMENT. CONSTRUCTION
AND FARM EQUIPMENT IS FEDERALLY
PREEMPTED. IT'S SO IT'S SO
THAT- YOU KNOW YOU SHOULD THAT
SHOULD HOPEFULLY ADDRESS SOME
OF THE CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE.
IF YOU BY LIKE YOU SAID I THINK
A CHAINSAW THAT'S GONNA LAST
THIRTY YEARS. YOU CAN KEEP
USING IT FOR THIRTY YEARS. MY
BILL DOES NOT BAN YOU FROM
USING ANY GAS POWERED
EQUIPMENT. THAT YOU BUY BEFORE
TWENTY TWENTY FOUR OR AFTER
ONCE CARBON. MAKES THE
REGULATIONS- SO. YOU KNOW IF
YOU'RE REALLY WORRIED ABOUT
THAT THAN A TWENTY TWENTY
THREE. YOU CAN STOCK UP AND USE
THAT STUFF UNTIL UNTIL YOU'RE
WELL INTO YOUR RETIREMENT
YEARS- THAT YOU CAN. TAKE THE
BATTERIES BACK TO. I MEAN YOU.
LIKE OR A- BIT. LIKE HOME D.
FOR A PSYCH. OF THE BATTERIES
YOU MENTIONED. I HOPE BONTA
BUNCH OF PEOPLE MAKE A WHOLE
LOT OF MONEY. THE SAME
COMPANIES THAT MAKE THE GAS
POWERED EQUIPMENT ALSO MAKE THE
ELECTRIC POWERED EQUIPMENT SO
IT'S THE SAME COMPANIES-
WHETHER YOU BOUGHT A GAS
POWERED OR THE ELECTRIC- BUT I
PUT IT IN AND YOU KIND OF TRY
TO MINIMIZE. THE IMPACT OF
STORE EMISSIONS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT. I THINK. I LOOK
FORWARD TO HAVING MORE
DISCUSSIONS WITH YOU ABOUT
EXACTLY HOW BIG OF AN IMPACT
THIS IS- LIKE I MENTIONED IN
TWENTY TWENTY ONE. DALY
EMISSIONS FROM STORE ARE
PROJECTED TO SURPASS. THOSE
FROM PASSENGER CARS. I THINK
THAT'S A PRETTY BIG DEAL I
THINK THAT'S A PRETTY BIG DEAL
ON SOMETHING THAT THE
LEGISLATURE SHOULD ADDRESS- YOU
TALK ABOUT THE LONG TERM IMPACT
OF THINGS. I THINK THERE'S NO
BIGGER LONG TERM IMPACT ON
CLIMATE CHANGE. AN THEN AND
THEN TO REDUCE THESE A MISS-
FOR THE FUTURE. SO I YOU AND I
HAVE A FOR. DISAGREE ON SOME OF
THESE. I THE CONCERNS THAT
YOU'RE RAISED I'LL TRY TO WORK
WITH YOU. TO ADDRESS THEM
HOPEFULLY SOME OF THE THINGS I
SAID. ADDRESS SOME OF THE
CONCERNS THAT YOU HAVE- BUT I
RESPECT WHERE YOU'RE COMING
FROM THAT YOU PROBABLY WANT IT
WOULDN'T GO ANY TO. TAKE ON
SOME BIGGER CLIMATE CHANGE
ISSUES LET LET ME NOW I WILL I
APPRECIATE THAT IMITATION THANK
YOU MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU
MISTER. AND WELL WE WENT ON
THAT JOURNEY WITH DEVON HELLO
GOOD JOURNEY THROUGH HIS
CHILDHOOD- I WAS I ONE SIMPLE.
AND WE WENT BACK ALREADY- WHERE
IS THE FUNDING COMING FROM AND
ACTUALLY THERE ARE A FEW OF US
THAT ARE ARE FIERCELY
PROTECTIVE OF SOME OF THE
EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT ARE IN
PLACE- WE GOT THIS NOT KICKED
OUT OF THIS BECAUSE WE
SUPPORTED FORMER PROGRAM YOU
KNOW SOME OF THOSE ISSUES AS IT
RELATES TO LARGER HORSEPOWER
ENGINES. WHERE IS THE FUNDING
COMING FROM AND OUT OF WHAT
BUCKET IS IT COMING FROM. BUT
THAT'S ALL THE LIKE YEAH SO
HOLES ARE GOING TO GO FIND THAT.
THIS AGAIN BILL BUT A MESS
APPEAR. ON THAT JOURNEY- WHICH.
ONE WITH US FOR PUTTING ON THE
SPOT NO NO NO IT'S A GOOD
QUESTION- THAT I JUST. KIND OF
GOT. LOST IN ALL MY NOTED HERE-
I'M THE FUNDING IS COMING FROM
DIFFERENT REBATE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS THAT THAT ALREADY
EXIST- SO I MEAN I THINK TO GET
TO THE CRUX OF YOUR QUESTION-
YEAH THAT'S THE THERE THERE'S-
REBATE PROGRAMS. UNDER CARBON
OF THE DEVON AIR QUALITY
DISTRICTS- AND THAT'S WHAT THE
PHONE WILL COME FROM OKAY THANK
YOU SO MUCH THANKS. AND I'LL
GET BACK TO WITH WITH MORE
DETAILED INFORMATION ABOUT
THAT. MISTER SERRA. THANK YOU.
ARE SO I THINK OF YOU HAVE
HEARD FROM- THE COLLECTION OF.
ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE-
DIFFERENT AREAS HAVE DIFFERENT
REQUIREMENTS AND- CITIES OUT IN
RURAL AREAS HAVE MUCH
DIFFERENT- ENVIRONMENTS- THEN
THEY DO AND ABILITIES TO TRYING
UC'S EQUIPMENT- I MYSELF HAVE A
COMBINATION OF ALL OF THOSE AND
SOMETIMES ONE PIECE OF COURT
AND THAT'S WORK I SWITCHED TO
THE OTHER ONE- I GO THROUGH BAD.
A LOT WHICH CONCERNS ME. AND
BUT YOU KNOWONE OF THE THINGS
THAT I KNOW EXISTS TODAY. IS
THAT LOCAL AGENCIES COMMUNITY
CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES. HAVE
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO BE
THESE IF THEY WANT. AND SO I
THINK IT'S REALLY MORE OF A
LOCAL CONTROL THING THAT I
THINK LOCAL LOCALITIES SHOULD
DETERMINE- WHAT WORKS FOR THEIR
AREA WHAT WORKS FOR THEIR
WORKERS. AND YOU KNOW AND ALLOW
THEM TO DO THAT- AND I WOULD
HOPE THAT. YOU KNOW AS WE DROP
THE EMISSIONS ON CARS YES
INDIVIDUALLY THE CARS WILL BE
SO LOW THAT ANYTHING ELSE AND
IT PRODUCES ANYTHING WILL BE
HIGHER. AND AND SO- YEAH I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
COLLATERAL DAMAGE BUT THIS WITH
THIS TYPE OF LEGISLATION- WE
ALL WANT CLEAN AIR- BUT- YOU
KNOW I THINK BECAUSE YOU KNOW
THERE'S A LOT. OF LIVELIHOODS
THAT DEPEND ON THIS THAT. THEY
CAN BE IN. SO- THAT THOSE ARE
MY- OKAY. THAT AND I USED TO
SERVE ON A CITY COUNCIL PALO
ALTO WITH THAT BAND- GAS
POWERED LEAF BLOWERS IN IT I
DID TALK TO. THIS IS A LITTLE
DIFFERENT. BECAUSE I'M NOT
TRYING TO BAN THE USE. YOU KNOW
COME A CERTAIN DATE I'M SAYING
LET'S BAN THE SALE OF NEW ONES-
BUT BUTI APPRECIATE THE POINT
ON THE LOCAL CONTROL- FRONT
AND- YOU KNOW IS. THAT WE'RE
TRYING TO CRAFT A BILL THAT NEW
WANTS ENOUGH TO ADDRESS ALL THE
DIFFERENT- YOU KNOW REGIONS IN
THE POLICIES OF CALIFORNIA BUT
BUT UNDERSTAND THAT. CONCERNS
EXIST PROJECT. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS. OKAY I'D LIKE TO-
THANK YOU AND THE OTHER AUTHORS
OF THIS LEGISLATION FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD- TO
ADDRESS WHAT IS A SIGNIFICANT
STATEWIDE ISSUE IMPACTING AIR
QUALITY YEAH THE SMALL AND JUST
SMALL ENGINES ARE WELL KNOWN
FOR THEIR EMISSIONS AND NOISE
POLLUTION WHILE I'M SUPPORTING
THE BILL TODAY- I WOULD LIKE
YOU TO TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THE CONCERNS RAISED IN THE
ANALYSIS A REGARDING COMMERCIAL
APPLICATION. OF YOU KNOW I KNOW
PEOPLE IN MY DISTRICT WANT TO
BE ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY BUT
THEY ALSO NEED TO MAKE A LIVING
YOU KNOW I HAVE A LOT OF
LANDSCAPERS AND GARDENERS THAT
LIVE IN MY DISTRICT THAT USE
LAWN EQUIPMENT- AND YOU KNOW
POTENTIALLY COULD NOT AFFORD ON
THIS NEW TECHNOLOGY AND SO I
KNOW WHAT WE'VE DISCUSSED THIS
BEFORE ABOUT FINDING A FUNDING
SOURCE I'M AND I YOU HAVE
COMMITTED TO DOING THAT AND TO
MAKING SURE THAT THAT. WILL BE
AVAILABLE BECAUSE A LOT OF THE
PROGRAMS EXISTING PROGRAMS ARE
ALREADY OVER SUBSCRIBED AND SO
IF WE REALLY WANT TO MOVE IN
THIS DIRECTION WE DO NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT FUNDING IS
AVAILABLE- ALSO YOU KNOW
BATTERY TECHNOLOGY MAKES IT
CHALLENGING YOU KNOW FOR ON THE
SMALL BUSINESSES- TO STOCK UP
AND ON MULTIPLE %TERIES
BECAUSE THEY'RE GOING TO NEED
THEM THROUGHOUT THE DAY TO DO
THEIR WORK- I KNOW IN LOS
ANGELES A LOT OF OUR
LANDSCAPERS MOVE FROM- MULTIPLE
HOMES IN ONE DAY ALL ACROSS THE
CITY. RIGHT YOU KNOW IN IN THIS
AREA IN THIS LARGE AREA I'M AND
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT
THEY WILL BE CONTINUING. AND
ABLE DO THEIR WORK YOU KNOW
THEY'RE JUST PROVIDE DOING THIS
TO PROVIDE FOR THEIR FAMILIES
HELLO THANK YOU FOR- COMMITTEE
INTO THAT. OKAY THAT- MADAM
CHAIR AND THE- YEAH PRESERVE
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE
HAD AND I TRIED TO HAVE A LOT
OF CONVERSATIONS BEFORE YOU
WERE INTRODUCED THE BILL
BECAUSE I KNEW THE
SENSITIVITIES. HISTORIC
SENSITIVITIES THAT THAT MR
MCCARTY RAISED AND IT IS. YOUR
CONSTITUENTS IT IS YEAH THE
LANDSCAPE WORKERS AND GARDENERS
THAT I'M TRYING TO LOOK OUT
FOR. BECAUSE CURRENTLY HAVING
GAS POWER MACHINES ON THEIR
BACKS EIGHT TO TEN HOURS A DAY.
SPEWING FUMES RIGHT NEXT TO
THEIR NOSE IN THEIR MOUTH. IS
DAN- AND WE NEED TO MOVE IN A
HEALTHIER DIRECTION. FOR THEM I
TOTALLY AGREE WITH YOU- THAT WE
ALSO NEED TO MAKES THAT IT'S-
FOR- SO YEAH THAT'S GOING TO A
BIGGER THAT WE'RE TO CONTINUE.
ON AND THE DISPERSAL BILL OR
GOVERNMENT TO TRY TO ADDRESS
THAT TO CREATE MORE FLEXIBILITY
FOR DISTRICTS TO PLUG PROVIDE.
MORE COMMERCIAL REBATES. IN
ADDITION TO THE RESIDENTIAL
REBATES THEY ALREADY PROVIDE SO
IT SO I APPRECIATE THAT AND-
YOU KNOW THE- CREATE YOUR YOUR
YOUR WORK WITH ME ON THIS SURE
IS. WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THE
VALUES THAT IS MY CLOTHES OR
USE THAT AS MY CLOTHES THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. OF THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
I'M NOT SURE IF AND IF ANYONE
HAS. MOVED THAT SOMEONE ALREADY
MOVED DEVELOPMENTS ALREADY IN
STONE. OKAY SO MOTION BY MISTER
MCCARTY SECONDED BY MR STONE-
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THINK ITEM THREE AB THIRTEEN
FORTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BERMAN MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA NO CHILD
FRIEDMAN GARCIA. GARCIA I
MATHIS MATHIS NO MCCARTY
MCCARTY I MURATSUCHI SAY OUR
JOB NOW. SEROTONIN STONE. STONE
I WOULD. FOUR THREE FOUR THREE
WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN THANK YOU
VERY MUCH THANK YOU NEXT UP WE
HAVE AB THIRTEEN NINETY BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BOERNER HORVATH.
WHO WILL. THANK YOU SO MUCH
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS AB THIRTEEN NINETY
WOULD PROVIDE THE STATE LANDS
COMMISSION WITH MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO GENERATE
ADDITIONAL REVENUES FOR RETIRED
TEACHERS AND FACILITATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY DEVELOPMENT ON
SCHOOL LANDS SCHOOL LANDS ARE
LANDS THAT ARE GRANTED TO THE
STATE FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT TO GENERATE REVENUE
THE BENEFIT SCHOOLS THE SCHOOL
ANSWER DIFFICULT TO MANAGE
OFTEN BECAUSE THEY'RE BROKEN UP
INTO NON CONTIGUOUS SQUARE MILE
PARCELS. BECAUSE CONSOLIDATION
OF SCHOOL PARCELS INTO
CONTIGUOUS HOLDINGS IS MORE
EFFECTIVE EXISTING LAW
AUTHORIZES THE COMMISSION TO
SELL ISOLATED NON ECONOMIC
SCHOOL AND USE THE FUNDS FROM
THE SALES TO PURCHASE READ A
REAL PROPERTY THAT WILL
GENERATE ADDITIONAL REVENUES
THE PROBLEM UNDER EXISTING LAW
IS THAT THE COMMISSION IS
CONSTRAINED BY THE EXISTING 5%
CAP USE THE FUNDS TO PAY
ANCILLARY COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
LAND PURCHASES. IN ADDITION
IT'S NOT CLEAR WHAT THIRD PARTY
COSTS ARE FOR SPECIFIC SEAL IN
THE COMMISSION CANNOT MAKE A
DOWN PAYMENT ON A LAND PURCHASE
ON A TIMELY FASHION BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT HAVE THE AUTHORITY
TO DO SO AB THIRTEEN NINETY
CLARIFIES THAT THE COMMISSION
CAMPAIGN BETWEEN LAND
ACQUISITION COSTS AND REMOVES
THE 5% CAP ON THESE EXPENSES
THE BILL AUTHORIZES THE
COMMISSION TO DELEGATE
AUTHORITY TO THE EXECUTIVE
OFFICER TO MAKE A DOWN PAYMENT
FOR POTENTIAL LAND ACQUISITIONS
AND BEYOND THE LEVEL PLAYING
FIELD WITH OTHER PARTICIPANTS
IN THE REAL ESTATE MARKET. IT
ALSO PROVIDES THE COMMISSION
MORE FLEXIBILITY WHEN IT
THOUSAND GIVE OR CONVEYS LANDS
IN A MANNER THAT RESULTS IN
RETURNING ANCESTRAL LANDS TO
NATIVE AMERICAN TRIBES I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE TESTIFYING SUPPORT INTO
THE OF THIS BILL SHERI
PEMBERTON CHIEF EXTERNAL
AFFAIRS LEGISLATIVE LIAISON FOR
THE STATE LANDS COMMISSION
SHARED ASK BECAUSE WE ALREADY
HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND THAT
YOU KEEP YOUR COMMENTS SHORT.
THANK YOU MISS BURNER HORVATH-
MODERATOR CAN PLEASE OPEN THE
LINE FOR- MISS SHERI PEMBERTON.
YOU ARE RIGHT OPEN. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
I'M SHERI PEMBERTON THE
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE LANDS
COMMISSION AND SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY
I'LL JUST BE BRIEF SEVERAL
DECADES AGO THE LEGISLATURE
CREATED A SCHOOL AND BANK FUND
AND AS THE TRUSTEE OF THE FUND
THE COMMISSION'S REQUIRED TO
INVEST REVENUE IN THE FUND TO
ACQUIRE PROPERTY TO GENERATE
REVENUE FOR CAL STARS. THE
STATE HAD BORROWED MOST OF THAT
MONEY IN RECENT YEARS- BUT
RECENTLY REPAID WITH INTEREST
AND MARK PURSUING AN INVESTMENT
STRATEGY ON THE PART OF THAT
PROCESS WE'VE IDENTIFIED A FEW
CONSTRAINTS THAT MAKE IT
DIFFICULT FOR US TO DO THAT FOR
THE BILL SIMPLY REMOVES THOSE
CONSTRAINTS AND IMPROVE THE
COMMISSION COMPETITIVENESS IN
THE MARKET. AND POSITION WITH
THE LAND COMMISSION TO PURSUE
INVESTMENTS THAT WILL GENERATE
MORE MONEY FOR RETIRED TEACHERS
THANK YOU AND I'M. AVAILABLE TO
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU.
ARE I DON'T. WE DON'T HAVE ANY-
WITNESSES REGISTERED FOR
OPPOSITION. I'M GONNA OPEN THE
PHONE LINES OF. OR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK I'M AB THIRTEEN NINETY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY HAVE
NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU. ANY WITNESSES
IN THE HEARING ROOM C. NINE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY LOCATION. THERE ARE
NONE QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. K. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. THE THANK YOU SO WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER MATHIS
SECONDED BY MR SO YOUR TOTAL
I'M SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ADAM FOR AB THIRTEEN
NINETY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BOERNER HORVATH THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA RCI
MATHIS. MCCARTY RIGHT TO THEY
R. CHAU HI THEATER OZ STONE.
STONE I WOULD. FOUR ZERO FOUR
ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN NEXT
UP WE HAVE. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BURKE PRESENT IN EIGHTY SIX
SADIE. I HAVE TO HOPE I CAN DO
ONE. THANK THINK MAN CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING YOU IN YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFFER HEARING THE BILL AND
INDICATE THAT I ALSO WILL BE
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
PROPOSED AMENDMENTS. CALIFORNIA
HAS BEEN A GLOBAL LEADER IN
COMBATING CLIMATE CHANGE OUR
STATE HAS LED THE WAY AN
AGGRESSIVE EMISSION REDUCTIONS
WHILE EXPANDING OUR ECONOMY TO
BE THE FIFTH LARGEST IN THE
WORLD. ALTHOUGH THIS TEST THERE
HAS BEEN GREAT PROGRESS THERE
IS MORE AND MORE EVIDENCE
SHOWING THAT OUR INVESTMENTS TO
FIGHT CLIMATE CHANGE ARE NOT
GOING TO THE COMMUNITIES WHERE
FUND. THING IS MOST NEEDED.
EIGHT JUNE TWENTY TEN TWENTY
REPORT AUTHORED BY THE STAFF
AND YOU. CENTER FOR SIXTEEN
COMMUNITIES. THE STRUCTURE OF A
CLAIM INVESTMENT. IS SKEWED TO.
THE MOST AFFLUENT COMMUNITIES
IN OUR STATE. THIS HAS COME TO
THE X. AT THE EXPENSE OF
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES AS
THEY HAVE SIGNIFICANTLY LESS
ABILITY OR RESOURCES TO
ACCESSING EXISTING PROGRAMS AND
INCENTIVES. FOLDABLE COMMITTEE
ARE BEING BY THE WAYSIDE AS OUR
STATE ADDRESSES CLIMATE CHANGE.
AB SIXTY EIGHTY HIT HELPS TO
BRIDGE THAT GAP BY IMPLEMENTING
KEY POLICIES RECOMMENDED IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S RECENT
REPORT. PUTTING ALIFORNIA ON
THE HIGH ROAD I JOBS IN CLIMATE
ACTION PLAN FOR TWENTY THIRTY.
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY REQUIRED GIGI
R. F. APPLICANTS TO USE FAIR
AND RESPONSIBLE EMPLOYER
STANDARDS TO PROMOTE HIGH
QUALITY JOBS. INCLUSIVE
PROCUREMENT POLICIES TO MAKE
SURE APPLICANTS ARE CONTRACTING
WITH OTHER RESPONSIBLE ENTITIES
AND PREVAILING WAGE FOR
CONSTRUCTION PROJECT. THE BILL
WOULD FURTHER PRIORITIZE
APPLICANTS THAT PARTNER WITH
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND
TRAINING PROGRAMS THAT TARGET
RESIDENTS OF DISADVANTAGED
TRIBAL AND LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES IN THE SAME REGION
ASK THE PROJECT. THESE
PROVISIONS WHICH ARE JUST A FEW
OF THE RECOMMENDATIONS PROPOSED
BY C. W. D. B.'S HI REPORT WILL
PUT PRINCIPLES OF EQUITY ON THE
FRONT END OF THE APPLICATION
PROCESS RATHER THAN AN
AFTERTHOUGHT. I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE ON AB
EIGHTY TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
COMMUNITIES WHICH NEED THAT
THESE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS ARE
NOT LEFT BEHIND. THANK YOU- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY WITNESSES
REGISTERED. IN SUPPORT WE HAVE
ONE IN OPPOSITION WE HAVE
RICHARD MARCUSSEN FROM THE
WESTERN ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION. MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE PHONE LINE FOR
THE WITNESS. THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. A GOOD MORNING A
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THIS IS RICHARD
MARCUSSEN FOR THE WESTERN
ELECTRICAL CONTRACTORS
ASSOCIATION WITH HIS OPPOSITION
IS LIMITED TO A SINGLE SENTENCE
IN THE BILL IT'S ON PAGE FOUR
AT LINE THIRTY ONE IT REQUIRES
THAT A CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS-
PURSUED UNDER THE GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND PROGRAM I
HAVE TO HAVE A PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENT. INCLUDED IN THEM THE
STATE AUDITOR MADE A NUMBER OF
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR WAYS TO
IMPROVE THE STATE'S USE OF CAP
AND TRADE PROCEEDS TO MAXIMIZE
THE REDUCTION OF GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS IN THE STATE BUT
NOWHERE IN THE REPORT WAS THERE
ANY MENTION. THAT A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT WOULD IMPROVE
THE PROGRAM'S EFFICACY THERE
ARE AT LEAST TWENTY FIVE
DIFFERENT STATE AGENCIES WHO
RECEIVED OVER TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS IN PROCEEDS FROM. CAP
AND TRADE SINCE IT WAS
INITIATED- THE STATE REPORT.
THAT THE STATE REPORTS THAT
OVER FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND PROJECTS HAVE BEEN
IMPLEMENTED SINCE THE PROGRAM'S
INCEPTION. AND WELL LIGHTED THE
STATE CLIMATE INVESTMENTS OR A
OR B. WEBSITES BREAK DOWN HOW
MUCH OF THE TWELVE BILLION
DOLLARS WAS FOR CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS GREATER THAN A MILLION
DOLLARS. YOU CAN EASILY
ENVISION HOW THE REQUIREMENT
FOR PLA'S. WILL ADD SUBSTANTIAL
BURDEN. BOTH TO THE STATE
AGENCIES WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE
FOR ADMINISTERING THE FUNDS.
BUT ALSO TO THE GRANT
RECIPIENTS TO NEGOTIATE AND
EXECUTE A P. L. A. IN ORDER TO
RECEIVE THEIR FUNDS.
FURTHERMORE STUDIES OF SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION HAVE SHOWN THE
PLA'S AND 15218% TO THE COST OF
CONSTRUCTION. MEANING THE
SINGLE SENTENCE IN AB SIX
EIGHTY IS CURRENTLY CRAFTED
WILL RESULT IN A DECREASE IN
THE AMOUNT OF WORK TO REDUCE
THE IMPACT OF GREENHOUSE GAS.
THAT HAS ON THE ENVIRONMENT FOR
THIS REASON A WEEK IS SUPPOSED.
UNLESS AMENDED TO A. B. SIX
EIGHTY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU I'M NEXT WILL OPEN
THE PHONE LINES ARE FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION. SESSION
ON THE BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO MAKE A COMMENT ON
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE IN CUBA JUST
BE ONE MOMENT FOR THAT COMMENT.
THREE COMMENTS THANK YOU THE
FIRST ONE IS FROM LINE ONE
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MEMBERS- THANK YOU
FOR TAKING MY CALL I ACTUALLY
WASN'T GOING TO COMMENT ON
THIS- PARTICULAR BILL HOWEVER-
THE GENTLEMAN WHO JUST SPOKE
BEFORE ME- IT BROUGHT UP SOME
NUMBERS THAT ACTUALLY- AREN'T
TRUE. DELAYED THREE NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION ON
THE BILL PLEASE- NAME IS THE
KARBI AFFILIATION AS YOU A
LOCAL ONE FOURTEEN POSITION IS
A- THE SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE FIFTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS JEREMY CENTERS- AND- I'M A
POLITICAL SCIENCE STUDENT AT
THE PUMP CAL POLY POMONA POLICE
SUPPORT ON A EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
PLEASE GO AHEAD A GOOD MORNING
ERIN LEHANE ON BEHALF OF THE
HALF A MILLION MEMBERS OF THE
STATE BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL WE APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK ON THIS
BILL AND WE SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. MORNING
MA'AM CHAIR MEMBERS MIKE WEST
ON BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES. WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU AND ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS TOM
EIGHT NON WITH THE PLUMBERS AND
PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN AND NINE MINUTES IN
SUPPORT OF AB SIX EIGHTY. THANK
YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NAMES FOR ARTS AND I'M WITH THE
IRON WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN
OUT OF SACRAMENTO AND WE STAND
WITH THE BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT. JEEZ. RAYMOND DAVIS
IRON WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN
SUPPORT. JASON LINDSEY FROM
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT IN SUPPORT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MEMBERS GLENN LEVEL
OF IRON WORKERS UNION LOCAL
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT ALSO IN
SUPPORT. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
DARLING REPRESENTING. THE
BOILERMAKERS FIVE FORTY NOT OUT
PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA WE STAND
WITH THE TRADES COUNCIL IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GOOD
MORNING RENDON DISCOUNT OF
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND I TRADE WE
STAND WITH BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT THEY GAVE. MORE JIM
JEFFERIES BOULEVARD LOCALIZED
FIVE FORTY NINE IS THAT IN
SUPPORT OF- SB SIX EIGHTY WITH
STATE BUILDING TRADES. THANK
YOU. I'VE DO WE HAVE ANY WHAT A
THREE LOW. C. NINE OF ANY
ACTUALLY OUT THREE OVER PHONE.
OKAY SORRY GO AHEAD THANK YOU.
RIGHT ONE NINETEEN PLEASED
AHEAD. THANKS FOR INCLUDING
THOSE TOM LET SENDING BUILDING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WON
SAID FOUR CALL. YES GOOD
COMMITTEE MY IS JOHN PAUL GRAY
THE IN YOUR MONO COUNTIES
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL AND WE
STAND IN SUPPORT WITH OF STATE
BUILDING TRADES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE THIRTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH MARC
ALMOND TO THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF ELEVATOR CONSTRUCTORS
STAND IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU ACTUALLY HAVE TO
AGAIN A WHITE ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE AHEAD. SHE HI GOOD
MORNING MRS THIS OUR- WELL SIX
HEAT AND- MICHELLE IN SUPPORT
WITH THE STATE BUILDING SURE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MUCH THREE
PLEASE WHAT HAD. YES PRIMEROS
SANTA CRUZ COUNTY BUILDINGS
TRADES CAL WE INS. OF THE STATE
BUILDING TRICKS. THANK YOU I AM
NO COMMENT THANK YOU IT THIS
TIME. THANK I'M DO WE HAVE ANY.
FROM MEMBERS THE COMMITTEE. THE
SAME. OF I BELIEVE HAVE A MO.
FOR MISS. I HAVE THIS. CAMPUS
BY MR STONE. THE MOTION. IS. DO
PASS AS A TO APPROACH. I'M CAN
COMMIT I'M SORRY TO GO I'M
SORRY WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE AYE
AYE JUST BECAUSE BEEN A LONG
TIME SO WE'VE HAD PEOPLE IN THE
BILL HERE TO TELL ONE AT THINK
EVERYONE CAME TODAY IS. IT'S A
PLUS CHANGE IT'S AN THING TO
SEE AGAIN YOU KNOW I WILL
RESPECTFULLY WERE AND I VOTE
BELIEVE THE HAVE TO REALLY THIS
THAT WE HAVE TO WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE FOR OUR- FOR THE- THAT
BY. AND.
CALL. FRIEDMAN GARCIA.
MATHIS MATHIS NOT VOTING
MCCARTY. RIGHT TO G. SARATOGA
NUMBER THEY ARE NOT VOTING.
STONE STONE I WOULD. TWO ZERO
K. TWO ZERO WE'LL LEAVE THAT
OPEN THANK YOU MA'AM THANK YOU
THANK YOU. I'M NEXT STEP WE
HAVE AB TWELVE SIXTEEN MR CHAN.
WELL. IF I MAY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
I'M HERE 2% EIGHTY TWELVE SIXTY
THIS BILL WOULD HELP JUMP START
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
PROJECTS A LOT OPPORTUNITY FOR
GETTING PEOPLE BACK TO WORK
X.-PEDITE CLIMATE FRIENDLY
TRANSPORTATION INFRASTRUCTURE.
SAN MARINO COUNTY
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY IS
LEADING THE EFFORT TO BRING THE
FIRST HYDROGEN AND BATTERY
POWER TRAIN INTO NORTH AMERICA
AB TWELVE SIXTY WOULD HELP
BUILD THE CRITICAL
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
SUPPORT ZERO MISSION TRAINS BY
STREAMLINING THEM THROUGH
SEQUEL. THIS PROJECT WILL HELP
ACTIVE THE STATE'S GOALS OF
REDUCING EMISSIONS AND MOVING
TO A CLEANER TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS BY THE YEAR TWENTY
THIRTY. WE CANNOT AFFORD DELAY
COMMONSENSE PROJECTS THAT
CREATE JOBS. REVIVE LOCAL
ECONOMIES IMPROVE
TRANSPORTATION CONNECT WITH
COMMUNITIES AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS. LAST
YEAR THE LEGISLATURE PROVES
SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS FROM SYKORA
FOR HYDROGEN FUELING STATIONS
FOR BUSES. NOW AB TWELVE SIXTY
ONE CLUE ZERO EMISSIONS TRAIN
CHARGING INFRASTRUCTURE FOR
HYDROGEN RIALS. THESE
PROVISIONS WILL HELP WE'LL SEE
FOR MORE AFFABLE AND
SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
SYSTEM IN A TIMELY AND COST
EFFECTIVE MANNER. WITH ME TODAY
IN SUPPORT IS DELANEY HUNTER ON
BEHALF THE SAN MARINO
TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY WILL
BE THE PRIMARY ONE IS FOR
EIGHTY TWELVE SIXTY. THANK YOU
A MODERATOR KEY PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINE FOR DELANEY HUNTER.
THANK YOU YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
NUMBERS DELANEY HUNTER ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN BERNARDINO
COUNTY TRANSPORTATION AUTHORITY
WITH A PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
TWELVE SIXTY. AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CHEN MENTIONS WE ARE
LEADING THE CHARGE FOR CLEAN
TRANSIT OPTIONS IN SAN MARINO
AND THE REST OF THE INLAND
EMPIRE WE BELIEVE THAT AB
TWELVE SIXTY IS IN LINE WITH
PREVIOUS ACTION TAKEN BY THE
LEGISLATURE LAST YEAR THAT
PROVIDED SIMILAR EXEMPTIONS FOR
CHARGING AND FUELING STATION
FOR CLEAN ZERO EMISSION BUSES.
AND WOULD SIMPLY EXTEND THOSE
SAME EXEMPTIONS TO CLEAN. RAIL
WE THANK THE COMMITTEE AND
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHAN FOR HIS
EFFORTS ON OUR BEHALF AND
URGENT I FELT. THANK YOU. NEXT
WILL OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. HE'S JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT ON AB TWELVE SIXTY
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY
HAVE NO COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU I'M ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
C. NINE ANY WITNESSES THAT THE
REMOTE LOCATION. I DON'T SEE
ANY- ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE. OKAY NOT
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL MANAGER
THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER MATHIS SECONDED BY
MR FLORIDA. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE
TAKE THE ROLE. I DON'T SIX AB
TWELVE SIXTY BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLOOR FLOOR AYE CHAU. FRIEDMAN
GARCIA. MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY WELL TO G. SARATOGA HI
THERE ARE TWO AYE STONE. STONE
NO WOULD. FOUR ONE FOUR ONE
WE'LL LEAVE THAT OPEN THANK YOU
YOUR TIME. C. IS MR CHEW HERE
TO PRESENT AB. FIVE TWO FIVE.
THREE HAVE. CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
MR CHIU START YEAH THANK YOU.
OKAY SINCE WE DON'T HAVE. ANY
OTHER PRESENTERS IN THE ROOM-
MISTER SEA ARE YOU WILLING TO
PRESENT YOUR BILL OKAY AB SEVEN
ONE THREE. WE WILL. I WOULD
SECOND MY OWN BILLIONS. THANK
YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU. AB
SEVEN ONE THREE- REQUIRES A
STATE EVERY FOR SPORTS CONDUCT
THE COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
ANALYSIS TO CORPORATE
INCORPORATE INTO THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SCHOOL BEING
PLAN WITH EACH UPDATE. THE
SCOPING PLAN UPDATE HAPPENS
EVERY FIVE YEARS AND I THINK I
TO HELP US REDUCE GHG EMISSIONS
AND IMPROVE AIR QUALITY. I
DON'T KNOW HOW THE TRICK IS NOT
NEW TO THE AIR B. BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND
EIGHTEEN. THE BOARD DIRECTED
STAFF TO PROVIDE HEALTH METRICS
AND THIS WILL BE IN PLAN WHICH
IS DUE IN TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
UNFORTUNATELY CAR HAS WORKED
WITH- WHILE CRIED BECAUSE WE'RE
WITH C. DPH TO INCLUDE THIS
INFORMATION- A COMPREHENSIVE
ANALYSIS IS NOT PLANNED TO BE
PART OF THE NEXT WILL BE IN
PLAN. BUT THIS WILL BE A PLAN
DRAFT BEING NEXT YEAR AND THE
HEALTH COMMUNITIES LIKE MY
COMPANY BEING COMPROMISED.
BECAUSE OF OUR QUALITY AND GHG
EMISSIONS THIS LEGISLATION IS
URGENTLY NEEDED. EVER TRULY
CARE ABOUT ADDRESSING
INSTITUTIONAL RACISM AND ALL
ASPECTS OF SOCIETY. AND
PRIORITIZING OVERBURDENED
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WHEN YOU
START TALKING ABOUT THE HEALTH
IMPACT ON THESE COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE THEY KNOWING THAT
ALLOWS US TO. BE COMFORTABLE
WITH MY LIFE BEING CUT SHORT
AND THAT OF MY NEIGHBORS. AND
I'M BEING SENTENCED TO A
LIFETIME OF CHRONIC DISEASES
THAT CAN BE PREVENTED HE WE
CLEAN UP OUR ERROR AND WE DO
SORRY MISSIONS. WITH ME TODAY I
HAVE DR LINDA RUDOLPH IN THE
PUBLIC. HEALTH INSTITUTE. AND
FORMERLY EMBARRASSED BY THE
AMERICAN ASSOCIATION TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINES
FOR THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU BOTH SIDES ARE OPEN.
GOOD MORNING I'M DR LINDA
RUDOLPH CAN YOU HEAR ME. YES
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I AM A
PHYSICIAN ADVISER ON CLIMATE
AND HEALTH EQUITY FOR THE
PUBLIC HEALTH INSTITUTE I WAS
PREVIOUSLY A LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER AND DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC HEALTH THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK TODAY IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB SEVEN ONE
THREE. CLIMATE CHANGE IS
IMPACTING THE HEALTH OF
CALIFORNIANS NOW
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECTING
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES WE NEED
AMBITIOUS CLIMATE ACTION TO
AVERT CATASTROPHIC CLIMATE
HEALTH IMPACTS BUT THE SCOPING
PLAN AS A VITAL PLAN TO PROTECT
OUR HEALTH. OUR TRANSPORTATION
LAND USE ENERGY FOOD AND
AGRICULTURE AND BUILDING
SYSTEMS ARE RESPONSIBLE NOT
ONLY FOR GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS BUT ALSO FOR THE
PERSISTENT HEALTH INEQUITIES
THAT PLAGUE EVERY CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY. WAITING FOR
THOUSANDS OF PREMATURE DEATHS
IN LOW INCOME PEOPLE AND PEOPLE
OF COLOR. IF CREATED WISELY THE
POLICIES WE ENACT TO MITIGATE
CLIMATE CHANGE PRESENT GREAT
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE HEALTH
AND REDUCE HEALTH INEQUITIES
GREEN CARDS AND CLEAN ENERGY
REDUCE AIR POLLUTION HEART
DISEASE AND LUNG DISEASE ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION REDUCES
CARDIOVASCULAR DISEASE AND
DIABETES. URBAN FORESTRY REDUCE
OF HEAT ILLNESS AND IMPROVES
WATER QUALITY BUT SOME CLIMATE
POLICIES CAN WORSEN HELP POORLY
DONE HOME WEATHERIZATION CAN
WORSEN INDOOR AIR QUALITY CAP
AND TRADE CAN PERPETUATE
UNACCEPTABLE HEALTH INEQUITIES.
CALIFORNIANS WILL SPEND A LOT
OF MONEY TO ADDRESS CLIMATE
CHANGE INCORPORATING A BETTER
HEALTH ANALYSIS INTO
DEVELOPMENT OF THE SCOPING PLAN
WILL PROVIDE POLICY MAKERS THE
INFORMATION THEY NEED TO ENSURE
THAT THOSE INVESTMENT OPTIMIZED
HEALTH BENEFITS AND MINIMIZE
HEALTH RISKS. ESPECIALLY FOR
THE MOST VULNERABLE. CDPH WE
HOW IN A OR B. TO IN AND FRAME
FOR YOU IN A KIND. HEALTH AND
NOW. AND IS PURPOSE MUCH
PROVIDE MUCH FOR TO A RP FOR
AND I. YEAH A. R. B. IS NOT
PLANNING TO ACQUIRE A ROBUST
AND NOW THAT THE NEXT COPING
REVIEW. I URGE YOU TO AB ONE
THREE TWO ENSURE THAT
CALIFORNIA'S CLIMATE POLICIES
PROTECT HEALTH AND PROMOTE
EQUITY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING I'M WILL THERE AT THE
DIRECTOR OF CLEAN AIR ADVOCACY
WITH THE AMERICAN LUNG
ASSOCIATION IN CALIFORNIA ALSO
SPEAKING IN SUPPORT IN
FOLLOWING DR RUDOLPH COMMENT I
WOULD START BY NOTING THAT I'M
MORE COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
EVALUATION OF THE SCOPING PLAN
AND MEASURES THAT FOLLOWS
COKING PLANT IS A HIGH PRIORITY
FOR THE AMERICAN LUNG SAID AND
MANY OF OUR PUBLIC HEALTH
PARTNERS. WOULD YOU THE
UPCOMING SCOPING PLAN AS A
CRITICAL EFFORT TO CHART
CALIFORNIA'S COURTS RAPIDLY
AWAY FROM FOSSIL FUELS WILL BE
ENGAGING WITH THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD THROUGHOUT THAT PROCESS
AND SHARE THE AGENCY PUBLIC
HEALTH FOCUSED MISSION THERE'S
NO QUESTION THAT THE SCOPING
PLANTED THE MAJOR TOUCH POINT
CALIFORNIA'S LEADERSHIP IN
REDUCING CLIMATE POLLUTION. THE
SCOPING PLAN WILL RESULT IN
SIGNIFICANT ACTIONS AND
INVESTMENT TO BE UNDERTAKEN
OVER THE COMING DECADE TO REACH
OUR HELP PROTECT THE CLIMATE
STANDARDS THIS BILL WILL ENSURE
THAT AT THE PLANT DEVELOP KARBI
UTILIZED BOTH INTERNAL AND
EXTERNAL EXPERTISE TO EVALUATE
QUALITATIVELY AND
QUANTITATIVELY TO THE EXTENT
POSSIBLE THE POTENTIAL IMPACT
AND BENEFIT. OF THE SCOPING
PLAN AND ASSOCIATED STRATEGIES
TO FOLLOW THE BILL ALSO CALLS
FOR CARD TO DETERMINE WHAT
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES WOULD BE
NEEDED TO ADVANCE THIS
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH ANALYSIS.
IF THOSE ARE NOT CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE. THE BOTTOM LINE HERE
I THINK THAT A CAR MOVES. TO
DEVELOP THE TWENTY TWO AND
FUTURE ITERATIONS OF THE
SCOPING PLAN. THE MORE
COMPREHENSIVE HEALTH
EVALUATION. WILL REALLY ALLOW
FOR DEEPER UNDERSTANDING OF THE
WAYS THAT THE POLICIES THAT
CALIFORNIA PURSUES MIGHT
INTERACT WITH HEALTH AND HEALTH
EQUITY. EITHER POSITIVELY OR
NEGATIVELY. THE PROCESS CAN
HELP THE REALLY TO IDENTIFY
WHICH POLICIES MIGHT NEED TO
BREAK BE PRIORITIZED GOING
FORWARD. AND YET YOU EXTREMELY
IMPORTANTLY TO HELP THE AGENCY
BETTER HOME HEALTH PROTECTIVE
MITIGATION. THAT WOULD BE
NEEDED WITH AN INDIVIDUAL
MAKING PROCESSES THAT FOLLOW
THE ADOPTION OF THE COMPANY
AND- WITH THAT I URGE HER AYE
VOTE AND REALLY DO APPRECIATE-
THE AUTHOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD. THANK YOU. I WILL OPEN
UP. THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN
UP THE LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT ON EIGHTY EIGHT
SEVEN THIRTEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
HAVE ABOUT TEN IN Q. WILL GO TO
LINE SIXTY NINE I'M SORRY ONE
EIGHTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MENTIONED WERE BUDGET
WITH CLIMATE CENTRE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE NINETY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING JULIA READ
OFF WITH THE COALITION FOR
CLEAN AIR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIDE ONE
NINETY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU CAN MEMBERS ROTH
BUCKLEY ON BEHALF OF PUBLIC
HEALTH ADVOCATES AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO- TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. AND MORNING JAMIE GO
ON BEHALF OF ENVIRONMENTAL
DEFENSE FUND AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT FIFTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. WITH THE
HARDWARE CALIFORNIA LICENSE OF
NURSES FOR HEALTHY ENVIRONMENTS
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT
CHAU WIND PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
MORNING CARE COMMITTEE THIS IS
KATHY DURBAN'S WITH THREE FIFTY
BAY AREA ACTION IN SUPPORT OF-
DISPELLED- AB SEVEN THIRTEEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO I'M JENNY CENTERS IN THE
CASE YOU CAN FROM CAL POLY
POMONA PLEASE VOTE YES ON.
EIGHTY SEVEN FIFTY. THANK YOU
I'M SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THE BILL MURRAY REPRESENTING
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY AND
ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION NOR CAL
IN SOCAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MIGHT WANT TO WAIT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I THINK OF THE MIXED UP
I WAS IN LINE WITH A SPINE
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE SIXTY CHEN.
THANK YOU RIGHT NOW ONE TWENTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO COMMENTS
I WAS WAITING ON A DIFFERENT
BILL. THANK YOU THANK YOU I
WANT FIFTEEN NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. WHAT CAN A LOT A LONG
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE ANY
WITNESSES THAT THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE. OF
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. HEY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
RUN A VOTE THANK YOU THANK YOU
FOR YOUR CONTINUING WORK IN HOT
AND EQUITY- ESPECIALLY AND
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES- I
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO THE COMMITTEE THANKS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
MATHIS SECONDED BY MR STONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. I AM SIXTEEN AB SEVEN
THIRTEEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA MEMBERS RUTH
RIVAS HI RIVAS I'VE FLOOR.
FLOOR AYE CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA
GARCIA AYE MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI SARATOGA NOT
VOTING THIRTY NOT VOTING STONE.
STONE I WOULD. FIVE ZERO EIGHT
FIVE ZERO WILL LEAVE THAT OPEN-
I'M NEXT WE WILL GO BACK TO
FILE ORDER TO FILE ITEM SEVEN-
MISTER TO AB FIVE TWO FIVE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
COLLEAGUES THIS IS A COMMITTEE
THAT KNOWS FULL WELL THAT
DURING THIS PAST YEAR ALONG
WITH THE PANDEMIC IN THE LOSS
OF OVER A MILLION JOBS OUR
STATE HAS EXPERIENCED INTENSE
CLIMATE CRISIS HEATWAVES
WILDFIRES ROLLING BLACKOUTS. AS
WE THINK ABOUT HOW TO ADDRESS
THIS CRISIS AND PUT PEOPLE BACK
TO WORK THERE'S A ONCE IN A.
GENERATION OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BOTH JUST TWENTY TO THIRTY
MILES OFFSHORE. OUR STATE IS
ACCESS TO ONE OF THE WORLD'S%
GREATEST UNTAPPED SOURCES OF
RENEWABLE ENERGY IN THE FORM OF
OFFSHORE WIND. WENT THANK YOU
WHEN THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL TO
COMBAT CLIMATE CHANGE MEET OUR
CLEAN ENERGY GOALS AND PROVIDE
GOOD PAYING JOBS. THE BY
DEMONSTRATION RECENTLY
ANNOUNCED SWEEPING INVESTMENTS
IN CLIMATE INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING PLANNING FOR THIRTY
GIGAWATTS OF OFFSHORE WIND BY
TWENTY THIRTY. BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS A PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
INDUSTRY. HE'S BECAUSE STATES
HAVE ALREADY ESTABLISHED
SIGNIFICANT GOALS RESULTING IN
SIXTEEN PROJECTS UNDER CONTRACT
UNFORTUNATELY CALIFORNIA IS
BEHIND BUT WE HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY NOW TO STEP UP.
OFFSHORE WIND IS A SMART
STRATEGY THAT COMPLEMENTS OUR
SOLAR INDUSTRY BECAUSE IT
GENERATES ENERGY AT NIGHT.
OFFSHORE WIND ALSO REQUIRES
SIGNIFICANT LABOR AND HAS
POTENTIAL TO ADD THOUSANDS OF
GOOD PAYING JOBS AND SUPPLY
CHAIN DEVELOPMENT CONSTRUCTION
OPERATIONS AND MAINTENANCE.
THIS BILL WILL MAKE SURE WE TAP
INTO ALL OF THE BENEFITS OF
OFFSHORE WIND BY ENSURING THAT
WE ALSO GIVE CONSIDERATION
CAREFULLY TO OUR STATES MARINE
AND COASTAL ECOSYSTEMS WITH THE
GOAL OF PRIORITIZING
DEVELOPMENT. IN THE AREAS OF
LEAST CONFLICT. EIGHTY FIVE
TWENTY FIVE WOULD JUMPSTART THE
OFFSHORE WIND INDUSTRY IN
CALIFORNIA CREATING A PLAN TO
CONSTRUCT AND HARNESS THE POWER
OF OFFSHORE WIND. AND WITH THAT
I WANT TO TURN IT OVER TO A
WITNESSES BUT WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT AND THANK THE STRONG
BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN THIS
BILL. AS WELL AS OUR COALITION
OF ENVIRONMENTALISTS BUILDING
TRADES AND CLEAN ENERGY
INDUSTRY WITH THAT TURN IT OVER
TO A WITNESSES. THANK YOU.
THANKS I WE HAVE TWO WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT- FIRST- LAURA D.
HAND FROM ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA BY PHONE MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR THE WITNESS. THANK YOU YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. SH THANK YOU AT
NINETEEN LARA THE HAND AND
ADVOCATE DIRECT CARE ADVISEMENT
CALIFORNIA AND WE'RE PRIVATELY
CLIP ON THERE AB FIVE TWO FIVE.
ONE OF THE BOND NATURAL BEEF.
AVAILABLE IN OUR STATE IF THE
WIND OFF OUR COAST IN FACT
NORTHERN. IS ONE OF THE HOT
SPOT FOR OFF SHORE WIND
ACCORDING TO THE NATIONAL
RENEWABLE ENERGY LAB AT THE
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY AND THE
WIND BLOWS FASTEST AND HARDEST
OFF OF OUR COAST COMPARED TO
ANYWHERE ELSE IN THE U. S. AND
THERE WAS A RECENT ENVIRONMENT
CALIFORNIA RESEARCH AND POLICY
CENTER REPORT. OFFSHORE WIND
FOR AMERICA WELL THE FACT IS
THAT WE HAVE THAT TECHNICAL
POTENTIAL CAN MEET MORE THAN
ONE AND A HALF BEHIND OUR
ENTIRE STATE. ELECTRICITY NEEDS
FROM TWENTY NINETEEN JUMPED
FROM OFFSHORE WINDS. AND WHILE
CALIFORNIA HAS BEEN A WORLD
LEADER IN TACKLING MANY ASPECTS
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS OTHER
PARTS OF THE WORLD HAVE JUMPED
AHEAD OF US IN TAPPING INTO
OFFSHORE WIND. UP FOR EXAMPLE
MY NEED TO COUNTRY SCOTLAND
WITH 97% COVERED BY RENEWABLE
ENERGY LAST YEAR AND ONE OF THE
BIGGEST CORTES WAS FROM
OFFSHORE WIND. BUT MATTER IF
THEY'RE TRYING TO CATCH UP
OFFSHORE WIND TECHNOLOGY HAS
IMPROVED SO THAT WE CAN
MEDICALLY BLOATING BY. NEARLY
DIED OF THE EIFFEL TOWER TWENTY
FIVE MILES OFF THE COAST RIGHT
TACKLE TURBINE CAN POWER
FIFTEEN TO TWENTY PRESIDENT
HOLDEN. AB FIVE THREE FIVE WILL
CAPITALIZE CALIFORNIA'S
OFFSHORE WIND ENERGY PRODUCTION
BY DIRECTING THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO COORDINATE
WITH ALL THE RELEVANT STATE
AGENCIES AND ASCETICAL AND
CREATE A PLAN TO COOPERATE ON
DR WHEN WHILE PROTECTING OUR
CRITICAL. ECOSYSTEMS AND OUR
STATE. BIODIVERSITY I CRISIS IS
REACHING HAVOC ON ON EARTH AND
THE FACT WE CAN MOVE TO PLIGHT
ENERGY AND DATA BURNING FOSSIL
FUEL. THE BANK YOUR TO WE
HAPPEN TO FUTURE. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. AND NEXT WHAT
IS IF WE HAVE ERIN LEHANE AND
THE HERE ROOM. GOOD MORNING IT
THIS TIME MEMBER RE MEMBERS OF
THE- ERIN THE HEAD HERE BEHALF
OF THE HAPPY MILLION MAY WAIT
OF THE UPDATE IS COULD PLEASE.
I WANNA MAKE SURE THAT THE MY-
IS ON. THEIR ON YEAH OKAY OKAY
I MOVED TO I THOUGHT I WAS TO
STAY SO OKAY. OKAY THAT'S WHAT
MAKES THAT HERE IS YOUR THANK
YOU- WE ARE HERE AND ENTHUSIAST
SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWO FIVE- AS
MOST OF YOU KNOW THE BUILDING
TRADES HAVE BUILT THE VAST
MAJORITY OF THE STATE'S
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOURCES FROM
SOLAR. AND WIND TO GEOTHERMAL
PUMP STORAGE- AS THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION HAS RECOGNIZED
OFFSHORE WIND WILL PRESENT A
HUGE OPPORTUNITY TO THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND THIS COUNTRY
AND IT REALLY IS THE NEXT
FRONTIER OF RENEWABLE ENERGY.
THE BUILDING TRADES ARE POISED
TO BUILD THE INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT WILL SUPPORT OFFSHORE
WIND- THEY REALLY YOU KNOW
WE'RE HERE TODAY- TO PLEDGES
SUPPORT OF OUR HALF A MILLION
MEMBERS. UP FOR MR CHOOSE KIND
OF AGGRESSIVE THINKING ABOUT
HOW WE BRING POWER ONTO THE
GRID VERSES JUST THINKING ABOUT
TAKING POWER OFF- WE HAVE ALL
EXPERIENCED THE ROLLING
BLACKOUTS THAT HAVE OCCURRED IN
CALIFORNIA IT IS MORE IMPORTANT
THAN EVER. TO START THINKING
ABOUT BRINGING MORE SOURCES OF
CLEAN ENERGY ONTO THE GRID- WE
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THIS REALLY.
IS A WIN WIN THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. SINCE I SEE SOME WITNESSES.
IN I'M GONNA GO AHEAD AND LET
THEM GO FIRST. PLEASE A STATE
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL PLEASE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIRMAN MIKE WEST
REPRESENTING THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING RENDON
DISTRICT COUNCIL SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND IN SUPPORT WITH
BUILDERS. GOOD MORNING GLENN
LEVEL OF IRON WORKERS UNION
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING JASON LINDSAY
IRONWORKERS LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT OAKLAND STANDING IN
SUPPORT WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES ON THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING TOM EIGHT WITH THE
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOUR FOUR SEVEN STANDING HERE
TODAY WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF AB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE. HI MY NAME IS MICHAEL
JOHN RIBS IN THE BOILERMAKERS
FIVE FORTY NINE WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH BILLION TRADES
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. Q.
RAYMOND DAVIS IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN SACRAMENTO
SUPPORT. DO WITH THE JEFFRIES
BOTTLENECK LOCALIZED FIVE FORTY
NINE AND THAT'S MORE THAN A
BOILERMAKER STANDING SUPPORT OF
AB. FIVE TWENTY FIVE. CHOI
AREN'T SO WHAT THE IRON WORKERS
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB. FIVE
TWO FIVE. GOOD MORNING MEMBERS
TEMPERAMENT INTERNATIONAL UNION
OF OPERATING ENGINEERS AND FULL
SUPPORT I'D LIKE TO- THINK THE
AUTHOR IN HIS OFFICE FOR
PATIENTS WITH THE PROPONENTS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR GOOD WORK.
THANK YOU. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS BRIAN WHITE HERE
ON BEHALF OF OFFSHORE WIND
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF
OFFSHORE WIND DEVELOPERS WHO
ARE HIGHLY UNCERTAIN
RESPONSIBLE DEVELOPING OFFSHORE
WIND. STRONGLY SUPPORT EIGHTY
FIVE TWO FIVE THANK YOU. OUR
MODEL GUERRERO SHEETMETAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OF ONE OF
FOUR AND BUILDING TRADES
COUNCIL PRESIDENT OF THE MIDDLE
VALLEY BUILDING TRADES IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS HELD IN THE CHART LOCAL
SIXTEEN INSULATORS AND WE HAVE
A STRONG SUPPORTER. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROB
STOKER REPRESENTING SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OF FOUR
STRONG SUPPORT. MORNING MY
NAME'S DEANA BRILL REPRESENT
WHAT THE STATE COUNCIL SHEET
METAL WORKERS AND WE'RE IN
SUPPORT. GOOD MORNING MORGAN
ALL THE PRESIDENT WESTERN
DISTRICT COUNCIL RIVERS
WATERPROOF RISEN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I'M NEXT
WILL GO TO THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. Q. IF YOU WISH TO COMMENT
ON EIGHTY EIGHT FIVE TWO FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. AND I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FORTY IN Q. WE'LL GO
TO LINE ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD DID YOU SAY FORTY.
MORNING OKAY THAT SORT OF MAKE
SURE YES OKAY WE WILL- TAKE
FIVE MINUTES. SO UP TO FIVE
MINUTES THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALL RIGHT ONE EIGHTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN
BIRTH PER THOUGHT YOU TALKED ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY OF HUMBLE
IN THE COUNTY OF FAMILY WITH
THE BEST A BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. THANK
YOU RIGHT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. AMERILA THE CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION VOTERS STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
NINETY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO GONZALEZ WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M MORE IN
COMMON WE HAVE A FAIR CALL
CALIFORNIA CALLING IT QUITS FOR
THINKING. THANK YOU I WON
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MICHAEL WITH
AMERICAN CLEAN POWER CALIFORNIA
AND STRONG SUPPORT ALSO
REPRESENTING ACTOR OFFSHORE
WIND BUSINESS NETWORK FOR
OFFSHORE WIND CASTLE AND THEIR
DEFENSE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
STRATEGIES EDF RENEWABLE FORCE
THAT OCEAN WINDS PACIFIC OCEAN
ENERGY TRUST PRINCIPLE POWER
AND RWE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M ONE FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. I MEAN I'M A WITHOUT ONE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO AWAIT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TO WHAT MANAGER WITH THE CALLER
CARE ACT YEAH THIS IS WHAT NOT
TO WHAT THE CLIENT CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
AYE TO TEND PLEASE GOING.
MORNING I'M CHAIR JAMES THEIR
LACK OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
FORTY EIGHTH PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU KNOW WHAT THE OPERATING
ENGINEERS LOCAL TWELVE JOINING
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
INSTRUCTOR COURT. THANK YOU I
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU TURN MEMBERS NIKITA CRAPPIE
BUT THE NATURAL RESOURCES
DEFENSE COUNCIL IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY SIXTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. TE BILL
MURPHY REPRESENTING THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY AND ELDERS
CLIMATE ACTION NOR CAL AND
SOCAL CHAPTERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RUN ONE FORTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY. ONE FOUR
FIVE. BY ONE THIRTY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING ADONIS
TAXES WITH IBEW LOCALS ELEVEN
WHAT KINDS OF THIS COUNTY IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU MIGHT
WANT TO LIVE IN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
EVEN BOOKER POLITICAL DIRECTOR
OF INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
ELECTRICAL WORKERS LOCAL SIX
SEVENTEEN TELL COUNTY WHICH
GRANDSTANDING STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS WIND WIND BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU BYE NINETY
FOUR AT. RIGHT. NINE ZERO.
RIGHT TO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING AARON RODRIGUEZ
WITH UNION OF CONCERNED
SCIENTISTS AND SUPPORT THANKS
BUT AS OF THE FIRST THIS IS THE
FIRST CALL NINE ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I MORNING THIS
IS HAPPENING YEAR SO LOCAL TO
HEAT PROC AND MISTRETTA WE STAY
IN STRONG SUPPORT- WITH
BUILDING TRADE AB FIVE TWENTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU NOW.
ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS BETTY
RIGHT BUMPERS AND PIPEFITTERS
LOCAL TWO FOUR SIX IN FRESNO
CALIFORNIA AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SIXTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING THIS IS JOHN CORSO UA
LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT CLIMBERS AND
STEVE CREDIT AND SAN FRANCISCO
WE STAND IN SUPPORT STATE
BUILDING TRADES ON AB FIVE
TWENTY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE NINETY SIX PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING CHAU
NUMBERS BURGEONING K. ON BEHALF
WHICH DURING THE COURT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
YOUR NAME IS TO RESTORE WITH
THE WHITE MAN GROUP ON BEHALF
OF EAST BAY COMMUNITY ENERGY
AND R. W. E. IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU RIGHT TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. LITTLE BALLS WITH
SMARTSHEET AFFORDABLE ONE ZERO
FIVE EXTEND THE BILL DRAYTON
BEFORE. THANK YOU I WANT SIXTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK YOU
MELISSA CORTEZ WITH
GOVERNMENTAL ADVOCATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
WIND ENERGY ASSOCIATION AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RYAN ONE
SEVENTY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MICHAEL MONEY GOING TO BE HELP
THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS AND THE COALITION OF
CALIFORNIA UTILITY EMPLOYEES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. WE'LL
BRING YOUR FOR THREE FIFTY
SACRAMENTO IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU ALL RIGHT TO ALL THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS TALKING ABOUT BY
REPRESENT IBEW LOCAL NEVER NOT
BE APPLE OR TWELVE THOUSAND
MEMBERS. WE'RE HERE TO
ENERGIZED THE WIND INDUSTRY
THANK YOU SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT ONE NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINE ONE GOOD
MORNING THIS IS ROBBIE COBLE'S
WITH THE SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA
PIPE TRADES AND WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU
MY WRITER FORTY MODERATOR WE'RE
FIVE MINUTES- WHILE I
APPRECIATE- ALL OF THE CALLS IN
SUPPORT- WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND AND I AM
SUPPORTING THIS BILL BUT I
WOULD LIKE TO REMIND THE
WITNESSES- THAT YOU ARE WELCOME
TO SUBMIT. OF YOUR TESTIMONY OF
ANY LENGTH VIA OUR WEBSITE- WE
WOULD WELCOME HEAR TESTIMONY
AND- APPRECIATE YOUR PATIENCE-
AND YOUR YOUR- SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL THANK YOU. LET'S SEE NEXT
NEXT ARE THERE ANY- QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
MR SAY ARE TOP. MR JURAI- I'M
GOING TO BE SUPPORTING YOUR
BILL TODAY- THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS TYPE OF BILLS
THIS IS NEW TECHNOLOGY AND NEW
TECHNOLOGY BRINGS NEW JOBS AND-
AND THOSE ARE PRETTY WELL
PAYING JOBS TO- SO I'M
ENCOURAGED BY THAT AND I THINK
WHETHER YOU'RE A 1100%
RENEWABLE WOOD CENTER ZERO.
CARBON EMISSIONS PERSON OR A
BALANCED ENERGY PERSON THAT. IS
MORE CONCERNED OR VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE RELIABILITY
OF ENERGY DELIVERY IN
CALIFORNIA- THIS BILL STILL
MAKES SENSE. SO I APPRECIATE
YOU BRING IT FORWARD AND- LOOK
FORWARD TO SUPPORTING. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM COMMITTEE
MEMBERS THANK YOU I'M MISTER TO
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SUPPORT
SHAPE THE COMMITTEES SUPPORTING
CONSIDERATION I ALSO WANNA JUST
THANK ALL THE SUPPORTERS WHO
SPOKE- I THINK WE WERE ALL
SURPRISED AT HOW MANY FOLKS
CAME OUT BUT I THINK IT'S%
INDICATIVE OF THE FACT THAT
THIS IS NOT ONLY AN IMPORTANT
CONVERSATION BEFORE BUT
CALIFORNIA WE ARE RISKING
COMING BEHIND EAST COAST AND
OTHER PARTS OF THE WORLD IF WE
DON'T MOVE QUICKLY AND THIS IS
A BILL TO ENSURE THAT WE PUT
OFF SHORE WIND. ON THE MAP AND
THE CALIFORNIA SAYS WE'RE READY
TO GO SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR ABOUT
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
MISTER MATHIS AND A SECOND OF
BY MR FLORA- SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ITEM
SEVEN AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER CHIU THE MOTION
IS TO PASS THE RIVER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA FLORA I'D CHAU. EGGMAN
GARCIA. GARCIA AYE MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
FERODO NINE THERE ARE TWO EYES
STONE. STONE I WOULD. SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO CAPITALIST SOUTH THANK
YOU. I'M NEXT- AB TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN IF YOU'D LIKE TO PRESENT
PLEASE GO AHEAD THANK YOU
VENTURE OUT FIRST I'LL BE
ACCEPTING AMENDMENTS IN THIS
COMMITTEE TO LIMIT THE FUNDING
SOURCE- THAT'S BEING PROPOSED
TO JUST THE RESIDENTIAL CLIMATE
CREDIT TO AVOID IMPACTING THE
INDUSTRIALISTS DISTANCE AND
SMALL BUSINESS CREDITS. AS WELL
AS AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY THE
ROLE OF THE THIRD PARTY GRANT
ADMINISTRATOR AND OTHER
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THIS BILL
IS ACUTELY NEEDED TO ADDRESS
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES DURING
CLIMATE CRISIS. DURING RECENT
WILDFIRES HEAT WAVES AND POWER
SHUT OFFS MANY COMMUNITIES HAVE
BEEN ESPECIALLY CHALLENGE
WITHOUT SAFE SPACES TO PROTECT
VULNERABLE RESIDENTS. FROM
EXTREME CONDITIONS. RESILIENCE
HOPES AREN'T INNOVATIVE
COMMUNITY LED SOLUTION TO
ADDRESS THESE CHALLENGES THIS
BILL WOULD AIM TO BOLSTER
COMMUNITY INSTITUTIONS THAT
ALREADY EXIST LIKE LIBRARIES
SCHOOLS COMMUNITY CENTERS AND
PLACES OF WORSHIP. THROUGH
CLEAN ENERGY AND PUBLIC HEALTH
UPGRADES TO OFFER COMMUNITIES
SAFE SPACES TO GATHER ACCESS
CRITICAL SERVICES LIKE BACKUP
POWER REFRIGERATION AND CLEAN
AIR AND OTHERWISE BE PROTECTED
FROM CLIMATE CRISIS. THIS MODEL
GOES BEYOND DISASTER RESPONSE
BY CREATING HUBS WHERE PEOPLE
CAN ACCESS EVERYDAY SERVICES
AND A CLIMATE AND IT AND A
CHANGING CLIMATE. THE CURRENT
PATCHWORK OF PROGRAMS HAS BEEN
INSUFFICIENT WELL THERE ARE
SEVERAL PROGRAMS FOR ENERGY
EFFICIENCY SOLAR AND BATTERY
STORAGE COMMUNITIES CONTINUE TO
EXPERIENCE OBSTACLES ACCESSING
BENEFITS ACROSS THESE
OPPORTUNITIES. BY REDIRECTING A
VERY SMALL PORTION OF THE
CLIMATE CREDIT THIS BILL MAKES
POSSIBLE COMMUNITY SKILLED
BENEFITS FROM PROJECTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA AND WITH THAT I'D
LIKE TO TURN IT OVER TO A
WITNESSES. THANK YOU WE HAVE
TWO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT-
MERION FOR DISSENT FROM NRDC.
AND HERLIN CHAN FROM A PAN
MODERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES. GIVE
ALL FILES ARE OPEN. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON SHERRY THAT'S I
COMMITTEE MEMBERS- MY NAME'S
MARIAN BERGESON SENIOR
SCIENTIST WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL
COSPONSORED WITH A HA AND A PEN
WE URGE YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY ON
EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY SEVEN THIS
BILL CREATES A COMPREHENSIVE
PROGRAM TO UPGRADE CRITICAL
COMMUNITY INSTITUTIONS AND
DISADVANTAGED AND VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
HUBS ROGRAM WILL ADVANCE
PROJECTS THAT REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AND CRITERIA
POLLUTANTS. WHILE ALSO
ENHANCING COMMUNITY RESILIENCE
TO CLIMATE CHANGE EVENTS AND
OTHER DISASTERS. THE BUILDINGS
ELIGIBLE FOR THIS PROGRAM MAY
INCLUDE COMMUNITY CENTERS
HEALTH CLINICS SCHOOLS
LIBRARIES AND OTHER PUBLIC
GATHERING SPACES AND THE
IMPROVEMENTS MAY INCLUDE THINGS
LIKE COOLING AND AIR FILTRATION
ENERGY EFFICIENCY SOLAR BACKUP
POWER. AND ELECTRICAL UPGRADES.
MANY PROGRAMS IN CALIFORNIA ARE
CURRENTLY DIFFICULT ACCESS FOR
RESIDENTS ORGANIZATIONS AND
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS FROM
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
BECAUSE ARE COMPLEX OFTEN SILOS
YOU HAVE TO APPLY TO MULTIPLE
PROGRAMS TO DEVELOP A
COMPREHENSIVE UPGRADE OR
REQUIRE COMPETING WITH BETTER
RESEARCH APPLICANTS. THERE ALSO
NO EXISTING PROGRAMS THAT FOCUS
ON COMPREHENSIVE UPGRADES TO
CRITICAL COMMUNITY
INSTITUTIONS. THIS PROGRAM WILL
BE A ONE STOP SHOP THAT
INCLUDES DIRECT TECHNICAL
SYSTEMS AND FUNDING FOR SUITE
UPGRADES FOR COMMUNITY
INSTITUTIONS THAT SUPPORT
CALIFORNIA'S MOST VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS THIS PROJECT
PROJECT MUST ALSO DEMONSTRATE
COMEDIAN GAUGE MEN AND REFLECT
GEOGRAPHIC DIVERSITY OF THE
STATE THESE ONLY PROJECT ACROSS
THE ENTIRE STATE. THIS PROGRAM
WILL ALSO CREATE FAMILY
SUPPORTING JOBS AND SPUR
VALUABLE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
TO KEEP CALIFORNIA AT THE
FOREFRONT OF CLEAN TECHNOLOGIES
AND HIGH QUALITY WORK IN
BUILDINGS. I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE ON EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN I WOULD BE HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY TECHNICAL.
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WITNESS
PLEASE. MORNING CHERRY AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY NAME IS
CAROLYN CHANG AND I'M HERE WITH
THE ASIAN PACIFIC ENVIRONMENTAL
NETWORK AT THE COOK ONCE
THEY'RE IN STRONG SUPPORT AB
TEN EIGHTY SEVEN ALONGSIDE THE
HIGH ENERGY. IF THE CLOTHES
BASED ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
ORGANIZATION A NUMBER OF THE
ASIAN IMMIGRANT AND REFUGEE
COMMUNITIES AT THE FRONT LINES
OF CLIMATE CHANGE. OUR MEMBERS
ARE THINKING LOCAL CRISES CODED
BOXCARS. POORLY COMMUNICATED
HARSH AN OPTION WITH YOU. ON
THE ACTIVITIES I THANK HAVE
BEEN EXACERBATED BY THE POOR
AIR QUALITY OUR COMMUNITY
ALREADY FACE DAILY AND I
CONCRETE INVESTMENT AND
ECONOMIC INSECURITY. AFTER
YEARS EIGHT HUNDRED HAVE BEEN
FIGHTING FOR A JOB DONE THAT
ACTUALLY. BENEFITS COMMUNITY.
ENRICHMENT WE'RE WORKING
PROVIDE NEW THANK TO MAKE IT
INTO A PLAN HAD. WON COOPER IT
WILL BE IF THEY A CRISIS JUST
CAN HEALTH IN ORDER. IT WILL
HAVE A SOLAR AND STORAGE BACK
DOWN TO POWER EMERGENCY
RESPONSE HE WON AT FOURTEEN HAS
BEEN WORKING HARD. I LEADING
ACTORS BECAUSE THEY- AND ARE
PLANNING THAT CONGRESS. AROUND
BATTERY STORAGE. I AM VERY
CONCERNED AND INFRASTRUCTURE I
CAN ALL BEEN TO KEEP EACH OTHER
SAFE. I THINK ALREADY ATTRACTED
BASED PROVIDE CREE IS THE
BUILDING PROGRAM. BUT IN ORDER
FOR BILLION ALL CONDITION AND
TO REALLY BE AND IT'S THAT MOST
LIKELY WILL UPGRADE OPERATE AND
NOT TAKE THREE COURSES. AB
SEVEN AT THE CHIU IN THE CHANCE
TO PROVIDE JUST THAT NOT JUST
FOR RICHMOND USED A DIVERSE
TEAM BE GREEN NEED ACROSS THE-
IF THE CHANCE TO SHINE. AFTER
ENTRY MASON WE CAN RELY ON NOT
JUST AFTER SHE- ON A DAILY. BUT
THAT I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
VOTE ON. EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY.
THANK I'M NEXT WEEK. ONE
WITNESS AN OP. VALERIE TO
RELATIVE FROM. MODERATOR CAME
PLEASE UP LINE. YOUR LINE IS UP.
GOOD MORNING- MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
VALERIE CALABASAS- GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY AND
REGRETTABLY PG&E DOES OPPOSE A.
B. TEN EIGHTY SEVEN HE DOES
SUPPORT EFFORTS TO ENHANCE
RESILIENCY IN OUR COMMUNITY AS
WE FACE THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE
CHANGE- WE WANT TO FIND
POSSIBLY FOR OUR COMMUNITY TO
BE RESILIENT ESPECIALLY FOR
THOSE. MOST VULNERABLE. FOR
EXAMPLE PDF WERE WITH SMALL
COALITION AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL-
IT SHOULD BRING- STATE MONEY TO
JEFF. ALBERT BILL FOR TO DO.
UNFORTUNATELY THE IS WHERE WE
PART WAYS WITH OUR AND- PG&E
OPPOSE USING WHOLE BELT IN THE
CLAIM CREDIT FOR THIS PURPOSE.
THE CLIMB CREDIT- AT THE CANAL
QUITE OUT ALREADY A 50% THAT IT-
AND THAT IS ALL MULTIPLE PEOPLE
BUT BUDGET PLACE BUT HAVE- BEEN
WELL HI. THE CARD IS A BILL
MECHANISM FOR KEPT. AS WE TRAIN
TO A LOW HEAT. AND IT WRECKED
THE INVESTMENT BUT THEY'VE ARE
MADE- TO BE. IT WE- THAT THIS-
SATISFY- WITH THE AMENDMENTS BY
ALL TODAY. HE DIDN'T SMALLER IN-
AN EXAM QUALIFIED LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS FROM PAYING. BUT WHO
WOULD NOT EXAM FOR EXAMPLE A
SINGLE PARENT ONE CHILD IF THEY
MAKE THIRTY FOUR THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR. THEY'RE
GOING TO BE WITHOUT THE- SO AT
THIS TIME WHEN OF PORTABILITY
IN THE UTILITY BILL IS CRITICAL
AND THERE'S SO MANY OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES. TO SECURE
ALTERNATIVE FUNDING. PG&E
REGRETTABLY- I SUPPOSE EIGHTY
POINT EIGHTY SEVEN FUTURE THAT.
PROPOSED SPENDING PART THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M NEXT WILL
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON
THIS BILL. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO COMMENT THAT EIGHTY TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
AND THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND
I CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT TWENTY
IN Q. OR TRYING TO TWENTY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR NUMBERS MENTIONED
WHAT MUCH OF WHAT THE
CONTRACTOR IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
YOU TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
ONE EIGHT TWO. RIGHT ONE
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THANK
YOU CAN TONE DOWN ADVOCACY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR
AND STORAGE ASSOCIATION WITH
THE SUPPORT AND AMENDED
CONDITIONS THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TWENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CALIFORNIA WE GET
CONSERVATION. YOU'RE RIGHT TO
THIRTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. G.
MINOR ON BEHALF OF MP SERVING
CUSTOMERS IN CONTRA COSTA
SOLANO NAPA MARIN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MATT WAS A ABOUT THE AS YET YOU
CALIFORNIA WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE BILL
BUT SPREE SHAPE THE WORK AND
CONTINUE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
AUTHORED SPONSOR AND- URGED
MEMBERS TO VOTE YES THAT WE CAN-CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO FIFTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THE CALPERS BOARD
WITH SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA EDISON
REGRETTABLY OPPOSE. THANK YOU
ARE TWO TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ERIN RODRIGUEZ AT UNION OF
CONCERNED SCIENTISTS AND
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RISE TO
THIRTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BECAUSE THE GOVERNMENT IN
SUPPORT ON BEHALF OF THE
FOLLOWING ORGANIZATIONS
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE ALLIANCE STRATEGIC
CONCEPTS AND ORGANIZING AND
POLICY EDUCATION. CENTRAL COAST
ALLIANCE UNITED FOR SCALABLE
ECONOMY PHYSICIANS FOR SOCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY LA CENTER FOR
COMMUNITY ACTION AND
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE AND THE
SAN ANDREAS POVERTY AND THE
ENVIRONMENT. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS ON YOUR OF
ALL ON BEHALF OF A LARGE
COALITION IN SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL INCLUDING THE GREEN LINING
INSTITUTE CALIFORNIA RELEASED
COLLECTION FOR CALIFORNIA GREEN
NEW DEAL RECLAIM OUR POWER
USUALLY GET THIS CAMPAIGN VOTE
SOLAR. NO I CAL RESILIENCE
NETWORK CALIFORNIA ALLIANCE FOR
COMMUNITY ENERGY GREEN BANK
ASSOCIATE CLEAN WATER ACTION
AND ROCKY MOUNTAIN INSTITUTE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO THIRTY TO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THE MORNING PERJURE
MCKAY ON BEHALF OF FUTURE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO FOURTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS ROGER
DICKINSON ON BEHALF OF THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMISSION IN
SUPPORT THANKS VERY MUCH. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO ALIVE IN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MARGOT PARTS
OF BUT YOU CAN'T CONTROL AND
I'M HERE JUST BRIEFLY TO THANK
THE AUTHOR FOR CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THAT I'M IN THE
GROUP- INDUSTRIAL I IN
COMMERCIAL- ON RATE PAYERS WE
BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE REACHED A
CONSENSUS ON LANGUAGE AND SO. I
LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING AND
PRINT WE CAN WITH. OUR
OPPOSITION THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YES HI THIS IS
YOUR BONTA MORALISTIC
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL WE SUPPORT
IN CONCEPT AND ENCOURAGE THE
ADDITION OF LANGUAGE
ACCORDINGLY WE RECOMMEND
EXPANDING EIGHTY TEN EIGHTY
SEVEN INCLUDE LANGUAGE
EXPRESSING THE NEED AND URGENCY
OF THE STATE TO MAKE CAPITAL.
IS PRESENT YOUR NAME.
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. THANK YOU. SURE I'M ONE
OF SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HEY
THAT THE CLEANING GONZALEZ ON
BEHALF OF HIM AND CLIMATE
SOLUTIONS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU RIGHT EIGHTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE ISRAEL HOLLIS WITH
SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
COMPANY IN OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I CHORE SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GUTIERREZ ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WHICH OPPOSES
THE BILL'S PROVISIONS REGARDING
THE USE OF RECORD DESIGNATED
FUND. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT ONE
FIFTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOUR ME TIME TO ENGAGE STUDENTS
FROM TOP POLICEMAN A PEACEFUL
YES AND EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU
RIGHT SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. PHIL MURPHY ON BEHALF OF
THREE FIFTY SILICON VALLEY IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. MORE
TO GET A NUMBER OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURES
TECHNOLOGY SO SHE CURRENTLY ARE
OPPOSING THE COMMITTEE THANK.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LOW INCOME
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA GOING INTO PORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ALL RIGHT
TO THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YEAH OVER THERE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
IN OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU
AT THIS TIME HER THINK WE WERE
AT THE FIVE MINUTE GOOD MORNING
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS I'M WE'RE
AT FIVE MINUTES- OF ACCEPTING
WITNESSES- IN WHICH- WE ARE
LIMITING IT TO BUT IF THERE IS
ANYONE ELSE THAT WANTS TO
SUBMIT. OF THEIR POSITION ON
THIS BILL- YOU CAN DO IT VIA
OUR WEBSITE THE COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE THANK YOU. I'M AT. DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM I DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE- ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I REQUEST MR SARATH
SO DO YOU HAVE AN ESTIMATE OF
HOW MUCH THE SHIFT IS FROM
CONSUMERS INTO THIS PROGRAM.
ABSOLUTELY SO- FIRST OF ALL I
SHOULD HAVE MENTIONED THAT WHEN
WE ORIGINALLY PROPOSED THIS
BILL WE PROPOSED AN EIGHTY FIVE
PERCENT- USE OF THE CLIMATE
CREDIT IN THE LAST COMMITTEE
THAT OT TAKEN DOWN FROM 85%
DOWN TO FIVE PERCENT. BOB SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A VERY
SMALL PORTION OF THE COST OF
THE CLIMATE CREDIT- THERE WILL
BE NO IMPACT ON LOW INCOME
CUSTOMERS BECAUSE WE EXEMPT
OUT- FOLKS ARE PARTICIPATING IN
THE CARE PROGRAM AND IN THE
FAIR PROGRAM. AND THEN WITHIN
MINUTES WERE TAKEN IN THIS
COMMITTEE WE'RE ACTUALLY ALSO
EXEMPTING OUT INDUSTRIAL
ASSISTANCE AND SMALL BUSINESS
CREDIT SO. THERE WILL BE NO
IMPACT AND NO NON RESIDENTIAL
CUSTOMERS AS WELL AS NO IMPACT
ON GIGI R. F. OR ANY THE
PROGRAMS THAT SUPPORTED THERE
SO THE CUSTOMERS WHO WILL BE
IMPACTED WILL ONLY SEE A
REDUCTION OF ABOUT FIFTY CENTS
PER MONTH. SO THAT'S WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT. I'M I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE TOTAL AMOUNT OF THE
TOTAL MARKET SURE I THINK IT'S-
I THINK IT'S IN THE FORTY
MILLION RANGE I'M JUST I WANT
TO ASK- MERION FROM ENERGY SEE
IF YOU HAVE THE NUMBER. THE
FINAL NUMBER. YEAH IT'S- IT'S
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR FIVE YEARS. THE FIFTY FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR FIVE
YEARS AND HOW MUCH IS THIS
PROGRAM. GOING TO I MEAN IF THE
PROGRAM WERE DONE BECAUSE
BEFORE YOU SAID THESE ARE
ENERGY I MEAN IT WAS BROUGHT
DOWN TO FIVE PERCENT. AND SO
OBVIOUSLY AT 80% THEY THOUGHT
THEY WERE GOING TO BE FUNDING
MUCH MORE IS THAT HOW MUCH. A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM WOULD BE.
WELL IT LET ME LET ME JUST SAY
WHAT I THINK THERE IS CONSENSUS
ON FROM EVERYONE INVOLVED THIS
CONVERSATION WITH YOU SUPPORT
THIS PROPOSAL WHICH IS THE NEED
IS SOMETHING WE ALL SHARE WE
KNOW THAT THESE ARE. COMMUNITY
HUBS RESILIENCY HUBS THAT NEED
TO BE HARDENED AGAINST CLIMATE
CHANGE AND CLIMATE CRISIS- IT
OPEN UP TO ME. OBVIOUSLY WENT
FROM EIGHTY FIVE DOWN 25% SO I
WOULD'VE BEEN FINE FOR US TO.
HAVE EXPENDITURES SEVENTEEN
TIMES OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT. BUT BUT AT LEAST BEING
ABLE TO DO SOMETHING IN THE
SPACE IS ABSOLUTELY CRITICAL
AND WE THINK- AND CERTAINLY THE
LAST COMMITTEE- UNC. THOUGHT
THAT IT MADE SENSE FOR US TO
MOVE FORWARD OF THIS SO THAT WE
PILOTED. A FOR THE NEXT FIVE
YEARS CD IMPACT- BECAUSE WE
NOTICE ARE AVAILABLE
COMMUNITIES IT'S OUR LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES. IT'S A LOT OF OUR
RURAL COMMUNITIES- THAT ARE IN
DIRE NEED OF THIS I KNOW FOR
YOURSELF AS A FORMER
FIREFIGHTER YOU KNOW THAT
ACUTELY. RIGHT AND I DO KNOW
THAT ACUTELY AND THAT'S WHY FOR
ME IT'S MORE OF AN ISSUE OF.
THE PROGRAM IS DESPERATELY
NEEDED. BUT WERE JUST MINIMALLY
FUNDING IT AND WE'RE DOING THAT
ON YOU KNOW BY TRANSFERRING
MONEY FROM CONSUMERS ENDED THIS
INSTEAD OF USING SOME OF THE
MONEY THEY'VE ALREADY PAID IN
TAXES. AND CREATED THIS LARGE
BUDGET THAT WE HAVE- BUDGET
SURPLUS THAT WE HAVE. WE SHOULD
JUST PARTNER PRO USING THAT SO
SOME OF THAT SURPLUS TO DO THIS
BECAUSE THIS IS REALLY
IMPORTANT. SOURCE OF THIS
LITTLE DROP IN THE BUCKET MONEY
IS NOT GOING TO. MAKE A HUGE
IMPACT ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE IN
THE NEAR TERM WHICH IS WHEN IT
NEEDS TO BE DONE. SO THAT'S MY
ISSUE WITH IT SO THANK YOU.
APPRECIATE THAT AND I KNOW YOU
KNOW LISTEN. TO A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS IS NOT TRIVIAL. AND
THERE HASN'T BEEN CONSISTENT IN
THE PAST ON EXACTLY HOW WHAT
MONIES WE USE AND SO WE THINK
THAT THIS IS THE BEST. A
PROPOSAL TO MOVE THIS FORWARD
IN A TIMELY WAY- BUT AGAIN
RESPECTFULLY I. APPRECIATE THAT
THERE ARE DIFFERENCES OF
OPINION ON THIS. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. MR TWO WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE CERTAINLY YOU
KNOW AS I STATED BEFORE- THIS
IS A MODEST AMOUNT OF FUNDING
TO HELP UPGRADE CRITICAL
FACILITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES TO INCREASE
RESILIENCY OF OUR COMMUNITY
STERN CLIMATE CRISIS AND WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
SUPPORT. THE MOTION. IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS- ARE. WITH
YOU I DON'T BELIEVE I HAVE A
MOTION FROM. OKAY MY MOVED BY A
MISTER STONE SECONDED BY MISS
GARCIA I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I DO MATE AB TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
CHIU THE MOTION IS TO PASS A
REFER TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA NO CHILD.
FRIEDMAN GARCIA GARCIA I MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY WROTE TO G.
SAY ARCHER NO THERE ARE TURNOUT
STONE. STONE I WOULD. THREE
THREE THANK YOU COLLEAGUES
THREE THREE WILL LEAVE THAT ON
CALL THANK YOU NEXT UP MR KOHLI
AND AB NINE NINE TWO. THE BILL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH GOOD
AFTERNOON OR GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS HERE TODAY
PRESENTED AB NINE NINE TWO.
AND- THIS IS A BILL ABOUT OUR
BATTLE FOR CLEAN AIR AND IT'S
SORT OF. IN THAT BATTLE YOU
WANT TO USE EVERY TOOL IN THE
TOOL KIT THAT'S WHAT THIS
ELECTION RELATES TO. ARE
CURRENTLY THE CALIFORNIA AIR
RESOURCES BOARD IMPLEMENTS A
CLEAN TRUCK BUS AND OFF ROAD
VEHICLE PROGRAM. US OTHERS WERE
GETTING THESE CLEAN TRUCKS OUT
THERE BUT IT DOES NOT ALLOW THE
USE OF THOSE TRUCKS. VIA A PEER
TO PEER TRUCK SHARING PLATFORM.
THAT MEANS ALTHOUGH WE HAVE
CLEAN TRUCKS SOME OF THEM ARE
SITTING IDLE WHEN THEY MIGHT
OTHERWISE BE USED. IF THEY WERE
SHARED- THIS BILL ALLOWS FOR A
DEMONSTRATION WHERE USERS CAN
PLACE YOUR VEHICLE ON A TRUCK
SHARING PLATFORM. WHICH WILL
PERMIT THE VEHICLE BE USED
INSTEAD OF SITTING IDLE. IT
WILL HELP CALIFORNIA IN OUR
QUEST TO REACH. OUR GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION GOALS. BY USING A
CREATIVE IDEA LET'S SMALLER AND
INDEPENDENT BUSINESSES AND
INDEPENDENT OVER TRUCK DRIVERS-
USER TRUCKS MORE. AND HAVE
ACCESS TO A BROAD ARRAY OF
CLEAN TRUCKS TO CARRY OUR GOALS
FORWARD. I HAVE I BELIEVE
MONISHA MERCHANT. WITH FOOD
TRUCK- HERE AS A WITNESS BUT
THAT'S THE BILL I THANK YOU
VERY MUCH AFTER TO BE HERE
TODAY. TO BE HERE WITH YOU
THANK YOU. A MODERATOR CAME
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
MANISH. A MERCHANT FROM FOOD
TRUCK. YOUR LINE IS OPEN. I
THINK YOUR NUMBER A MEMBER
COOLEY FOR INTRODUCING THIS
BATTLE AND THANK YOU FOR TODAY
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE FOR-
ALLOWING ME TO- TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF THE SPONSOR OF AB
NINE NINE TWO. FIVE EIGHTY NINE
NINE TWO WILL EXPAND SMALL
MINORITY OWNED BUSINESSES
ACCESS TO ZERO EMISSION CARGO
VANS AND TRUCKS. CALIFORNIANS
INCENTIVE PROGRAMS BY ALLOWING
OWNERS TO RECEIVE PROGRAM
FUNDING TO OFFER THEIR VEHICLES
ON TRACK SHARING PLATFORMS.
CAPTURING PLATFORMS LIKE FLUID
TRACK ARE INSTRUMENTAL IN
GETTING MORE ZERO EMISSION
TRUCKS ON THE ROAD IN
CALIFORNIA. FIVE MINUTES AN AS
WE'VE HEARD EARLIER IN THE
DISCUSSION AND YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO FIND CREATIVE WAYS TO
REDUCE EMISSIONS OF HER DAY TO
DAY USE- AND IF THE COMING
INCREDIBLY MORE IMPORTANT. SO
PURCHASERS CAN WHO ARE GETTING
IN THE BENEFIT OF THE INCENTIVE
PROGRAMS WOULD BE ABLE TO LIFT
THEIR VEHICLES ON. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY MENTIONED. WILD
THEIR VEHICLE BE NOT IN USE FOR
THEIR DAY TO DAY WORK IT COULD
BE AVAILABLE TO. BROADLY
AVAILABLE REALLY CO DIVERSE
GROUP OF SMALL AND MEDIUM
BUSINESSES AND BENEFITING JUST
IDLE IN THE GARAGE- AND YOU
KNOW WE'VE TALKED TO BUSINESS
OWNERS LIKE TIFFANY SCALIA WHO
FOUNDED PASADENA BASED- ABOUT
BROUGH COMPANY. I'M IN THE CITY
OF PASADENA LOCAL CITY PARKING
RESTRICTIONS ACTUALLY WILL NOT
ALLOW HER TO PARK THE VEHICLE
IN FRONT OF OUR STORE FRONT AND
SO IF SHE WERE TO PURCHASE A
VEHICLE SHE WOULD NEED TO TURN
OFF THE RENT A PARKING SPACE-
WHILE IT REMAINS IDLE- SO SHE
WOULD LIKE TO ACCESS A WIDE
VARIETY AND THEIR EMISSION
VEHICLES COMMUTER BUSINESS
NEEDS. WHILE ALSO BEING PART OF
VINO THE LOCAL EFFORTS TO
REDUCE. EMISSIONS AND HER
DELIVERY AREA. THAT SHARING
MODEL PROVIDE ACCESS TO THE
ZERO EMISSION VEHICLES AT A
LOWER COST. ENABLING DIVERSE
ENTREPRENEURS TO ENTER THE
GROWING DELIVERY AND LOGISTICS
INDUSTRY MARCHING Q. PLANET
ROCK ASSEMBLY MEMBER PASSED THE
TWO MINUTES. OH I'M SORRY SO
FOOD TRUCK LOOK FORWARD TO
PARTNERING WITH CARD TO SHOW
THE EMISSION REDUCTIONS AND AIR
QUALITY IMPROVEMENTS FOR THESE
REASONS FLUID TRACTORS PROUD TO
SPONSOR EIGHTY NINE NINETEEN
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE ON THIS MEASURE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU I'M NEXT WILL
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR SUPPORT
OR OPPOSITION. HE'S JUST STATE
NAME AFFILIATION AND YOUR
POSITION ON THE BILL. Q. IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK AND EIGHTY NINE
NINE TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION. THERE ARE NONE
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS IN THE
COMMITTEE- MISTER MATHIS THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR JUST JUST
BRIEFLY MISTER COOLEY AYE I
KNOW YOU'RE BILLS ON CONSENT
AND- MAY I KNOW YOU UNDERSTAND
WHY WE PULLED BILLS OFF BECAUSE
WE WANT TO ENSURE THAT ALL
BILLS ARE BEING SAID BEING
HEARD WE DO SUPPORT YOUR BELT
AND APPRECIATE YOUR HARD WORK
ON THIS. THANK YOU AS MATHIS.
FOR MUCH WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE. I JUST THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE I'VE ENJOYED FOLLOWING
YOUR WORK TODAY FROM EARLY ON
BUT- VERY PLEASED TO BE IN THIS
COMMITTEE I REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU. FOR THE MOTION IS.
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER MATHIS
SECOND BY MR SAY ARE TOLD
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
I DO NINE EIGHTY NINE NINETY
TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOLEY
MEMBERS RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE
FLORA. FLORA I'D CHAU. FRIEDMAN
GARCIA. MATHIS ARE MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY RIGHT TO CHOOSE THEIR
CHILD HI THERE TO ALL AYE STONE.
STONE I WOULD. FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO- DOUBLES ON CALL THANK YOU
MUCH THANK. C. NEXT UP MISTER
COOPER PRESENTING AB THREE
FIFTY FOUR. SORRY THERE. WE'RE
ABOUT HALFWAY THERE AWESOME
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS- IN ORDER FOR
CALIFORNIA TO CONTINUE ON THIS
PATH TOWARDS A SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE CALIFORNIANS NEED TO
BEGIN TO MODERNIZE THEIR HOMES
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE FIVE FOUR
WILL HELP LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS PURCHASE ENERGY
EFFICIENT APPLIANCES. IT WILL
HELP US NOT ONLY REACH OUR
GOALS WILL HELP WORKING
FAMILIES WITH THEIR EVER RISING
ENERGY COSTS AB THREE FIVE FOUR
WOULD REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO CREATE A
THREE YEAR APPLIANCE REBATE
PROGRAM PROVIDES ELIGIBLE
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS. OF
ELECTRIC GAS OR UTILITY WITH
MONETARY INCENTIVES INCENTIVES
TO PURCHASE NEW APPLIANCES THAT
MEET ENERGY EFFICIENCY
STANDARDS APPROVED BY THE
COMMISSION THE BILL LIMIT
ELIGIBILITY TO THE PROGRAM TO
THOSE CUSTOMERS WITH ANNUAL
HOUSEHOLD INCOMES THAT ARE NO
GREATER THAN 2% OF THE FEDERAL
POVERTY RATE. WOULD LIMIT
REBATES TO APPLIANCES PURCHASED
FOR ELIGIBLE CUSTOMERS PRIMARY
RESIDENCE IN LIMIT A CUSTOMER
TO NO MORE THAN THREE REBATES.
OKAY I'M DO YOU HAVE A WITNESS.
IN SUPPORT I HAVE TIFFANY FAN
YESTERDAY. THE MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR
MISS TIFFANY FANT. CURRENTLY I
DON'T SEE HER DIALED IN
TIFFANY'S FAN IF YOU ARE ARM
PLEASE PRESS STAR ZERO SO I CAN
OPEN YOUR LINE. ONE MOMENT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CURRENTLY I
DON'T SEE HER DIAL THAT OKAY SO
LET'S MOVE ON TO WITNESSES AND
SUPPORTED OR OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO COMMENT ON EIGHTY THREE FIVE
FOUR PLEASE PRESS ONE AND ZERO
AT THIS TIME. HAVE A COMMENT
FROM LINE TO FORTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING SURE
MEMBERS ASSISTED ME BAN ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA IF IT
SHOULD BE AND DEMAND MANAGEMENT
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR IN THE REMOTE
LOCATION. DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS. THERE
ARE NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE YES MADAM CHAIR
RESIDENTIAL CUSTOMERS ARE PRICE
SENSITIVE WITH RESPECT TO
PURCHASING APPLIANCES AND WITH
THE ECONOMIC IMPACT OF COVER
NINETEEN HAVE EXACERBATED THAT
SENSITIVITY FOR MANY
CALIFORNIANS. APPLIANCE REBATES
CAN HELP WORKING INDIVIDUALS
AND FAMILIES MAKE THE
TRANSITION TO MORE EFFICIENT
HOUSEHOLD APPLIANCES WHICH TO
HELP REDUCE STATEWIDE ENERGY
CONSUMPTION SAVE HOUSEHOLDS
MONEY INSTANTLY THE ECONOMY
THROUGH APPLIANCE PURCHASES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS WE
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER MATHIS
SECONDED. BY MISTER C. R. TOTAL
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I AM TEN AB THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COOPER. MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA
I CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA. MATHIS
MATHIS AYE MCCARTY WROTE TO G.
SAY ARTHUR HI SIR TO AYE STONE.
STONE I WOULD. FIVE ZERO FIVE
ZERO YOUR THE BILL WILL REMAIN
OPEN THANK YOU FOR THANK YOU.
I'M NEXT UP MR FRAZIER
PRESENTING AB. FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE. THAT. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS I'D LIKE TO START
BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. THE PAST SEVERAL
DECADES WILDFIRES HAVE
INCREASED IN INTENSITY AND
DESTRUCTIVENESS THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. USING FOR
AN AVERAGE OF ABOUT SIXTY
THOUSAND ACRES ANNUALLY BETWEEN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES THE
NINETEEN NINETIES TO MORE THAN
ONE MILLION ACRES ANNUALLY THIS
DECADE. THE CONDITION OF
CALIFORNIA'S FORCE HAVE LED TO
HIGHER INTENSITY WILDFIRES THAT
ARE FAR MORE DESTRUCTIVE. THAN
WHEN THE FORESTS AND WILDLANDS
WE'RE IN A MORE ECOLOGICALLY
BENEFICIAL RESILIENT INDIVIDUAL.
WILDFIRES IN CALIFORNIA HAVE
ALSO BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT SOURCES OF
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS AND
POLLUTION. IN TWENTY EIGHTEEN A
BROAD REPRESENTATION OF LOCAL
STATE FEDERAL AGENCIES FINALIZE
CALIFORNIA'S FORCE CARBON PLAN
TO SET GOALS TO IMPROVE FOREST
HEALTH. EVENT AND REDUCE
GREENHOUSE GAS EMISSIONS FROM
HIGH SEVERITY WILDFIRES AND
PROMOTE CARBON SIX QUEST
CREATION ENFORCE AND WILDLANDS.
THE PLAN IS THE RESULT OF
SEVERAL YEARS OF CAREFUL
COLLABORATION INCLUDES
VEGETATION MANAGEMENT AND FUELS
TREATMENT STRATEGIES. FOR
CARBON PLAN SCHOOLS ALSO SERVE
AS THE FOUNDATION FOR GOVERNOR
NEWSOM'S MOST RECENT FORCE
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE ACTION
PLAN. WELL OFTEN CITED AS A
ROAD MAP FOR REDUCING EMISSIONS
FROM CALIFORNIA'S DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. THE CALIFORNIA
FOREST CARBON PLAN GOALS HAVE
NO STATUTORY AUTHORITY BEHIND
THEM. TO DEMONSTRATE THE
STATE'S COMMITMENTS TO
IMPROVING FOREST HEALTH. REDUCE
THE RISK OF WILDFIE AND
INCREASING CARBON SEQUESTRATION.
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE DOES THE
FOLLOWING. CODIFIES THE HIGHEST
PRIORITY GOALS OF CALIFORNIA'S
CALIFORNIA FOREST CARBON PLAN
AND STRESSES THE URGENCY OF
IMPROVING FOREST HEALTH. AND
REDUCING GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS FROM WILDFIRES. IT
REQUIRES THE STATE TO IDENTIFY
THE FOUR RESOURCES NECESSARY TO
ACHIEVE THOSE GOALS. AND
FINALLY PROVIDES THE
LEGISLATURE GREATER OVERSIGHT
BY REQUIRING. CAL THE
CALIFORNIA NATURAL RESOURCES
AGENCY AND CAL EPA TO REPORT
ANNUALLY ON THE PROGRESS OF
MEETING THESE GOALS. I DO
APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEES FIND
WORK TO APPROVE THIS BILL AND
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH STAKEHOLDERS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND HAVE WITH MEANS. IN
SUPPORT JOHN KENNEDY WITH A
RURAL COUNTY REPRESENTATIVES OF
CALIFORNIA AND JULIA HALL WITH
THE ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
WATER AGENCIES AND TEST. TO
TESTIFIES WORD PT AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE. THANK YOU. THE
MODERATOR CAME PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU BOTH LINES
ARE OPEN.8OD
IS JOHN KENNEDY I'M HERE TODAY
ON BEHALF OF THE WORLD COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
RC RC IS PLEASED TO SPONSOR AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE WHICH SEEKS
TO CODIFY FORCED HEALTH
IMPROVEMENT WILDFIRE PREVENTION
AND CARBON SEQUESTRATION GOALS
OUTLINED IN THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN
CALIFORNIA FORCED CARBON PLAN
AND THE CALIFORNIA FORCED
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCES MORE
RECENT WILDFIRE AND FOREST
RESILIENCE ACTION PLAN. RT RT
MEMBER COUNTIES CONTAINMENT
MUCH OF CALIFORNIA'S FORESTED
LANDS INCLUDING MORE THAN 70%
OF THE STATE'S NATIONAL FOREST
LANDS ARE COMMUNITIES THAT
HISTORICALLY MORE THE MAJORITY
OF DESTRUCTION CAUSED BY HIGH
SEVERITY WILDFIRES BUT THOSE
RESEARCHERS SPREADING
THROUGHOUT THE STATE AS A
RESULT OF CLIMATE CHANGE YOU'LL
LOADS AND THE IMPACT OF A
RENEWED DROUGHT. WILDFIRES OVER
THE LAST FEW YEARS HAVE BEEN
ESPECIALLY HORRIFIC BOTH IN
TERMS OF THE NUMBER OF LIVES
INSTRUCTORS LOST BURNED
INCLUDING ROUGHLY 4% OF THE
STATE LAST YEAR ALONE. WELL
WILDFIRE HAS ALWAYS HAD A PLACE
IN THE CALIFORNIA ECOSYSTEM
MODERN FIRES ARE FAR MORE
DESTRUCTIVE IN ADDITION TO THE
MASSIVE AMOUNT OF GG EMISSIONS
RESULTING FROM WILDFIRES AND
POST FIRE TO K. WHILE PARLAYED
AIR POLLUTION IS BECOMING A
BIGGER AND BIGGER PROBLEM EVEN
IN DISTANT URBAN AREAS. JUST IS
AB THIRTY TWO SB THIRTY TWO
CODIFIED STATE GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSION REDUCTION GOALS AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE SEEKS TO
CODIFY THE FORCED IMPROVEMENT
GOALS SET FORTH BY THE FORCE
CLIMATE ACTION TEAM. ARE HERE
HE WAS A PROUD PARTICIPANT AND
THE FORCE CLIMATE ACTION TEAM
AND BELIEVES THE GOALS TARGETS
AND STRATEGIES THEY SET FORTH
ARE VITAL TO THE FUTURE OF THE
RESILIENCE OF CALIFORNIA'S
FORESTS AND WILDLANDS AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE ALSO HELPS
IMPROVE THE STATE'S LONG TERM
PLANNING BY REQUIRING STATE
AGENCIES TO NOTIFY THE
LEGISLATURE WHAT RESOURCES ARE
NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE THOSE
GOALS. AND PROVIDE ANNUAL
PROGRESS UPDATES WE BELIEVE AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE GOES A LONG
WAY TO HELPING THE STATE
ACHIEVE ITS GOALS TO IMPROVE
FOREST HEALTH REDUCE WILDFIRE
RISK INCREASE CARBON
SEQUESTRATION AND FINALLY WE
THINK THE IMMINENT TOP BY THE
COMMITTEE TODAY REALLY IMPROVE.
THE BILL AND WE ASK FOR YOUR I.
PHONE. THANK YOU NECK WITNESS.
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN MAKING IS
JULIA HALL THAT UTILITIES OF
CALIFORNIA PREACHING AND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS BILL
BIPARTISAN BECOME MORE FREQUENT
AND SEVERE AS OUR CLIMATE IS
CHANGING URGENT ACTION IS
NEEDED TO ADDRESS STATE UNDER
MANAGE FORESTED LANDS. IN MAY
TWENTY EIGHTEEN THE STATE
RELEASED A REPORT ENTITLED THE
CALIFORNIA FOREST CARBON PLAN
MANAGING OUR FOREST LANDSCAPE
AND A CHANGING CLIMATE IN
TWENTY TWENTY CALIFORNIA THANK
AN AGREEMENT WITH THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT FOR SHARED
STEWARDSHIP OF CALIFORNIA'S
FOURTH AND RANGELAND WHICH EACH
PARTY HAD COMMITTED TO A GOAL
OF REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK ON
FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND ACRES OF
FOREST LAND PER YEAR. THIS YEAR
THE GOVERNMENT FOREST
MANAGEMENT TASK FORCE REALLY TO
COMPREHEND THE POOREST AND
WILDFIRE REGIONALLY ACTION PLAN
THAT WILL SERVE AS A ROADMAP
FOR IMPLEMENTING THAT
AGREEMENT. WITH THE PORT OF ALL
THESE EFFORTS TO ESTABLISH
GOALS AND A FRAMEWORK TO MAKE
CALIFORNIA MORE FIRE RESILIENT
AB FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE SIXTY
CODIFY GOALS THAT WERE OUTLINED
IN THE FORTHCOMING PLAN WHICH
OUTLINED A COMPREHENSIVE
STRATEGY TO RESTORE THE
RESILIENCE TO CALIFORNIA'S
FORESTS FORESTS OF WATERSHED
AND WILD LANDS BUT REDUCING THE
IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE IN
CRITERIA. POLLUTANTS FROM
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRES. THANK
COURT MANAGEMENT HAVE BECOME AN
URGENT. I THINK THE INCREASING
SEVERE. IN PART BECAUSE BACK
OVER GROWN UNDER MANAGE FORESTS.
THIS THREATENS THE HEAD OF THE
ENTIRE. AS WILDFIRE HARM CALL
AND SUPPLY IN DAMAGE. WHY
INTEREST. AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
ONE ELEVATE THE IMPORT OF
REDUCING. GAS EMISSIONS FROM
FOR IT WILL IMPROVING
HEADWATERS MANAGEMENT AND
REDUCING WILDFIRE RISK. THIS
BILL WILL CODIFY STATE GOALS TO
INCREASE FOREST MANAGEMENT
IMPROVE HEADWATERS HEALTH
ACROSS THE STATE AND HELP
PROVIDE A FRAMEWORK FOR FURTHER
ACTION BY FEDERAL STATE AND
LOCAL AGENCIES. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
BILL. THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES
FOR WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU
WISH TO SPEAK OUT AT FOURTEEN
THIRTY ONE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. AND I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I SEE ONE MADAM
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS CHRISTOPHER
KELLY ON BEHALF OF THE HUMBOLDT
AND MENDOCINO REDWOOD COMPANIES
WE DO HAVE A SUPPORT IF AMENDED
POSITION THANK. THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION I DON'T SEE ANY ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER SERICULTURE.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
REALLY IMPORTANT BILL- TO US
AND I THINK- IT'S NICE TO SEE
THE PEOPLE ARE FINALLY REALIZED
THAT MANAGING FORCE IS ACTUALLY
A REALLY IMPORTANT THING TO DO
IF WE'RE GOING TO GET A GRIP ON
THIS- DOES THIS. CARBON PLAN
THAT WE HOPE IT WILL YOU KNOW I
LOVE THE PLANS YEAH WE'VE
ALWAYS HAD PROBLEMS WITH THE
IMPLEMENTATION SOMETIMES WHEN
WE DO A PLAN WE ALSO INCLUDE
THE ENVIRONMENTAL PART OF THIS
SO THAT THE ENVIRONMENTAL PART
IS ALREADY DONE- SEQUEL IS ONE
OF THOSE DOCUMENTS THAT. I'M
I'M HOPING IS INCLUDED WHEN
THEY DO THE PLAN SO THAT EACH
PROJECT THAT COMES ALONG ISN'T
SUBJECTED TO HAVING TO DO THE
PROCESS OF SYKORA BECAUSE THAT
WILL UNDOUBTEDLY SLOW THE PLAN
DOWN. OR NOT ENABLE THESE
PROJECTS TO GET DONE IN A
TIMELY MANNER. SO EQUAL COVERED
AND THIS PLAN OR IS IT GOING TO
BE AN INDIVIDUAL THING SO
SEQUEL IT IS AN INDIVIDUAL
THING AT THIS POINT AND YOU
MAKE A GREAT- OBSERVATION- WHEN
I WAS THE CHAIR OF-TRANSPORTATION WE STARTED PRE
PRE MITIGATION PROCESSES. I
THINK THAT THAT WOULD BE A
WONDERFUL OPPORTUNITY TO AS YOU
AS SUGGESTED TO LOOK AT AND
MAKE SURE THAT THAT THAT IS
ADDRESSED AND CAN BE AN OPTION
OF MAKING SURE THAT THE OF
FORD- THINKING PROCESS WAS PUT
IN PLACE. TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS MOVES ALONG WE DO HAVE THE
OVERSIGHT OF THE LEGISLATURE IN
THERE ALSO TO MAKE SURE THAT
KALYAN PA AND NATURAL RESOURCES
OF AGENCIES ARE DOING WHAT WE
PUT INTO STATUTE BUT AS THE
BILL MOVES FOR WOULD LOVE TO
HAVE YOUR INPUT AND ANY OTHERS
FROM THE PUBLIC THAT WOULD MAKE
THIS A SUCCESSFUL OUTCOME.
RIGHT I DID HAVE A BILL THAT
TRIED TO ADDRESS THAT SO THAT
PROJECTS IMPORTANT BILLS LIKE
THIS CAN IT CAN BE CAN GO
THROUGH AND ACTUALLY PERFORM
WHAT THEY WANNA WHAT THEY
PLANNED FOR- BUT THAT'S NOT
BEING HEARD SO- IT'S UP TO EACH
OF YOU THE INDIVIDUAL BILLS
THAT COME FORWARD TO TRY TO
ADDRESS THAT BECAUSE OTHERWISE
WE'RE JUST GOING TO BE STUCK
DOING WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING THE
LAST THIRTY YEARS. WHICH IS
IDENTIFYING PROJECTS THAT NEED
DONE AND THEN TAKING FIVE YEARS
TO GET TO SEE QUITE TO BE ABLE
TO GET IT DONE SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH IT'S GREAT BILL SIR
THANK YOU AS. A NEW MEMBER
WELCOME TO OUR WORLD. THANK YOU
ANY OTHER. FROM MEMBERS. OKAY
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR IDOL OKAY
I HAVE A MOTION FOR MISTER
FLORA SECOND- BY MISTER MATHIS
THE MOTION IS DO YOU PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WOULD YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
SECRETARY ITEM ELEVEN AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA
I'D CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA.
MATHIS BROUGHT MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI CERTO I'D. SAY ARE
TO AYE STONE STONE AYE WOULD
WOULD I. FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WE
LEAVE THAT BILL OPENED YOU
MISTER THANK YOU MEASURE OKAY
WE- I'M MORE THAN HALFWAY THERE
WE HAVE TEN BLAH- WE'RE GOING
TO. GO AHEAD AND- HERE ITEM
FOURTEEN. MISTER SALAS AB THREE
TWO TWO. THANK MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M PLEASED PRESENTS
ASSEMBLY BILL THREE TWENTY TWO-
WHICH WILL DIRECT CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION TO CONSIDER
PRIORITIZE FUNDING FOR NEW
INNOVATIVE BIOMASS PROJECTS
EFFORT PROGRAM. ACCORDING TO
THE CALIFORNIA BOARD OF
FORESTRY MORE EPIC FUNDING IS
NEEDED FOR BIOMASS PROJECTS TO
REDUCE OPEN BURNING OF
AGRICULTURAL WASTE MITIGATE
WILDFIRE RISKS AND TO CREATE
CLEAN ENERGY TO STABILIZE OUR
GRIDS. AB THREE TWENTY TWO WILL
HELP REDUCE WASTE AND MEET OUR
CLIMATE GOALS BY INVESTING IN
THE NEXT GENERATION OF BIOMASS
PROJECTS WHICH WILL PRODUCE
RENEWABLE ENERGY OUT OF WASTE
THAT WOULD OTHERWISE BE PUT IN
A LANDFILL OR BURNED. AB THREE
TWENTY TWO IS SUPPORTED BY A
WIDE COALITION OF AIR DISTRICTS
WATER AND WASTE WATERAGENCIES
THIRTY SEVEN RURAL COUNTIES
RENEWABLE ENERGY STAKEHOLDERS
AND CLEAN ENERGY GROUPS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE- WITH ME
TO TESTIFY BY PHONE IN SUPPORT
IS A JULIA LEVINE THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR A
WITNESS. THANK YOU THEY'RE
RIGHT ABOUT THAT. GOOD MORNING
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JULIA
LEVIN WITH THE BIOENERGY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WE
ARE VERY PROUD TO SPONSOR AB
THREE TWO TWO WHICH WILL HELP
CALIFORNIA PUT ITS MILLIONS OF
TONS OF ORGANIC BIOMASS WASTE
TO BENEFICIAL USE. THAT IS
WASTE FROM FOREST AGRICULTURE
AND URBAN WOOD WASTE THAT WOULD
OTHERWISE GO TO LANDFILL. BE
PILED AND LEFT TO DECAY OR
PILED AND BURNED ALL OF WHICH
RELIEF RELEASED A VERY HARMFUL
SURE THE KIND OF POLLUTANTS AND
AIR POLLUTION IT WILL ALSO HELP
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENTS OF SB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE THE STATE SHORTLY
CONCRETE LAW TO DIVERT 75% OF
ORGANIC WASTE AWAY FROM
LANDFILLS BY TWENTY TWENTY
FIVE. THE VAST MAJORITY OF THAT
WAY IT IS WITH THE CELLULOSIC
WASTE AND THE MOST BENEFICIAL
REUSE OF THAT WASTE IS FOR
ENERGY. SO FOR ALL THESE
REASONS WE URGE THE COMMITTEE.
TO PASSED EIGHTY THREE TO TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NEXT WILL
OPEN A THE LINES FOR WHITNEY IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. Q. IF
YOU WISH TO SPEAK ON AB THREE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE
ABOUT THREE COMMENTS THINK
YOU'LL WATCH WIDENED TO FIFTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING TERM MEMBERS CRYSTAL HE
DOES ON BEHALF OF THE SOLID
WASTE ASSOCIATION OF NORTH
AMERICA LET'S TAKE A TASK FORCE
IN CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU. THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY
TO PLEASE GO AHEAD. BY TWO SIX
CHILL. HI THIS IS JOHN KENNEDY
WITH THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE TO
SIXTY THREE. THANK YOU TURN
MEMBERS RENEE IS TO IS TO WITH
THE WHITE MALE GROUP ON BEHALF
OF BLOOM ENERGY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT TO SIXTY
FOUR. JULIA HALL AT THE
EXHORTATION OF CALIFORNIA
LOTTERY COMPETE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE ONE
MORE CHEMISTRY HERE TO JUST BE
ONE MOMENT FOR THAT LINE.
THE
LAST COMMENT I HAVING Q. IS
GOING TO BE FROM LINE TO SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JULIET MALACHOWSKI BONTA ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
BIOMASS ENERGY ALLIANCE IN
SUPPORT OF AB THREE JUNE TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENTS THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU. I DON'T
SEE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM OR IN THE REMOTE
LOCATION. DO WE HAVE QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS JUST ONE. MISTER
SIR. SO- YOU MENTIONED THE
ORGANIC WE- AT. LEAST WISEMAN
ASSEMBLY ACTUALLY PART OF THE
END GAME WITH THAT BUT WE DON'T
HAVE A PLACE RIGHT FOR THIS
THIS BILL VERY IMPORTANT AND
BEING ABLE TO PUT IN THE
INFRASTRUCTURE. FORTY PROGRAM
IS GOING INTO END OF THE YEAR
YEAH. AB VISITED WITH THE. FOR
WE NEED THREE. AB APPRECIATE
THAT QUESTION I COULD TELL YOU
FROM THE SUCH VALLEY PER. A LOT
OF TIMES WHAT WILL HAPPEN IS
WE'LL TURN UP AN ORCHARD AND
I'LL PUT IT ALL IN THE MIDDLE
OF THE FIELD AND LIGHT A MATCH
TO IT WHICH CREATES A HUGE
ABOUT OF- PUBLIC HEALTH ISSUES
WITH ASTHMA RATES THROUGHOUT
THE CENTRAL VALLEY THIS WILL
PROVIDE AN OPPORTUNITY INSTEAD
OF LIGHTING A MATCH. TO THIS TO
ALL THE WOULD THE WOULD BE
WASTE IS ACTUALLY CREATE
RENEWABLE ENERGY OUT OF IT AND
I THINK THAT'S WHY YOU SEE THE
BROAD COALITION OF ENERGY
GROUPS THE AGENCIES AND
EVERYBODY IN SUPPORT OF THIS
ALL RIGHT WELL THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL AND-
ESPECIALLY BECAUSE OF THAT IT'S
SUPER IMPORTANT TO GET THAT IN
PLACE BECAUSE I DON'T SEE THAT
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION PROGRAM
BEING DELAYED. AND THERE'S JUST
NO PLACE FOR CITIES TO BE ABLE
TO DO THAT CITIES OUT IN YOUR
AREA BLIGHTED STUFF ABSOLUTELY
WE ALSO THAT ISSUE UP AND
ANALOG VALLEY KILEY RETHINKING
THE MIDDLE AND WHEN IT GOT
WRECKED AND I AND I WOULD I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD A YOU KNOW
THAT'S WHY EVEN THE CALIFORNIA
AIR RESOURCES BOARD IS ACTUALLY
A CALL FOR MORE INVESTMENT INTO
BIOMASS AS WELL BECAUSE OF SOME
OF THESE ISSUES. BUT ALSO EVEN
WITH THE FOREST MANAGEMENT
PLANS ARE ALSO CALLING FOR
INCREASED INVESTMENT. INTO
BIOMASS FACILITIES AS WELL. HEY
MISTER MATHIS. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR- VALLEY STRONG- SALAS
LOWER DOING- THE- I CAN'T SAY
ENOUGH ABOUT HOW IMPORTANT THIS
IS FOR DIVERSE IN OUR
PORTFOLIO- JUST THE SIMPLE FACT
THIS IS A 90% REDUCTION IN
EMISSIONS VERSUS AS YOU SAID
LIGHTING A MATCH- AND IT GOES
TO KEEP THE LIGHTS ON AND-
HEALTH OF OUR GREAT SO ANYTHING
I CAN DO THAT TO HELP YOU OUT
BESIDES MY AYE VOTE TODAY
PLEASE LET ME KNOW. THANK YOU
APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OKAY WE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MR SAY ARE TôI BELIEVE WE
NEED A SECOND SECOND BY MISTER
MATHIS SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. I AM FOURTEEN. AB
THREE TWENTY TWO BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA
I'D CHAU. FRIEDMAN GARCIA.
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI SARTELL HIGH SAY OUR
TWO EYES JONES. STONE I WOULD
WOOD I. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO APPLE
IS OUT BUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ADD ONS. NEXT YOU HAVE AB
SIX NINETY NINE YES THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I FOR ONE
OF FIRST START BY SAYING
THEY'LL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS WHICH
CORRECT THE TECHNICAL DRAFTING
ERROR PLEASE PRESENT A BILL SIX
NINETY NINE WHICH WILL
ESTABLISH A NEW REBATE PROGRAM
TOP UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES
PURCHASED SMART HOME APPLIANCES
LIKE THERMOSTATS PLUGS AND
STRIPS. AND RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE. THANK YOU. LEAVE
THERE'S ONE WITNESS YES I'M IN
SUPPORT MATT KLOPFENSTEIN SORRY
IF I MISPRONOUNCED THAT FROM
CALIFORNIA ADVISORS
REPRESENTING CENTER FOR
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY THANK YOU.
HE SAID. GOOD MORNING SURE
NUMBERS- THANK YOU SO MUCH THAT
HAS NOT COME TO THE NUMBER A
COMPANY VISORS ON BEHALF OF
INTERPRETABLE ENERGY WE'RE
PROUD CO SPONSORING THE SIX
NINETY NINE REALLY WANT TO
THANK THEM ARE SALAS AND HIS
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK AND ALSO
FOR THE COMMITTEES- VERY GREAT
WORKING CATCHING AYE AYE TACKLE
IN THE BILL- I'LL KEEP IT VERY
QUICK BUT IN SHORT EIGHTY SIX
NINETY NINE WILL HELP
CALIFORNIANS PREPARE FOR FUTURE
GREAT EMERGENCIES AS BESIDES
ESPECIALLY PARTNER THE BLACKOUT
THE TWENTY TWENTY. AND
ESPECIALLY BY EQUIPPING LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS WITH THE
TOOLS THAT THEY NEED TO
AUTOMATICALLY SPONDA GRANT WHEN
THERE ARE STRESSES ON THE
CREDIT IN ORDER TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF- TAKE A PROGRAM
THAT CAN EARN THE MONEY THAT
THE BILL WOULD ADD MALL GREAT
CONNECTED APPLIANCES INTO THAT
ENERGY SAVINGS ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM AND LEVERAGE THE TECHNO
WORK TECHNICAL WORK BEING DONE
BY THE CVC PER AT THE FORTY
NINE BY SENATOR SKINNER- AT
THIS BILL IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL- AND ALSO IT'S GOING TO BE
BUILT. INTO THE EXISTING HE'S
THAT PROGRAM SO IT DOESN'T-
COST REPAIRS ANY ADDITIONAL
DOLLARS- THANK YOU VERY MUCH
YOUR TIME HAVING INTERNET
QUESTIONS. AND RESPECTFULLY
QUESTION ABOUT. THANK YOU- NEXT
WILL MOVE TO. OUR WILL OPEN UP
THE FOR LINES FOR WITNESSES AND-
OR OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK I'M EIGHTY SIX NINE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT FIVE IN CUBA WERE
TRYING TO SEVENTY TWO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BIDS WERE
LARGER WITH THE CLOCK CENTER IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RYAN SIX NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
BILL MURPHY RIGHT AT THE
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I WANT TO WAIT PLEASE
LAD. METROLINK IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWELVE SIXTY CHEN. THANK YOU I
TWO SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GLAD.
TWO SEVEN ONE THIS IS GREG WITH-
THIS IS GREG QUICKLY CAN YOU
HEAR ME. YES AGREGUE WIKLER
CALIFORNIA PATIENTLY DEMAND
MANAGEMENT COUNCIL- I JUST
WANTED TO- IT TAKES THAT MUCH
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY SIX NINETY
NINE AND- WE ARE PROUD SPONSORS
OF THE OF THE LEGISLATION AND
WE- WE ASK FOR AYE VOTE ON. THE
LEGISLATION. THANK YOU RIGHT
CHIU FORTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. DANIEL GUTERRES ON
BEHALF OF TURN THE UTILITY
REFORM NETWORK WITH THE POST
POSITION ON THE BILL BUT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS WITH THE OFFICE. THANK
YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. OKAY
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM C. NINE NO
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION ANY QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. THERE ARE NONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE HIS FIRST
RESPECTFULLY ASK PRIVATE THANK
YOU THANK YOU SEE THE MOTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. I HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER MATHIS SECONDED BY
MR FLORA I'M SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. I DON'T FIFTEEN
AB SIXTY NINETY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER SALAS MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVERSIDE FLORIDA.
FLORIDA I CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA
MATHIS. MCCARTY MARTUCCI SAY
OUR JOB HI THERE TO ALL AYE
STONE STONE I WOULD. WOOD I
FIVE ZERO FIVE ZERO WILL LEAVE
THAT OPEN. UP NEXT WE HAVE
MISSED KAMLAGER AB. NINE SIX
TWO. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS GOOD MORNING I'M HERE
TO PRESENT AB NINE SIX TWO. SO
FIRST I WANT TO SAY THAT I AM
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB NINE SIX TWO
WILL PAVE THE WAY FOR
REFILLABLE BEVERAGE BOTTLES.
BOTTLE SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA BY
ALLOWING BOTTLES TO FLOW
THROUGH. THE CAL RECYCLE
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM. RATHER THAN BEING
CRASHED FOR RECYCLING THE
BOTTLES CAN BE PRESERVED TO BE
WASHED AND RE FILLED BY
BEVERAGE PRODUCERS
SIMULTANEOUSLY CREATING JOBS
AND REDUCING WASTE. THE DATA
SHOWS CALIFORNIANS PRODUCED AN
AVERAGE OF TWO TO THREE PACKAGE
TO PURCHASE. AN AVERAGE OF TWO
TO THREE PACKAGE DRINKS EVERY
DAY NINETY NINE POINT 9% OF
WHICH ARE SINGLE USE GLASS
PLASTIC METAL. OR PAPERBOARD
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS THE LARGEST
CATEGORY OF THESE ARE BEVERAGES
COVERED BY THE CALIFORNIA'S
BEVERAGE CONTAINER RECYCLING
PROGRAM. WHICH ACCOUNTS FOR
JUST OVER TWENTY FIVE BILLION
SINGLE USE CONTAINERS ANNUALLY.
THOSE 7280% OF THESE CONTAINERS
ARE RETURNED AND SUCCESSFULLY
RECYCLED INTO MOSTLY NEW
CONTAINERS NEARLY FOUR HUNDRED
AND FIFTY THOUSAND TONS OF
SINGLE USE BEVERAGE CONTAINERS
ARE STILL DISPOSED OF ANNUALLY
THIS IS A WEIGHTY PROBLEM THAT
ISN'T GOING AWAY ANYTIME SOON.
THERE ARE CALIFORNIA BEVERAGE
COMPANIES THAT ARE DOING THEIR
PART BY USING REFILLABLE
BOTTLES. THESE BOTTLES ARE THE
MOST SUSTAINABLE CHOICE FOR
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS AND THERE
IS A GROWING INTEREST IN USING
MORE GLASS REFILLABLE BOTTLES.
THEY KEEP OUR AIR CLEAN OUR
BEACHES PARKS AND ROADSIDES
LITTER LITTER FREE PROMOTE A
CIRCULAR ECONOMY AND
INCENTIVIZE A RENEWAL OF
RETURNABLE GLASS SOMETHING THAT
WAS COMMON FORTY YEARS AGO.
LAST YEAR I VISITED ORGANS
REFILLABLE BOTTLES SYSTEM DROP
WHERE IF THE LEVELS ARE STARTED
WATCHED STERILIZED INSPECTED
AND DELIVERED BACK TO CRAFT
BEVERAGE PRODUCERS. CALIFORNIA
BUSINESSES THAT HAVE STARTED
USING GLASS REFILLABLE BOTTLES
ARE TAKING THEM OUT OF STATE TO
HAVE THEM WASHED STERILIZED AND
INSPECTED. AB NINE SIX TWO WILL
LOSE WILL LAY THE FOUNDATION
FOR MORE SUSTAINABLE AND
ECONOMICALLY VIABLE BUSINESS
MODEL BY CREATING AN EVEN
PLAYING FIELD FOR THE USE OF
REFILLABLE BEVERAGE BOTTLES BY
BEVERAGE MANUFACTURERS. IT'S A
STATUTORY FIX WHAT'S
SIGNIFICANT ENVIRONMENTAL
BENEFITS. WITH ME IN SUPPORT
TODAY IS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE MARK
MURRAY AND RICH NORGROVE CEO
AND FOUNDING BREWMASTER. FOR
BEAR REPUBLIC BREWING AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE BILL. THANK YOU- MODERATOR
KEEP PLEASE OPEN UP THE PHONE
LINES FOR WITNESSES. CUEBALL
FINES ARE OPEN. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MARK MURRAY WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL GROUP
CALIFORNIANS AGAINST WASTE-
BEFORE PLASTIC BEFORE ALUMINUM
REFILLABLE GLASS BOTTLES WERE
THE ORIGINAL BEVERAGE CONTAINER.
AS RECENTLY AS TWENTY FIVE
YEARS AGO MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
BILLION REFILLABLE GLASS
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS WERE
REGULARLY DISTRIBUTED IN RETURN
FOR REFILLING CALIFORNIA. WE
KNOW THE REFILL GLASS BOTTLES
WHEN REGULARLY RETURNS WASHED
AND REBUILD HAVE A LOWER COST
FOR BOTH THE ENVIRONMENT AND
FOR BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS.
EIGHTY NINE SIX TO UPDATE
STATUTES TO ALLOW REFILLABLE
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS WHICH THE
CONSUMER IS ALREADY PAID THE R.
B. TWO B. PER TURN FOR REFUND
OF THAT C. R. D. WASHED
REFILLED AND RE DISTRIBUTED. IN
STATE. THEY'RE ALREADY GLASS
BEVERAGE CONTAINERS CAPABLE OF
RETURN WASH AND REFILL BEING
SOLD IN CALIFORNIA. THIS
MEASURE IS NEEDED TO ALLOW
THOSE CONTAINERS TO BE RETURNED
AND WASHED- AND REBUILD TO
CURRENT INTERSTATE
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR WHICH
BEVERAGE DISTRIBUTORS. AND
CONSUMERS ARE ALREADY PAYING.
WE URGE NIVEAU AND ON AVAILABLE
TO ANSWER ANY. THANKS THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. YES NOT
THANK YOU CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM RICH NORGROVE
JUNIOR CEO AND FOUNDING
BREWMASTER BEAR REPUBLIC
BREWING COMPANY IN SONOMA
COUNTY. WE ARE A SUCCESSFUL
CALIFORNIA INDEPENDENT CRAFT
BREWER WHO HAS BEEN IN BUSINESS
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY FIVE. WE
ARE THE TEMPLE LARGEST
INDEPENDENT CRAFT BREWER IN
CALIFORNIA AND WE EMPLOY OVER A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FIVE PEOPLE.
AND WE ARE PROBABLY VETERAN
OWNED. REPUBLICAN TENDS TO
BEGIN TO PACKAGE YOUR- INTO A
SINGLE RETURNABLE GLASS BOTTLE
THIS YEAR. THIS RETURNABLE
BOTTLE HAS A 95% LOWER CARBON
FOOTPRINT THAN A SINGLE USE
GLASS BOTTLE YOU CAN BE WASHED
AND FILLED OVER TWENTY FIVE
TIMES. RETURNABLE BOTTLE
SYSTEMS EXIST ALL AROUND THE
WORLD AND WHY NOT HERE. AFTER
THE INITIAL GLASS BOTTLE
PURCHASED THE COST PER. MILLION
RECORDED BOTTLE IS REDUCED OVER
THE LIFECYCLE OF THE BOTTLE
ALLOWING BEER MANUFACTURES TO
BENEFIT. FROM INCREASED COST
SAVINGS AS THE BOTTLES ARE
REACHED RETURNED FOR REFILLING.
WIENER CALIFORNIA BOTTLE BILL
TO SUPPORT THE OPTIONS YOU HAVE
THIS COST SAVING AND
SUSTAINABLE RETURNABLE BEVERAGE
BOTTLE BLOWING THROUGH OUR
REDEMPTION THE STUDENTS. THIS
SINGLE CHANGE TO OUR BOTTLE
BILL IS ALL ABOUT WASTE
PREVENTION OUR CUSTOMERS AND
OUR CONSTITUENTS ARGUMENT. MY
BUSINESS AND OTHER CALIFORNIA
CORPORATIONS TO REDUCE SINGLE
USE PACKAGING WASTE IN HERE IS
THE POWERFUL ANSWER. RETURNABLE
BEVERAGE BOTTLES FLOWING
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA POLICY
L. SYSTEM. WE SENATOR COME
LONGER FOR HER LEADERSHIP AND
URGE THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS TO
PLEASE SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU THANK YOU NEXT LET'S
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL. IF YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK I'M
EIGHTEEN NINE SIX TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. I HAVE ABOUT FIFTEEN IN
Q. FOUR TOP LINE TO SIXTY SIX
PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE MORNING
CARE MEMBERS CREEK THANK YOU ON
BEHALF OF THE NATIONAL
DEALERSHIP ACTION COUNCIL STOP
WEIGHT CALIFORNIA PRODUCT YOUR
SHIP COUNCIL IN SALT LAKE CITY
XIN OF NORTH AMERICA AND STATE
TAX FOR THE CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JIM LINDBERG ON BEHALF
OF THE FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
WON SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS THIS IS JENNIFER
FEARING ON BEHALF OF OCEANIC IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB NINETY
COULD YOU THANK YOU. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THE MORNING CARE MEMBERS
TECHNI MORE WHILE BEHALF OF
ANHEUSER BUSCH AND PART OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU RIGHT TWO
HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING KAREN MEMBERS GENEVIEVE
AVEDON ON BEHALF OF THE ELEVEN
CLEAN HE'S LOBBYING COALITION
MEMBER ORGANIZATIONS PRACTICAL
SPONSOR THIS MEASURE AND TRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M SURE TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN MORNING ON
BEHALF OF A STORE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE TWO
FIFTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. IN
MORNING TURN MEMBERS MODELING
COOPER FROM THE OPEN MARKET ON
BEHALF OF MARIN COUNTY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOUNG. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH SIXTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. BILL MURRAY THREE FIFTY
SILICON VALLEY IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I WON EIGHTY TO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI LAUREN COME
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU AYE CHIU FORTY EIGHT PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HI ALL CAN GO
CONTAINER THAT. I DON'T THINK
EIGHTY NINE AND WE BACK WHICH
BECAME. THANK YOU RIGHT SIXTEEN
CALL. HI KATHY SHAPER SAN
FERNANDO VALLEY CLIMATE REALITY
PROJECT IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I TWO SEVENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CHRISTINE
WON'T QUIT HER COLLEGE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU RIGHT TO
SEVENTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MY NAME IS NATALY CARE
ON BEHALF OF THE SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
TWO SEVENTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS KAREN
MCNAMARA I AM THE FOUNDER AND
CEO OF A FILLABLE BOTTLES START
AT CONSCIOUS CONTAINER IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU ARE INTO
SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE CALL HAD.
HI MY NAME IS CHERYL AUGER AND
I AM THE OWNER OF BANDS UP WE
FEEL AND I AM STRONG SUPPORT IN
STRONG SUPPORT FOR EIGHTY TWO
SEVEN FOUR THANK YOU. RIGHT TO
SEVENTY SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
GOOD MORNING- GERMANS TRIP
POSSIBLY FROM CONSCIOUS
CONTAINER IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
AB NINE SIX TWO. THANK YOU I
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK
YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU DO
WE HAVE ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. I DON'T SEE ANY
AND WITNESSES OF THE REMOTE
LOCATION THERE ARE NONE-
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS- MISTER
WHAT. JUST A COMMENT I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD TO A SENATOR- AND-
YOU KNOW I THINK IN MY OWN
COUNTY- CINEMA COUNTY MY HOME
COUNTY THEY'RE ACTUALLY DOING
THIS AS PART OF AND I MISSED
I'D STEP OUT FOR A CALL AS PART
OF A PILOT PROGRAM SO. IT'S
ALSO NICE THAT TO HAVE SOMEONE
FROM MY COUNTY- TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF THIS SO I DO
REMEMBER AS A CHILD THAT WE
ACTUALLY GOT MILK DELIVERIES
AND REUSABLE BOTTLES AND I'M
NOT THAT OLD BUT-WE LIVED IN
EUROPE AND THEY DO THAT KIND OF
THING THERE SO. SO AND DID THAT
FOR MANY MANY YEARS SO THANK
YOU FOR THAT AND- IF THE BILL
PASSES OUT OF COMMITTEE I'D
LOVE TO BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU TO
MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE MOTION IN
THE SECOND AND YES CINEMA
COUNTY IS I THINK LEADING THE
WAY WITH THEIR PILOT PROGRAM
AND WE WANT TO BE ABLE TO SHOW
OTHER FOLKS ACROSS THE STATE
HOW THIS CAN BE DONE AND- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR- WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR MR WENT SECONDED. BY
MR STONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS. YES I'M
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
I DON'T TWELVE EIGHTY NINE
SIXTY TWO BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COME LONGER MEMBER THREE OF US
I RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA I CHAU
FRIEDMAN GARCIA MATHIS. MATHIS
AYE MCCARTY MURATSUCHI SERTA HI
THEY ARE TO OUR EYES STONE
STONE I WOULD WOULD I. SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO THE BILL US OUT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. I'M NEXT AB NINE
SIX THREE YES SO ONCE AGAIN
GOOD MORNING KEREN MEMBERS. I'M
HERE TO PRESENT. AB NINE SIX
THREE I ALMOST FEEL LIKE I
SHOULD JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR MY VOTE IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME. THE DISTRICT BILL TO
EXPAND THE CONSERVANCY FOR THE
PROBLEM HAS CONSERVANCY. THANK
WITH ME IN SUPPORT TODAY'S
LUCAS FOR FREE RICH WITH THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND PAUL
POLITO WITH THE SOUTH LA
TRANSIT EMPOWERMENT ZONE. THANK
YOU MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE.
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. IF YOU DON'T FIND
TERRAPIN. GOOD MORNING MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS LUCAS BURKE
AND HALF THE NATURE CONSERVANCY
PROUD TO BE HERE TO SUPPORT
SENATOR CALM WATERS EIGHTY NINE
SIX THREE AND IF THE LAST YEAR
DEALING WITH THE KOBE PANDEMIC
IT TAUGHT US ANYTHING IT'S THAT
ACCESS TO THE OUTDOORS
ASCENTIAL TO MENTAL HEALTH AND
WELLBEING AND MAYBE EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT NOW THAN EVER BEFORE.
AT THE BALD HILL CONSERVANCY
MIGHT BE SMALL BUT IT CERTAINLY
MIGHT EAT AND INTERACT WITH
CLIMATE CHANGE IMPACTS AND
IMPROVE QUALITY OF LIFE BY
INCREASING ACCESS TO NATURE
IMPROVING URBAN WATERSHEDS
ENGAGING COMMITTEES DIRECTLY
EXPANDING THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONSERVANCY WOULD PROVIDE
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE FACED
HISTORIC DISINVESTMENT IN LOS
ANGELES WE APPRECIATE THE
LEADERSHIP BY CENTER COM LOGON
SUPPORT. ISSUE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
NEXT WITNESS PLEASE. HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS DR PAUL
POLITO AND I'M THE INTERMIX
ACTIVE DIRECTOR FOR SLATE AND
SEE WE ARE THE BACKBONE
ORGANIZATION FOR THE SOUTH LOS
ANGELES PROMISED ON ONE OF
TWENTY TWO FEDERALLY DESIGNATED
PROMISE ZONES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY. OUR PARTNERSHIP OF
OVER SEVENTY PUBLIC AND PRIVATE
ORGANIZATIONS STRIVE TO MOVE
OUR SOUTH LOS ANGELES RESIDENTS
TO GREATER OPPORTUNITY AS A
COMMUNITY SOUTH LOS ANGELES
DEMONSTRATE THE HIGHEST LEVEL
OF ADVERSE CLIMATE AND
ENVIRONMENTAL FACTORS WHICH
SPILLED OVER INTO THE HEALTH
AND WELLNESS OF OUR RESIDENTS.
NEGATIVE CONDITIONS ARE
EXACERBATED BY A LACK OF EASY
ACCESS NATURAL RESOURCES HIGHER
CONCENTRATIONS OF URBAN
POLLUTION AND PRECIOUS LITTLE
HEALTHY RECREATION SPACES. ARE
PROBLEMS ON EFFORT THAT SOUGHT
TO EQUITABLY WE'VE UPCOMING
INNOVATIONS WITH EXISTING
PROJECTS AND PROGRAMS FOR THE
BENEFIT OF OUR COMMUNITY THE
EXPANSION PROPOSED IN THIS BILL
WOULD HAVE A SUBSTANTIAL IMPACT
AND BROADENING ACCESS TO
NATURAL RESOURCES. IN ADDITION
TO GREATER RETRACTED INABILITY
EFFORTS AROUND COMMUNITY
RESILIENCE AND INCREASED ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION OUR CROSS SECTOR
WORK HIGHLIGHTS HOW INABILITY
EFFORTS POSITIVELY INFLUENCE
HEALTH AND WELLNESS WHILE ALSO
HAVING SOME TWIT SPILLOVER
BENEFITS ON JOB OPPORTUNITIES
EDUCATIONAL ENRICHMENT AND
OVERALL COMMUNITY SAFETY AND
WELL BEING. OUR PARTNERSHIP
APPLAUD YOUR CONSIDERATION OF
THIS BILL AS IT WOULD NOT ONLY
HELP PROTECT NATURAL RESOURCES
VAILABLE TO TALK ONLY
RESIDENTS BUT ALSO SET IN
MOTION BROADER ACCESS FOR
COMMUNITY IN DESPERATE NEED OF
MULTI FACETED PUBLIC AND
PRIVATE INVESTMENT EQUITABLE
REVITALIZATION. THIS PROPOSED
EXPANSION REPRESENTS A CRITICAL
STEP IN CONNECTING SOUTH LOS
ANGELES RESIDENTS WITH A WIDE
RANGE OF POSSIBILITIES FOR
SIGNIFICANTLY BETTER QUALITY OF
LIFE AND ALSO TO SERVE AS A
MODEL FOR COMMUNITY LED
INNOVATION STATEWIDE. THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NEXT OPEN UP THE LINE
FOR WITNESS IN SUPPORT- OR
OPPOSITION. PLEASE JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION. AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK I'M
EIGHTEEN NINE SIX THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO ACTORS
TIME. AND I CURRENTLY HAVE NO
COMMENT THANK YOU AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU I DON'T SEE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM
OR AT THE REMOTE LOCATION. SO
MOVE ON TO QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. THERE ARE NONE WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. UP YES
MANAGER I JUST WANT TO SAY THAT
THE AREA WHERE THE CONSERVANCY
IS LOCATED IS ONE OF THE LAST
LARGE OPEN SPACES AND- ALL OF
L. A. COUNTY. AND WHILE OUR
CONSERVANCY HAS SUCCESSFULLY
COMPLETED MILLIONS OF- IMPROVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AN
IMPROVEMENT PROJECTS WITHIN ITS
TERRITORY SEVERAL NEIGHBORING
AND NEARBY COMMUNITIES HAVE NOT
HAD DIRECT ACCESS TO THE SAME
PLANNING AND DEVELOPMENT
OPPORTUNITIES. AND THIS WOULD
ALLOW- THOSE AT COMMUNITIES TO
BE ABLE TO AT NOW PARTICIPATE
IN ACCESSING- STATE GRANT-
WATERSHED BASED PROGRAMS AND
SERVICES TO MANY OF OUR BOND
INITIATIVES I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU
SENATOR AND THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP- WITHIN OUR LOS
ANGELES DELEGATION AND FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL YOU KNOW I
AGREE WITH YOU THAT. OPEN SPACE
IS VERY IMPORTANT. IN LOS
ANGELES A VERY LIMITED- SO
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE DOING
ESPECIALLY FOR SOUTH LOS
ANGELES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
SO WE HAVE. WE HAVE A MOTION
FOR MISTER MATHIS. I NEED A
SECOND. SECOND BY MR SAY OUR
TOTAL. ON THE MOTION IS DUE TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM THIRTEEN
EIGHTY NINE SIXTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER COME LONGER
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE LARA.
FLORA I'D CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI SERTA NINE ZERO TWO
AYE STONE STONE I WOULD WOULD I.
SIX ZERO SIX ZERO PHYLLIS OUT
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE YOU ALL
GOOD TO SEE YOU THANK YOU
MISTER FLORA IS UP NEXT AB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE. THE BILL. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR THE MEMBERS FOR
MOVING THE BILL JUST QUICKLY AB
F. FIVE SEVENTY NINE AUTHORIZED
CALIFORNIA PURCHASE PP FROM A
PA OR A PRIVATE VENDOR IN
ADHERENCE TO CAL OSHA AND NFPA
STANDARDS. THIS ADDITIONAL
ACCESSIBILITY TO PP FOR CAL
FIRE FIREFIGHTERS WILL ALLOW
FIREFIGHTERS TO HAVE THE
EQUIPMENT THEY NEED TO REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF JOB CAUSED
INJURIES ILLNESSES SUSTAINED BY
FIREFIGHTERS DUE TO AN ADEQUATE
P. P. P. P. P. P. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I DO HAVE ONE WITNESS-
MINUTEMAN NUNO- WHO IS A VICE
PRESIDENT CALIFORNIA LOCAL TO.
I'M SORRY TWENTY EIGHT EIGHTY
ONE IF EVERY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. CAN HE WILL BE
TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT ONLY BE A
TECHNICAL QUESTION OKAY OKAY
GOOD. UNTIL NEXT LET'S OPEN UP
THE LINES- FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK OUT AB
FIVE SEVEN NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME. I
CURRENTLY HAVE ONE MINING Q.
RIGHT INTO FIFTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS TO OBSERVERS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
SPORTS THANK YOU. THANK YOU I
CURRENTLY HAVE NO FURTHER LINE
SINCE YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU HE WITNESSES IN THE HEARING
ROOM SEEN NONE. NO WITNESSES AT
THE REMOTE LOCATION. WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS- NINE SO
WE HAVE A MOTION FOR MR SAY
YOUR TOTAL- SECONDED BY MR
MATHIS THE MOTION. IS THE-
MOSHE'S DO PASS APPROPRIATIONS
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE JUST
RESPECT RESPECT LAST BATTLE
THANK YOU. SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM EIGHTEEN AB
FIVE SEVENTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA MEMBERS
RIVAS HI RIVAS FIVE FLORA BY
FLORA I CHAU FRIEDMAN GARCIA
MATHIS. MATHIS AYE MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI SAY ARCHER HI THERE
TO ALL EYES STONE STONE I WOULD
WOULD I'D- SIX ZERO SIX ZERO.
PHYLLIS OUT THANK YOU THANK YOU
I'M NEXT AB SEVENTY NINE SEVEN
NINE TWO FOUR THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR. SECOND THANK YOU SB
SEVEN NINETY WOULD PROVIDE
CALIFORNIA WITH FULL
RESPONSIBILITY FOR PROCESS
PRESCRIBED BURNS INITIATED AT
THE DEPARTMENT'S REQUEST
INCOMES AND- WITH THE CONSENT
OF THE LANDOWNER FOR TRAINING
OR OTHER PURPOSES REGARDLESS.
OF WHO'S LANDED IS IN
CALIFORNIA FOREST ARE REACHING
A BREAKING POINT AND WE NEED TO
FIX THIS PROBLEM I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A VOTE. THANK YOU
MODERATOR KEEP PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES- FOR SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION. IF YOU IF YOU WISH
TO SPEAK AT EIGHTEEN SEVEN NINE
TWO PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I CURRENTLY
HAVE ABOUT TWO COMMENTS THANK
YOU WORK GO TO VIOLENCE TWO
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
ALICIA PRIEGO ON BEHALF OF
AMERICAN COURSE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU OUR NEXT
COVERAGES FROM LINE ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE CALL HAD. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
NOEL KRAMER'S WITH WINE
INSTITUTE IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU NEXT WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANY IS ALSO IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. THANK YOU.
I DON'T SEE ANY WITNESSES AT
THE REMOTE LOCATION. WE HAVE
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS. THERE
ARE NONE WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THIS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU. WE HAVE A
MOTION FOR ISTER MATHIS SECOND
FROM MISTER SEA ARTO THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO APPROPRIATIONS
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ITEM NINETEEN EIGHTY SEVEN
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLORA MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE
FLORA FLOOR I'D CHAU FRIEDMAN
GARCIA MATHIS. MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI THEY ARE JOB
HI THERE TO ALL EYES JONES.
STONE I WOULD WOULD I SIX ZERO
SIX ZERO APPLE IS OUT. MISTER
MATHIS PRESENTING AB NINE TWO
SIX MOVED TO BELL. SECOND THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS. AB
NINE TWENTY SIX DISS SPANS UPON
WHAT WE'RE ALREADY DOING WITH
CAL FIRE TO DO FORCED
MANAGEMENT PROGRAMS AND GRANTS
AND INCENTIVES WITH ME TODAY IN
SUPPORT IS CHRISTMAS CEILIDH
AND ROBERT SPIEGEL I BELIEVE
WHO SHOULD BE ON THE LINE WHO
CAN ASK ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS- WITH THAT MEMBERS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU SO WE'LL START WITH OF
CHRISTMAS CEILIDH IN PERSON IN
THE HEARING ROOM. AND THEN MOVE
ON TO THE PHONE LINE YES MADAM
CHAIR CHRISTOPHER KELLY ON
BEHALF OF HUMBOLDT MENDOCINO
REDWOOD COMPANY AS WE DO
SUPPORT THE MEASURE WE THINK
IT'S VERY IMPORTANT FOR LOCAL
ASSISTANCE PROGRAMS AND HAPPY
TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
OTHERWISE WE URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
CHRIS. MODERATOR WILL YOU
PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINE FOR MR
SPIEGEL. CHINA'S OPEN. THANK
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
ROBERT SIEGEL CALIFORNIA FARM
BUREAU FEDERATION CREATE THE
OPPORTUNITY OF PRIDE SOME QUICK
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB NINE
TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY SIX WILL IMPROVE AND
PROVIDE GREATER ACCOUNTABILITY
TO CAL FIRE PREVENTION GRANT
PROGRAMS GIVEN THE CURRENT
STATUS OF THE DROUGHT AND WHAT
IS EXPECTED TO BE YET ANOTHER
ACTIVE FIRE SEASON EIGHTY NINE
TWENTY SIX APPROPRIATE
APPROPRIATELY PRIORITIZES
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PROJECTS
THAT HAVE COMPLETED OR NEARLY
COMPLETED SECRET DOCUMENTS THE
BILL FURTHER PROVIDES OTHER
CONSIDERATIONS THAT WERE
APPLIED IN CAL FIRE'S FORTY
FIVE DAY REPORT FOR TWENTY
NINETEEN. TO BETTER PROTECT
SOME OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES. PROGRAMMERS
APPROPRIATE GIVEN THE
CHALLENGES THAT LAY AHEAD WITH
THAT WE RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. I'M NEXT WILL MOVE TO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINES
MODERATOR PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES. IF YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK I'M EIGHTEEN NINE TWO SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ABOUT TWO
IN Q. OVER TWENTY ONE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. THEY ARE
MODEM SOUTH THROUGH Q. OPRYLAND
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE KNOW
ALL CREAMERS WITH WINE
INSTITUTE IN CONCORD AND.
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SIX. THANK
YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY FIVE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES GOOD MORNING
JULIE MALINOWSKI BOBBY HAPPY
CALIFORNIA BIOMASS ENERGY
ALLIANCE AND THE MID PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT OF EIGHTY NINE TWENTY
SIX. THANK YOU RIGHT TO SIXTY
FOUR PLEASE GO AHEAD. THIS IS
REALLY A WHOLE WITH THE
EXHORTATION CALIFORNIA LOTTERY
INTO COURT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENTS
THANK YOU AT THIS TIME. THANK
YOU ANY WITNESSES IN THE
HEARING ROOM. THERE ARE NONE NO
WITNESSES AT THE REMOTE
LOCATION QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
THERE ARE NONE OF THE MOTION
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THIS
SPECIALLY AFRIN I HAVE A THANK
YOU THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM MR SAY OUR TOE SECONDED.
BY MR FLORIDA SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL ITEM TWENTY
EIGHTY NINE TWENTY SIX BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MATHIS MEMBERS
RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA
I'D CHAU. FRIEDMAN GARCIA
MATHIS ALL RIGHT MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI
SAY ARCHER HI THERE ARE TWO AYE
STONE STONE I WOULD. WOOD I.
SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT. NEXT MISTER MAYOR
SU CHI AB. THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR. I AM PRESENTING ALONG
WITH MS GARCIA. AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
CLIMATE CRISIS ACT. AS WE ALL
KNOW LAST WEEK. PRESIDENT BIDEN
CONVENED LEADERS FROM AROUND
THE WORLD FOR THE GLOBAL
CLIMATE SUMMIT. TO ADDRESS THIS
GRAVE EXISTENTIAL CRISIS FACING
OUR GENERATION AND OUR WORLD.
PRESIDENT BIDEN MADE A BOLD
CALL TO ALL AMERICANS TO CUT
OUR NATION'S EMISSIONS AND HALF
IN LESS THAN TEN YEARS. IN
ORDER TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY. TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. THE SCIENCE IS CLEAR IF
WE DON'T REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY OR BEFORE TWENTY
FORTY FIVE WE WILL MISS THE
POINT OF NO RETURN. WHERE ARE
PLANET. OUR CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN. AND THOSE OF US
WHO ARE STILL ALIVE. WILL
SUFFER MASSIVELY. AND MANY MANY
WILL DIE. ALREADY TOO MANY
CALIFORNIANS ARE SUFFERING FROM
THE RAPIDLY UNFOLDING EFFECTS
OF THE CLIMATE CRISIS. EVERY
YEAR MORE AND MORE DEVASTATING
WILDFIRES. LIVES LOST. BILLIONS
OF DOLLARS IN ECONOMIC DAMAGES.
SMOKE FILLED ORANGE SKIES.
RAINING ASH. THAT OUR CHILDREN
ARE BREATHING IN. MEGA DROUGHTS.
EXTREME HEAT. WHAT WE NEEDED
TO. AS THE LEGISLATURE AS
LAWMAKERS FOR THE WORLD'S FIFTH
LARGEST ECONOMY. TO AVERT THIS
CATASTROPHIC FATE. THIS BILL
PROPOSES FOR MAIN ACTIONS.
FIRST THIS BILL WILL CODIFY OUR
STATE'S COMMITMENT TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY BY OR BEFORE
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. WITH A NET
NEGATIVE EMISSIONS THEREAFTER.
A COMMITMENT MADE THROUGH THE
LEADERSHIP OF GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN. IT IS TWENTY EIGHTEEN
EXECUTIVE ORDER. SECOND THIS
BILL WILL REQUIRE THE AIR
RESOURCES BOARD TO CREATE A
ROADMAP TO CARBON NEUTRALITY.
WITH AT LEAST 90% OF REQUIRED
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. TO BE
ACHIEVED THROUGH DIRECT
EMISSION REDUCTIONS. TO INSURE
THAT WE NOT ONLY MAKE NECESSARY
REDUCTIONS. BUT THAT WE ALSO
pIMPACTS ESPECIALLY IN LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES OF COLOR.
THIRD THIS BILL RECOGNIZES THE
CRITICAL IMPORTANCE OF
INNOVATIVE CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE SOLUTIONS. AND WILL
REQUIRE THE AIR RESOURCES BOARD
TO ESTABLISH REGULATIONS FOR
THEIR USE. FINALLY THIS BILL
WILL PRIORITIZE THE IMPORTANT
USE OF NATURAL AND WORKING
LANDS. TO CAPTURE CARBON IN OUR
FORESTS SOILS AND OCEANS. I
WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT ALL
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS. I WAS
GOING TO TURN OVER TO MY JOIN
AUTHOR THE CELL NUMBER GARCIA
BUT I. DON'T SEE HER AVAILABLE
AND SO AT THIS POINT I WOULD
LIKE TO. TURN IT OVER TO THE
TWO WITNESSES ALEX JACKSON
JACKSON. WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL. AND
LUCAS FRERICHS WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY. IN PLEASE OPEN UP
THE LINES FOR OUR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU FIVE FIVE
ZERO FAN. GOOD MORNING JERRY
MEMBERS ALEX JACKSON ON BEHALF
OF ENERGY C. PLEASED TO SPEAK
IN SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THE PROVIDED TO THE
LEVEL OF AMBITION REQUIRED TO
CONFRONT THE ESCALATING QUITE A
CRISIS WE'VE HEARD TODAY. I
MEAN YOU JUST OUTLINED
VIRTUALLY EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
STATE TO AVOID EVEN MORE
CATASTROPHIC IMPACTS WE MUST
ACCELERATE OUR EFFORTS TO SLOW
STOP AND REVERSE THE BUILDUP OF
GREENHOUSE GASES IN THE
ATMOSPHERE. WE CAN DO THAT WE
NEED COMMITMENT CLARITY IN
COLLABORATION EACH. OF WHICH
ANIMATES THE SPELL. PERSONAL
CONDUCT CAL COMMIT. TO ACHIEVE
CARBON NEUTRALITY AS SOON AS-
NO LATER THAN TWENTY FORTY
FIVE. THE AIRPORT IS DEVELOPING
THE TWENTY TWENTY TO UPDATE TO
THIS COMPANY PLAN. AND WILL
NEED DIRECTION AND BUY IN FROM
THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE THAT
IT IS AFFECTING A DURABLE
FRAMEWORK THANKS FOR NEEDED
INVESTMENTS. SECOND FIVE W.
SEPARATE TARGETS AND ACCOUNTING
FOR NEGATIVE INITIAL STRATEGIES
FROM MEDICATION AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE CLARIFIES THAT
REMOVAL ALONGSIDE REDUCTION NOT
THAT THE LIGHT TO KEEP LETTING.
GOING FORWARD WITH THE SAME
CLARITY LET ME TOOLS REMAIN ON
THE TABLE ALONG WITH ME BECAUSE
THEY SHOT. IN THIS PRODUCTION.
GLOBAL SECRETARY ARE PER AT THE
CORE CARE HEALTH. THE THIRD
PERSON LONGEST PATH WILL A OF.
HELLO HAS LONG BEEN A LEADER
CLIMATE AND RENEWABLE ENERGY
IT'S BEEN CHOI. BY THE FIRST OF
SICK. WE NEED THAT SAME BIG
TENT HE- THE STATE MUST IT SO
ANOTHER. AND WE KNOW WE'LL NEED
A BRA THE TENT SO IT'S SECTORS
BE CLIMATE POLICY IN THE
OPPORTUNE THAT IT IS NOT A
THREAT. WE IN THIS BILL THE
RIGHT COMPONENTS THE TACTICAL.
AND I THINK BOTH BOXERS OR
BRIEFS MEASURE FOR OUR SITE ASK
OKAY. NECK WITNESS. GOOD
MORNING MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
THE CONSTRUCTION HAPPENING
CONSIDER ALLEN ST CHAIR THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS PROPERTIES
TODAY THAT WE ARE NOW
EXPERIENCING IN DEALING WITH
THE IMPACT OF CLIMATE CHANGE
ASSOCIATED EXTREME WEATHER
EVENTS FROM HEAT EXTREME HEAT
THE FLOODS THE FIRE AND DROUGHT
IPCC SCIENTIST THEY TO AVOID
SOME OF THE WORST AND MOST
DEVASTATING IMPACTS OF CLIMATE
CHANGE WE HAVE TO ACCELERATE
OUR EFFORTS IN REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY MID CENTURY IF
NOT SOONER. AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE WOULD PUT IT ON A PATH TO
HELP ACHIEVE SUCH A GOAL BY
ACCELERATING EFFORTS TO REDUCE
EMISSIONS DIRECTLY IN BY
ELEVATING OTHER CRITICAL
CLIMATE STRATEGIES LIKE NATURE
BASED CLIMATE POLLUTION AND
CARBON APPROVALS FOR
TECHNOLOGIES SCIENTIFIC
ANALYSIS CONDUCTED BY THE
NATURE CONSERVANCY AND OTHER
COLLEAGUES SUGGEST THAT WITHOUT
INTERVENTION OUR NATURAL
WORKING LANDS ARE AT RISK OF
BECOMING AN INCREASING THAT
SOURCE EMISSIONS INSTEAD OF
INCREASING THAT SINK TO THE
FIRE IN MY AND CONVERSION AMONG
OTHER MANAGEMENT PRACTICES. THE
GOOD NEWS THEN WITH IMMEDIATE
ACTION AND INTERVENTION WE CAN
CHANGE THE TRAJECTORY REDUCING
EMISSIONS ENHANCING CARBON
SEQUESTRATION THROUGH A VARIETY
OF MANAGEMENT RESTORATION AND
CONSERVATION ACTIVITIES ARE
NATURAL LOOKING LAND CAN MAKE A
SIGNIFICANT CONTRIBUTION TO OUR
TEAM OF CARBON NEUTRALITY
HOWEVER FOR THESE RESOURCES
COMPLAINING POLL WELL TO
ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE GOALS THEY
NEED TO BE A HIGHER PRIORITY
THAN THEY HAVE BEEN
HISTORICALLY WITH POLICY THAT
INVESTMENTS ARE ON PAR WITH
OTHER SECTORS. THIS IS WHY WE
ARE SO PLEASED THAT AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE PRIORITIZES NATURE
BASED CLIMATE STRATEGIES AS
PART OF THE STATE'S OVERALL
GOAL TO ACHIEVE CARBON
NEUTRALITY WE RESPECTFULLY-
URGE YOUR AYE. VOTE ON IT AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
NEXT WE HAVE TO WAIT. IN
OPPOSITE. TIM JEFFRIES FROM THE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS WHICH I BELIEVE
IS. IN THE HEARING ROOM. AND
THE- PAY HOLES FROM CALPINE-
VIA PHONE. SO LET'S START WITH
MISTER JEFFRIES. MORE MEMBERS
OF THE ASSEMBLY NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE MY NAME IS
TIMOTHY JEFFRIES ON THE
BUSINESS MANAGEMENT BOUGHT FOR
THE LOCAL FIVE FORTY NINE
INTERNATIONAL BROTHERHOOD OF
BOILERMAKERS I'M ALSO PROUD
BETTER KNOW UNITED'S MARINE
CORPS APPEAR BEFORE YOU IN
OPPOSITION OF AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE. WE'RE SURPRISED BY
THE AMENDMENTS IN THIS BILL WHY
WOULD CALIFORNIA CHOOSE TO
LIMIT- CLIMATE INNOVATION. WILL
NEED EVERY TOOL OUT TO ABOUT
WE'RE GOING TO GET IT GOING TO
ATTEMPT TO ME CALIFORNIA'S
AGGRESSIVE CLIMATE GOALS. THIS
BILL WOULD EFFECTIVELY KILL
CAPPED A CARBON CAPTURE
INNOVATION CALIFORNIA. AND KILL
OFF THE RAPID GROWTH OF IN
MANUFACTURING THAT'S HAPPENING
CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW CARVING
CHARACTERS NOT SOME FUTURISTIC
TECHNOLOGY. IS NOT DESIGNED TO
MERELY CREATE A PATH OF
PERMITTED DIVERT DEPENDENCY ON
FOSSIL FUELS THE BOILERMAKERS
TO THE NORTH HAVE BUILT AND
OPERATED A UTILITY SCALE CARBON
CAPTURE PLANT. JUST OUTSIDE OF
EDMONTON. TO DATE THEY HAVE
CAPTURED MORE THAN FIVE MILLION
TONS OF CO TWO THAT IF NOT FOR
THIS TECHNOLOGY WOULD BE. IN
OUR SHARED ATMOSPHERE. WE ALSO
WORK WITH MANY PROJECTS ARE IN
CALIFORNIA IN THE BILL YOU BAY
AREA. LA IN KERN COUNTY ON
UTILITY SCALE CARBON CAPTURE
PROJECTS THAT WILL UTILIZE
CUTTING EDGE TECHNOLOGY. TO
TAKE CARBON OUT OF THE AIR AND
CREATE GOOD JOBS FOR BLUE BLUE
COLLAR WORKERS. PEOPLE THAT
WANT TO UC CARBON CAPTURE
INNOVATION KILLED IN CALIFORNIA
ARE FOCUSED SOLELY. ON KILLING
A FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY. BUT
WHAT THEY AREN'T FOCUSED ON ALL
THE EFFECTS THAT THIS MISGUIDED
POLICY WILL HAVE ON INNOVATION
TECHNOLOGY AMEND AFFECTED
DESIGNED TO MEET. THE CLIMATE
CRISIS. CALIFORNIA'S LEADER
MANUFACTORY ELECTRIC CARS AND
BUSES TO MEET THE DEMANDS. AND
MANDATES WITHOUT CARBON CAPTURE.
WE CAN ALSO BID FAREWELL TO
THIS TYPE OF MANUFACTURING
REALLY EVERY TYPE
MANUFACTURING. AS WE LEAVE THE
STATE AND IT WOULD IT WOULD
LEAVE THE STATE FOR OTHER
STATES WERE MANUFACTURING IS
OFFSET MY CARBON CAPTURE. AT
THE PASSAGE OF NAFTA CALIFORNIA
LOST MORE JOBS THAN ANY OTHER
STATE. WHICH WE THINK WE SHOULD
ALL BE CONCERNED WITH THE LOSS
OF YET MORE MANUFACTURING
CAREERS. THE SPONSOR THIS BILL
MIGHT NOT WANT TO JOB IN
MANUFACTURING OR THE B. AS A
BOILERMAKER. I CAN TELL YOU
EVERY APPROACH TO WALK AND TALK
TRAINS AND DOES WELL. IT DOES
IT WILL MAKE A PATH TO MIDDLE
CLASS FOR THE FAMILY. WE ARE
PROUD OF THE BUILDING TRADES
70% OF THE SIXTY THOUSAND.
YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN. IN
PRESSURE PROGRAMS. LOOK LIKE ME
MANY OF THEM. ARE FROM THE
ARMED FORCES JUST LIKE MISTER
JEFFRIES KEY PLEASE WRAP UP HE
Vç. GOVERNMENT WE ARE HOPEFUL
THAT THIS COMMITTEE SEES BEYOND
THE BILL TO. WHICH IS POSSIBLE
IN CALIFORNIA WE SHOULD BE THE
LEADER IN INNOVATION IN CARBON
CAPTURE TECHNOLOGY RENEWABLE
FUELS. ENERGY AND MANUFACTURING
NEED TO MEET THIS GLOBAL CRISIS
AND WE CAN BE. IF NOT THIS BILL
THIS BILL DOESN'T PASS THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- NEXT WITNESS
MODERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN
UP THE PHONE LINE FOR OUR NEXT
WITNESSES WITNESS IN OPPOSITION.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. YEAH MANAGER
MEMBERS YEAH PAYER COUPLES IN
CALPINE CALIFORNIA NO POSITION
ON THE AMENDMENTS TAKEN
COMMITTEE THAT LAYS THE STATE'S
CARBON EMISSIONS STANDARDS WE
STAND READY TO HELP THE STATE
MEET WHATEVER CARBON EMISSIONS
REDUCTIONS GOALS IT SET.
HOWEVER I WOULD NOTE THE IRONY
OF THE BUILDING ON THE ONE HAND
INCREASES. THAT STANDARD ON THE
OTHER HAND. KLOPP'S THE TOOLS
JANET STATE. SEPTEMBER STATE'S
READY IN ORDER TO MEET THE
GOALS CALIFORNIA ARE OPPOSES
THE IDEA LIMITS ON CASH
DIMINISH. IN AB. THIRTEEN FIVE.
THE ARBITRARILY FALLING BASIS
THAT MEANS. FROM ST AND
FEATURES IN THE- AS WELL AS
FROM LAW LEVEL LAB. AT LEAST-
EARLIER THIS. AS WELL AS ALL
AND PAPERS PUBLISHED IN
BIOMEDICAL FONG AND THE CLEAN
ENERGY TASK FORCE. A 10%
CAPITAL BILL ALL APPLIES IN THE
FACE OF PRESENT BY THE
AMERICANS PLAN. WHICH CONTENT
AGREE ROLE CCF IN ELECTRIC SUCH
HELLO. IN THE TEMPERATURE CAP
NAVY THIRTEEN FIVE. CAL ALSO
OPPOSE THE BILL. BECAUSE SOME
THINGS DO NOT POINT. LAST YEAR
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE MILLION
METRIC TONS OF CARBON WE
RELEASED THE LOCK BOX. THIS
WILL MEAN THAT THE STATE.
CONTINUES WILL NEED MORE SINCE
YOU LAST NOT LAST. LASTLY AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE IS NOT THE
MESSAGE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
CONCERN THE COMPANY'S ARE
CONTEMPLATING MAKING LARGE
INVESTMENTS IN THE STATE'S
ABILITY TO CAPTURE CARBON
CARBON IN ORDER FOR THE STATE
TO AVOID THE WORST EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE. SHOULD JUST
TRANSITION THAT WE HEAR ABOUT
ALL THE TIME IS IN FACT IN THIS
INDUSTRY. WE DO NOT BELIEVE
THAT THIS TIME THE STATE SHOULD
BE RESPECTING THE WHOLE SEASON.
YOU ESCALATE. A HUNDRED AND
FORTY POINT WITHOUT. FOR THOSE
REASONS HELPLINE IS A- TO A
GROUP. NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU
OUR NEXT I'LL MOVE TO WE IN THE
HAIR ROOM. PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME AFFILIATION AND POSITION
ON THE BILL. HI MY NAME IS
MICHAEL DRAWING REPRESENTING
THE BOILERMAKERS LOCAL FIVE
FORTY NOT OUT OF PITTSBURGH I
AM IN THE PERNICE- WE STAND IN
SOLIDARITY TO OF STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL. THE GOOD AFTERNOON
GLENN LEVEL OF IRONWORKERS
UNION LOCAL THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT- ALSO STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL. MIKE WEST ON
BEHALF OF THE INTERNATIONAL
UNION OF PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WITH DOWN THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION AS WELL
THANK YOU. RENDON DISCOUNT
SIXTEEN PAINTERS ALLY TRADE WE
STAND OPPOSITION WITH BUILDING
TRADES. GOOD MORNING JASON
LINDSEY WITH THE IRON WORKERS
LOCAL THREE SEVENTY EIGHT
STANDING IN OPPOSITION AND IN
SUPPORT OF THE BUILDING TRADE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
DOMINATING- BUSINESS
REPRESENTATIVE FOR THE PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL FOUR FOUR
SEVEN SACRAMENTO CALIFORNIA I'M
HERE STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION OF AB.
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. MADAM
CHAIR- TORRANCE WITH IRON
WORKERS LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN-
STAND IN OPPOSITION OF AB ONE
THREE NINE FIVE THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROB STOKER
ON BEHALF OF SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR
STANDING WITH STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG OPPOSITION.
ARE ONE OF THE RIVER WITH THE
SHEET METAL WORKERS AND
PRESIDENT OF THE MIDDLE
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL IN
OPPOSITION. OUR LITTLE CHOI
WITH A LOCAL SIXTEEN INSULATORS
AND NOT IN CALIFORNIA. IN
OPPOSITION. KIANA BRILL WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS IN OPPOSITION. MORGAN
OLDIE PRESIDENT WESTERN
REGIONAL DISTRICT COUNCILLOR
REFERS A WATERPROOF FURS AND
STANDING WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN OPPOSITION. RAYMOND
DAVIS IRON WORKERS LOCAL ONE
EIGHTEEN IN OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU I'M NEXT WILL OPEN UP THE
PHONE LINES FOR WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OR OPPOSITION WITH WE
WILL BE LIMITATION- THE TIME TO
FIVE MINUTES TOTAL. AMENDED ONE
REMIND WITNESSES TO JUST STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THIS BILL MODERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK OUT AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. I HAVE ABOUT
THIRTY IN Q. WILL GO TO LINE
SIX TIME PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE
BILL MURPHY. SILICON VALLEY AS
WELL AS- ELDERS CLIMATE ACTION
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA CHAPTERS.
IN STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU
RIGHT TO NINETY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON JAMIE
MINOR SOMETHING HAPPENED AND
YOU SERVING CUSTOMER THING
CONTRA COSTA SOLANO NAPA AND
MARIN COUNTIES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU I TO NINETY NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. JOHN LINGER ON
THE OUTTHE CALIFORNIA FUEL THE
CONVENIENT ALLIANCE IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I TO
NINETY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS WILLIAM
GONZALEZ WITH DISTRICT COUNCIL
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES AND WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE.
DURING THREE OH TO PLEASE GO
AHEAD. THANK YOU CONCORSO UA
LOCAL THIRTY EIGHT. AMERICANS
THINK FETTERS DAMPENED CISCO
STAND WITH THE BUILDING TRADES
THAT OPPOSE AB THIRTEEN NINETY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
THREE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
JOHN DORY BUSINESS MANAGER IBEW
LOCAL SIX SAN FRANCISCO I'M
STAYING WITH TH CAL STATE
ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU I TWENTY
SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. THE END
RESULT WAS MARGINAL CRITICAL
ONE ZERO FIVE SITTING IN THE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ON ONE FOURTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. SCHNEIDER'S
NATALIE THIS YEAR'S SO
REPRESENTING LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT
ACROSS INSULATORS AND WE
STRENGTH STANDING STRONG
OPPOSITION TO AB THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU I'M THREE OH THREE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS JOHN
SPALDING REPRESENTING THE
CURTAIN UNION MONTGOMERY'S
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COUNCIL AND WE STAND WITH THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES IN THEIR
OPPOSITION TO AB THREE NINETY
FIVE. THANK YOU RIGHT ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
ONE NINE. BOB LEVINSON LEGAL
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU LINE TO TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. LOG IN THE
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADE IN OPPOSING AB
ONE ONE THREE NINE FIVE. ONE
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WHEELABRATOR ON BEHALF OF THE
THOUSANDS OF MEMBERS OF THREE
FIFTY SACRAMENTO IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I TWO EIGHTY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING ROB MILLER SECULAR
SECRETARY OF THE ALIEN ORANGE
COUNTY BUILDING TRADES ON
BEHALF OF A HUNDRED FORTY
THOUSAND MEN AND WOMEN. WE
STAND IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL THAT LIMITS OUR ABILITY AS
HUMANS TO GET TO A CLEAN
ENVIRONMENT. WERE IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU I'M THRILLED FOR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
JAMIE THOUGH ON BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL DEFENSE FUND IN
COURT. THANK YOU I TO NINETY
FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ROSHEN
THE CALIFORNIA FARM BUREAU IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU RYAN TO
NINETY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
WATER SALAS WITH DISTRICT
SIXTEEN PAINTERS ALLIED TRADES
AND WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN OPPOSITION
OF AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MY NAME IS MARK ABOVE THE HEAT
ACROSS INSPIRES LOCAL SIXTEEN
WE STAND WITH THE STATE
BUILDING TRADES IN STRONG
OPPOSITION THIS BILL. THANK YOU
I'M EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD GOOD GOOD AFTERNOON ISRAEL
SALAS WITH SAN DIEGO GAS AND
ELECTRIC COMPANY AND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA GAS COMPANY IN
OPPOSITION TO THIRTEEN ACT BY.
THANK YOU RIGHT TO NINETY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MY NAME IS TOMMY PHAM NINE OUR
REPRESENT IBEW LOCAL IN LOS
ANGELES COUNTY ON BEHALF OF
GOLF. OF OUR MEMBERS YOUR SENSE-
WE STAND OPPOSED TO THIS BILL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU ARE WANT
FORTY NINE TO GO AHEAD. HI MY
WAYS ABOUT THE- BOOKMAKER LOCAL
BY FORTY NINE AND WE ARE THE OF
THE THIS BILL. THANK YOU I TWO
EIGHTY PLEASE CLASS. YELLOW
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS SCOTT
WHICH BE OFF THE CALIFORNIA'S
PIPE TRADES COUNCIL THE WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS THE STATE'S ASSOCIATION
OF ELECTRICAL WORKERS IN THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION OF UTILITY
EMPLOYEES OPPOSED. TO THIRTEEN
NINETY FIVE THANK YOU. THANK
YOU RIGHT ONE NINETY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE NINE
THREE. RIGHT TO NINETY PLEASE
GO AHEAD. MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKET PARTS WHAT YOU
TAKE CONTROL INSTITUTION IN
OPPOSITION. THANK YOU TO FORTY
ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. TWO FOUR
ONE. YEAH I THIS IS GREG LEWIS
LOCAL SEVEN SIXTY ONE PLUMBERS
AND PIPEFITTERS STAND IN
OPPOSITION OF THIS BILL. THANK
YOU LINE THREE OH SIX PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JAMES DIRECTOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE COUNCIL LABORS
IN STRONG OPPOSITION THANK YOU
MODERATOR WE ARE AT. ASKED FIVE
MINUTES- I WANNA REMIND ANYONE
ON THAT THEY CAN IF THEY'RE
STILL ON THE LINE AS THEY CAN
I'M SUBMIT ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY
OF ANY LANE VIA OUR COMMITTEE
WEBSITE BUT I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE. THAT WAS PRESENT AND
CALLED IN OF TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE. SEE DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MISTER SEA ARE TO.
THANK YOU SO. AND THANK YOU FOR
YOUR EFFORTS TO- YOU KNOW HELP
OUR ENVIRONMENT AND CREATE
CLEAN AIR BECAUSE WE ALL NEED
THAT- BUT YES I REALLY HAVE
SOME ISSUES WITH THIS AND THE
BIG ONE IS BEEN BROUGHT UP A
LOT AND THAT'S THE TEN PERCENT.
OF A C. C. S. N. AND
EFFECTIVELY ELIMINATING FOR
CALIFORNIA WHICH WE JUST SAID
WE WANT TO LEAD THE WORLD. IN
AND IT YOU KNOW CREATING AND
THAT THE CLEAN ENVIRONMENT AND
ENERGY POLL ARE THEY
ENVIRONMENTAL PUSH- TO GET TO
ZERO EMISSIONS- IF. IN AN EARLY
RETIREMENT WIND ENERGY AND
LOSING OUR- LOSING TO THE EAST
COAST. LOSING THAT TECHNOLOGY
OVER THERE- IF WE'RE GOING TO
LEAD IT'S NOT JUST GOING TO BE
IN THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE
THE REST OF THE WORLD. NEEDS
THIS TECHNOLOGY BECAUSE THEY'RE
NOT GOING TO DO WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TRY TO DO IN TWENTY
FORTY FIVE. AND SO. IF THEY'RE
DEPENDING ON US TO DEVELOP THE
TECHNOLOGY BUT WORSHIPING THAT
WE'RE DISINCENTIVE ICING THE
TECHNOLOGY. HOW ARE E GOING
TO. HOW ARE WE GOING TO GET THE
REST OF THE WORLD ON BOARD WITH
THE TYPES OF TECHNOLOGY THEY
NEED. TO TRY TO REDUCE THE
EMISSIONS BECAUSE WE CAN DO AS
MUCH WE CAN ALL GET TO ZERO
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA BUT IF
THE REST OF THE WORLD IS NOT
DOING IT EITHER. ARE NOT NOT
ABLE TO DO IT- WORKS WE KNOW
WHAT IT IS WE ALL BREATHE THE
SAME AIR. SO WHAT WHAT IS THE
WHAT IS YOUR ANSWER TO THOSE
CONCERNS THAT YOU HEARD OUT
THERE BECAUSE THIS CREATES
JOBS. AND YOU KNOW THE
MANUFACTURING LORD KNOWS WE
NEED IT HERE. YOU KNOW WE TALK
ABOUT RAISING PEOPLE OUT OF
POVERTY THEY NEED JOBS TO DO
THAT. SO THAT'S THAT'S MY
CONCERN IS THAT 10% THANK YOU
MISTER SURCHARGE SO I.
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH YOU AND I
COMPLETELY AGREE WITH THE
EVERYONE- THAT SPOKE OF- BOTH
FOR AND AGAINST- THIS BILL- AND-
NO EMPHASIZING THE IMPORTANCE
OF. THE INNOVATION IN THE
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE
SPACE- THIS BILL. BUT DOES NOT.
CREATE ANY CAPS FOR CARBON
CAPTURE AND STORAGE. THE
OPPOSITION TO THIS BILL HAS
CEATED THIS FALSE NARRATIVE OF.
YOU KNOW OUR ATTEMPT TO PROVIDE
GUIDANCE AND FRAMEWORK TO THE
AIR RESOURCES BOARD TO PLACE
YOU KNOW THE OVERWHELMING
EMPHASIS ON THE NEED FOR GROSS
EMISSION REDUCTIONS YOU KNOW
TO FOCUS ON THIS FALSE
NARRATIVE QUITE FRANKLY THAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO. CAP
CARBON CAPTURE AND STORAGE IN
FACT. YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL FOR
THE INNOVATION I MEAN IF- IF
CALIFORNIA CAN DEVELOP THE BIG
CARBON VACUUM THAT CAN SUCK UP
ALL THE CARBON IN OUR
ATMOSPHERE THEN MORE POWER TO
THEM THERE IS NOTHING IN THIS
BILL THAT LIMITS THE CARBON
CAPTURE STORAGE CONTRIBUTION TO
THE- GREENHOUSE GAS REDUCTIONS
THROUGH CARBON CAPTURE AND IN
FACT TO MAKE IT ABSOLUTELY
CLEAR- WE HAVE ACCEPTED ONE OF
THE AMENDMENTS EVERY ACCEPTED
FROM THE COMMITTEE THE
COMMITTEES- THANK THE CHAIRS
SIX. RECOMMENDED AMENDMENT WAS
TO TAKE OUT THAT 10% LANGUAGE
BECAUSE YOU KNOW IT'S CLEARLY-
BEEN MISTER INTERPRETED AND
USED. TO CREATE THIS FALSE
NARRATIVE THEY WERE TRYING TO
CAPTURE THE CARBON CAPTURE SO
WE ARE TAKING OUT THAT 10% CAP-
THAT THAT 10% LANGUAGE. BUT
THAT THE MAIN POINT IS THIS
THAT IN ORDER TO REACH CARBON
NEUTRALITY BY TWENTY FORTY FIVE
WE NEED TO. DRAMATICALLY REDUCE
EMISSIONS THAT IS WHAT- A
RECENT AARP STUDY ON ON HOW TO
ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY BUT
TWENTY FORTY FIVE. AS THEY THEY
EXPLORED THREE DIFFERENT
SCENARIOS BETWEEN YOU KNOW 90%
OVER 90% REDUCTIONS 2280%
REDUCTIONS BUT IN ANY CASE. YOU
KNOW EVERY. CREDIBLE FEASIBLE
STUDY THAT IS FOCUSED ON HOW WE
GET TO CARBON NEUTRALITY BY
TWENTY FORTY FIVE WHETHER THE
COMMISSION THAT THE STUDY
RECENTLY COMMISSIONED BY THE A
RP OR WHETHER STUDIES
COMMISSIONED AND EUROPE. HAVE
ALL FOCUSED ON. MODELS WHERE WE
CAN ONLY ACHIEVE THAT GOAL IF
WE FOCUS ON THE NEED FOR GROSS
EMISSIONS REDUCTIONS THE MAIN
POINT OF THIS IS THAT WE CANNOT
ALLOW CARBON CAPTURE AND
STORAGE. AS AN EXCUSE. IN ORDER
TO KEEP BURNING FOSSIL FUELS WE
NEED TO MAKE THOSE. THAT THAT
DRAMATIC TRANSITION THAT IS THE
ONLY WAY- QUITE FRANKLY THAT WE
CAN SAVE OUR PLANET. OKAY WELL
THAT'S DRAMATIC- AND- BUT I
GUESS I HAVE TO SAY IT YOU CAN
REMOVE THE 10% LANGUAGE BUT IF
YOU LEAVE THE 90% LANGUAGE ALL
THAT LEAVES IS 10% AND THAT
REMOVES THE INCENTIVE FOR
TECHNOLOGY TO DO THEIR THING.
TO ENABLE THAT YOU KNOW THAT
CAR THAT CCS. TECHNOLOGY TO
ADVANCE AND ACTUALLY MAKE ANY
DIFFERENCE AT ALL AND IF WE'RE
NOT GOING TO BE ABLE TO
INCENTIVIZE THOSE BY HAVING.
YOU KNOW HAVING A MARKET OUT
THERE WHERE IT'S NEEDED. OR
WHERE IT'S EFFECTIVE DAN IT'S
NOT GOING TO EXIST. SO YOU KNOW
YOU KNOW I JUST DIFFER A LITTLE
BIT ON IT THE GRAVITY OKAY- BUT
BUT ON THIS I A DIFFERENT
ITEMS. I DEFEND MY DIFFERENCE
OF OPINION IS BASED ON.
IMPORTANT TAKE AWAY THE
INCENTIVE YOU TAKE AWAY TO THE
JOB OKAY OKAY SO I'M THAT.
THANK YOU OF IT I MAY BE
MISTAKE. AGAIN I YOU KNOW WE'RE
NOT AND- AND THIS AGREEMENT AND
THAT. YOU KNOW PART OF THAT
FALSE NARRATIVE IS THAT THIS IS
GOING TO- YOU KNOW WAS SOMEHOW
IF WE ACHIEVE CARBON NEUTRALITY
BY OR BEFORE TWENTY FORTY FIVE.
THEN MISSION ACCOMPLISHED THAT
IS NOT WHAT THIS BILL CALLS FOR
IT CALLS FOR NET NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS THEREAFTER AND SO YOU
KNOW THERE THERE ISN'T AGAIN
THERE IS NO LIMIT ON. HOW MUCH
CARBON REMOVAL HOW MUCH CORE
CARBON CAPTURE. AND STORAGE
THAT THAT WE'RE GONNA NEED IN
ORDER TO SAVE OUR PLANET-
BECAUSE- WHERE WHERE NOT WE'RE
WE'RE WE'RE NOT LIMITING IT TO.
TEN NET ZERO EMISSIONS WEEK
WHERE WE ARE SEEKING OVER THE
LONG TERM NET NEGATIVE
EMISSIONS. MORE POWER TO THE
CARBON CAPTURE STORES TO GO
BEYOND NET ZERO EMISSIONS TO
ACHIEVE NET NEGATIVE EMISSIONS.
MISTER WHAT. YEAH JUST A VERY
QUICK QUESTION AND YOU KEEP
TALKING ABOUT CARBON CAPTURE
AND SO I SPENT BE SURE THE
CARBON OFFSET PROJECTS LIKE FOR
EXAMPLE MY DISTRICT THE YUROK
HAVE BEEN PURCHASING BACK
ANCESTRAL LAND THOSE ARE NOT
BEING CHANGED IN ANYWAY BY THIS
CORRECT THAT IS CORRECT THIS
THIS BILL DOES NOT BE THE
OFFSETS ARE UNDER THE STATE'S
CAP AND TRADE PROGRAM THIS
PURPOSE THIS BILL DOES NOT
AFFECT OUR OUR STATE CAPTURED
PROGRAM INCLUDING THE OFFICES
THAT ARE. INCLUDED IN THE CAP
AND TRADE PROGRAM THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
MEMBERS. OKAY MISTER MESSAGE I
JUST WANTED TO CONFIRM THAT YOU
ARE TAKING THEM AT MIDNIGHT I
DID HEAR YOU SAY THAT YES IN
ONE OF YOUR ANSWER SO THANK YOU
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL TO OUR COMMITTEE. WE DON'T
HAVE A MOTION THAT. THANK YOU
SIR MOTION OF PRESENTED BY MR
STONE SECOND BY MR WOOD THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ITEM TWENTY ONE
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE
ASSEMBLY MURATSUCHI MEMBERS
THREE OF US I RIVERSIDE FLORIDA.
CHAU FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA MATHIS. MATHIS NO
MCCARTY. MURATSUCHI HI
MURATSUCHI I'D SAY ARE TOP NOW
SAY I DON'T KNOW STONE STONE I
WOULD I WOULD I. FIVE TO PAY
FIVE TO BELIEVE THAT OPEN NEXT-
ANOTHER BILL BY MISTER
MURATSUCHI AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE. THANK YOU AGAIN MADAM
CHAIR- THIS IS A PERFECT
TRANSITION OUT AND IF YOU
PLANNED IT THIS WAY BUT- YOU
KNOW AS WE SAW THE OPPOSITION
TO MY PREVIOUS BILL IS A
PERFECT ILLUSTRATION OF WHY WE
NEED TO. PLAN FOR IN AND HAVE
AN OPEN STAKEHOLDER DRIVEN-
DIALOGUE ON HOW DO WE ACHIEVE
OUR OUR CLIMATE GOALS WHILE AT
THE SAME TIME- MAKING SURE THAT
WE ARE LEAVING NO MAN NO WOMAN
BEHIND- IN THE JUST TRANSITION-
TO ACHIEVE OUR STATE'S CLIMATE
GOALS WHILE AT THE SAME TIME
SUPPORTING. ALL OF OUR HARD
WORKING MEN AND WOMEN-IN
CALIFORNIA ESPECIALLY ALL OF
OUR OUR GOOD PAYING UNION JOBS-
IN IN THE FOSSIL FUEL INDUSTRY.
THIS BILL CALLS FOR A JUST
TRANSITION COMMISSION. WHERE WE
WOULD HAVE THE STAKEHOLDERS-
REPRESENTED- THE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADE UNIONS
ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS OIL
COMPANIES YOU KNOW ALL OF THE
STAKEHOLDERS. THAT SO WE NEED
TO BRING TOGETHER AND EIGHT
OPEN AND TRANSPARENT- DIALOGUE
ON HOW WE CAN ALL AS STATED
CALIFORNIA. AGAIN SAVE OUR
PLANET ACHIEVE OUR CLIMATE
GOALS WHILE AT THE SAME TIME-SUPPORTING OUR GOOD UNION JOBS
ARE ARE WORKING MEN AND WOMEN-
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
SO THAT IS THE GOAL OF- OF THIS
BILL AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. LET'S
OPEN UP THE LINES FOR SUPPORT
FOR OPPOSITION. MODERATOR Q.
PLEASE DO WE SHOULD. THANK YOU
IF YOU WISH TO SPEAK AT AB
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE CURRENTLY HAVE ONE
COMMENT IN CUBA JUST BE ONE
MOMENT FOR THAT LINE. BY THREE
SIXTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. YEAH
HELLO THIS IS A MANAGER MEMBER
SCOTT WHICH SHOULD BE AT THE
CALIFORNIA PIPE TRADES COUNCIL
IN THE STATE ASSOCIATION.
ELECTRICAL WORKERS AND WE'RE
OPPOSED TO THIS BILL. AND I'LL
TELL YOU WHY WERE OPPOSE THIS
BILL BECAUSE THE LEGISLATURE
CONTINUES TO PASS LEGISLATION
LIKE THE PREVIOUS BILL TAKING
OUR- NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION ON THE BILL. Q. I HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT THANK YOU AT
THIS TIME. THANK YOU ANY
WITNESSES IN THE HEARING ROOM.
SEE NON- NO WITNESSES AT THE
REMOTE LOCATION- ANY QUESTIONS
FROM MEMBERS. THERE ARE NONE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK WAY I'VE-
THANK YOU. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BUT I BELIEVE
I DON'T HAVE A MOTION FOR THIS
BILL. OKAY. BY MISTER STONE
SECONDED BY MISS FRIEDMAN
MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL I AM TWENTY TWO A. B.
FOURTEEN FIFTY THREE BY
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI
MEMBERS RIVAS I RIVERSIDE FLOOR.
CHAU FRIEDMAN HI FRIEDMAN I'D
GARCIA MATHIS. MATHIS NOT
VOTING MCCARTY BROUGHT TO
CHENNAI READ THROUGH GI SAY ARE
TO. SAY ARE NOT VOTING STONE
STONE I WOULD WOOD I. FIVE ZERO
FIVE ZERO THE BILL HAS REMAINED
OPEN. WE'RE NOW AT OUR FINAL
BILL SB SEVEN SENATOR MCGUIRE.
IN THE ROOM C. OKAY- NO I WELL
I. ME CHECK OKAY CAN WE PLEASE
CALL SENATOR MCGUIRE PERCENT
THE BILL. YEAH YES BUT- OKAY
WE'VE ALREADY CALLED THE ROLE
BUT WE CAN- THERE'S LOTS OF
BILLS THAT ARE ON CALL. OR ARE
AVAILABLE FOR MEMBERS TO ADD
ON- LET'S GO AHEAD AND START
WITH THAT AND WHEN THE SENATOR
GETS HERE WE WILL UP HERE SB
SEVEN. YOU WANT ME TO ALSO CALL
THE BILLS THAT STICK OUT OUT
ALREADY. YES BECAUSE WE HAVE
THE NUMBERS HERE THAT WEREN'T
PRESENT PLEASE DO THAT. JUST
AFFECTED ONE. OKAY. ONE ITEM
ONE AB FIVE HUNDRED SOMETHING
MEMBER LORD LORD. THE MOTION I
TO PASS REFER TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FORTY ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORIDA. FLORIMO FRIEDMAN.
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA MATHIS
MATHIS NO MCCARTY MARTUCCI
BRITISCHEN NOT VOTING. FIVE
THREE. FIVE THREE. APPLE WILL
STAY OPEN WELL. I AM TOO AB
THIRTEEN FORTY FOUR ARAMBULA.
TO PASS A REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE%
CURRENT VOTE FORTY THREE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA. MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO CHU
NOT VOTING THEY ARE TOUGH.
APPROACH THEY ARE DON'T KNOW.
FIVE FOUR FIVE FOUR. I DIDN'T
THREE AB THIRTEEN FORTY SIX BY
BERMAN. TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FORTY THREE WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I TUCCI MURATSUCHI I WOULD. SIX
THREE SIX THREE THAT PULLS OUT.
THE ITEM FOR AB THIRTEEN
NINETY. BY BOERNER HORVATH TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FOUR TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. CHAU CHAU
AYE FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI FIVE MURATSUCHI I
WOULD WOOD I. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT. I DON'T
FIVE EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BURKE TO PASS AS AMENDED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE. TWO TWO
ZERO WITH THE CHORE VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I'D GARCIA.
MCCARTY. RIGHT TO CHOOSE RATHER
TO GI. WOOD I WOULD I'D- SIX
ZERO SIX ZERO THAT PULLS OUT.
IDM SIX AB TWELVE SIXTY AYE
CHANCE TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FOUR TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR OR FORTY ONE WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS
CHILD CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI I YES ON ON ON IT
NOW. I AM SIX AB TWELVE SIXTY
MURATSUCHI NO. ABSENT MEMBER
WOULD. WOOD I. SEVEN TWO SEVEN
TWO THAT BILL IS OUT. I DON'T
SEVEN AB FIVE TWENTY FIVE BY
MEMBER TO DO PASSED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHILD. CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY.
RIGHT TO G. RIGHT TO GI WOULD.
WOOD I. TEN ZERO TEN ZERO. IDM
EIGHT AB TEN EIGHTY SEVEN BY
MEMBER CHIU TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE THREE TO THREE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI AB TWO GI WOULD
WOULD I. SEVEN THREE. FOR ITEM
NINE EIGHTY NINE NINETY TWO BY
MEMBER COOLEY TO PASS PREFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE KERR
OF ALL FIVE TO ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
HI GARCIA. MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
MURATSUCHI I WOULD. WOOD I.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO. I DON'T
TEND AB THREE FIFTY FOUR BY
MEMBER COOPER TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA MCCARTY
RIGHT TREE ROOTS TO GI WOULD.
WOULD I NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT. ADAM ELEVEN
A. B. FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE BY
FRAZIER TO PASS AS AMENDED AND
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHAU AYE
FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA.
MATHIS MATHIS AYE MCCARTY.
MURATSUCHI ROAD TO GI. NINE
ZERO NINE ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT.
I ROOM TWELVE AB NINE SIXTY TWO
BY KAMLAGER DO PASS AND
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE- VOTE SIX TO ZERO
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU. CHAU AYE FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. MCCARTY
MURATSUCHI ROSE TO GI. NINE
ZERO. NINE ZERO THAT WAS OUT.
IDM THIRTEEN EIGHTY NINE SIXTY
THREE COME WATER FROM LONGER TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CAR ABOUT SIX ZERO AT
THE CHERVONA GUY ABSENT MEMBERS
CHILD SHALL I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
I'D GARCIA MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
ROUTE TO GI. NINE ZERO. NINE
ZERO THE ITEM FOURTEEN AB THREE
TWENTY TWO BY MEMBERS SALAS TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE KERR ABOUT SIX TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING AYE
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHAU
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA.
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO CHU
NOT VOTING. EIGHT ZERO EIGHT
ZERO APPLESOFT. I FIFTY AB SIX
NINE NINE BY SAW TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND RE TO
APPROPRIATIONS CURRENT VOTE
FIVE ZERO WITH TROUBLED I
ABSENT CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN I. MATHIS MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY MURATSUCHI RIGHT TO GI.
NINE ZERO. NINE ZERO THAT
PHYLLIS OUT. I'D M. SIXTEEN A.
B. SEVEN THIRTEEN BY MEMBER
CRISTINA GARCIA DO PASSED
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I.
ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU CHOW I
FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN I MCCARTY.
RIGHT TO CHOOSE RIGHT TO GI
WOOD. WOOD I. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO THAT PHYLLIS OUT. I'D IN
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY FIVE SEVENTY
NINE BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER FLORA.
MOTION TO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA. MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
RIGHT TO GI. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO. I DO NINETEEN A. B. SEVEN
NINETY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
FLORA TO PASS REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SIX ZERO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS
CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN FRIEDMAN
AYE GARCIA MCCARTY MURATSUCHI
RUSSERT GI. NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO. YEAH I DON'T TWENTY AB
NINE TWENTY SIX ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS TO PASS REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO WITH
THE CHAIR VOTING I ABSENT
MEMBERS CHAU CHOW I FRIEDMAN
FRIEDMAN AYE GARCIA. MCCARTY.
NINE ZERO NINE ZERO I'M SORRY
YEAH I HAVE MISSED YOUR NOT TO
G. S. I. YES SO WE ARE AT NINE
ZERO. I AM TWENTY ONE AB
THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MARTUCCI TO PASS AS
AMENDED AND REFER TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO WITH THE
CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA FLORA NO CHAU. CHAU AYE
GARCIA. MCCARTY. SIX THREE. SIX
THREE THAT BILL IS OUT. I AM
TWENTY TWO AB FOURTEEN FIFTY
THREE BY AND MEMBER MURATSUCHI
TO PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT FOUR FIVE
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORIDA. FLORIDA
VOTING. CHAU CHAU AYE GARCIA
MCCARTY. SIX ZERO SIX ZERO THAT
BILL IS OUT. AND WE ARE READY
TO HEAR SB SEVEN. WITH THE BILL
OKAY. IF THE- MISTER MCGUIRE
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND THE
SECOND AND THIRD. THANK. THANK
YOU SO MUCH MADAM CHAIR VERY
GRATEFUL IN DIE HERE THAT WE
HAVE A MULTIPLE MOTION SO I'M
VERY GRATEFUL I'D IN ALL JUST
BE LESS THAN THIRTY SECONDS
MADAM CHAIR AND JUST SAY ON
BEHALF OF PRESENT ACTIONS WHEN
I SAY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
INTO THAT COMEDIAN THE VERY
CAPABLE STAFF FOR ALL OF THE
WORK LONG STORY SHORT AS YOU
KNOW SB SEVEN EXTENDS TO TWENTY
TWENTY ONE CENTS SAID OF AB
NINE HUNDRED THROUGH THE END OF
THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FOR
LARGER PROJECTS IN NOW FOCUSING
ON A NEW THRESHOLD AND THAT IS
FOR HOUSING- SO THE THRESHOLD
WOULD HAVE QUALIFYING PROJECTS
TO FIFTEEN MILLION- IT WHICH IS
AN 85% REDUCTION REQUIRED
INVESTMENT OVER THE PRIOR. LAW
SO WE'RE ABLE TO BE ABLE TO GET
HOUSING DONE QUICKER WITH THAT%
TWO HUNDRED AND SEVENTY DAY
TRADITIONAL REVIEW HI MADAM
CHAIR I'D BE HAPPY TO GO
FURTHER IF YOU'D LIKE
ADDITIONAL EXPLANATION BUT
AGAIN I'M GRATEFUL TO BE HERE
ON BEHALF OF PROTEIN BACK INTO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE AND THINK YOU CAN FOR THE
MOTIONS AND FOR ALL YOUR WORK
THANK YOU SO WE HAVE TO
WITNESSES YES WE DO TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT BY PHONE- FIRST WE
HAVE- SAM LICCARDO MAYOR OF THE
CITY OF SAN JOSE. AND RON
MILLER FROM THE L. A. O. C.
BUILDING. AND CONSTRUCTIONS
TRADE. CAN TRADE. OF MODERATOR
Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE LINES FOR
WITNESSES. SHE BOTH LINES ARE
OPEN. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
THIS IS SAM LICCARDO WHICH YOU
LIKE ME TO PROCEED YES PLEASE.
THANK YOU THAT MEANT CHAIRED
ALL THE MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE- THANK YOU FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP IN THIS IS STARTING
DEEPLY CHALLENGING MOMENTS.
YEAH THAT THANK YOU SENATE
MCGUIRE FOR HIS ADVOCACY
LEADERSHIP I THANK YOU ALSO FOR
TAKING UP SB SEVEN EARLY IN THE
SESSION IF YOU'RE PASAPORTE SB
NINE NINETY FIVE LAST YEAR. MY
CITY IS HERE TODAY AND SEVERAL
OTHER CITIES HAVE HAD CERTIFIED
SB NINE HUNDRED PROJECTS
DELAYED BY THIS PANDEMIC AND AS
AN EXAMPLE SAN JOSE DOWNTOWN
WEST PROJECT COMPRISES ONE OF
THE MOST BENEFICIALLY IMPACT
ALL. PRIVATE SECTOR INVESTMENT
IN CALIFORNIA HISTORY IT OFFERS
CONCRETE SOLUTIONS TO MANY OF
OUR GREATEST CRISES CONFRONTING
OUR FOR WHAT HOUSING CRISIS
WITH THE PRODUCTION OF ONE IN
FOUR THOUSAND HIGH DENSITY
HOMES AT LEAST 25% WHICH WILL
BE RENT RESTRICTED IN
AFFORDABLE. ADDRESSING THEIR
STATE 8% UNEMPLOYMENT RATE BY
CREATING FIFTY SEVEN HUNDRED
PREVAILING WAGE CONSTRUCTION
JOBS TO BUILD AN URBAN VILLAGE
OF MORE THAN SEVEN MILLION
SQUARE FEET OF COMMERCIAL
DEVELOPMENT DOWN THEY'VE A
LONGER TERM EMPLOYMENT FOR TENS
OF THOUSANDS. OF CALIFORNIANS I
COUNTY CLIMATE CHANGE BY
MAXIMIZING THE HIGHEST POSSIBLE
THAT HE'S AROUND CANDIDATES
DOWNTOWN CENTRAL TRANSIT
STATION THAT SERVES SEVEN MAJOR
TRANSIT SYSTEMS CAN
CONSTRUCTING ALL THIS PROJECT
AT LEED GOLD GOLD STANDARD WITH
NET ZERO GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS. ALONG WITH THE
DEVELOPMENT OF FIFTEEN ACRES OF
PARKS AND GREEN SPACES. AND
FINALLY AS THIS PANDEMIC IN
EXACERBATES CALIFORNIA STARK
ECONOMIC DIVIDE THAT THIS
PROJECT IN GOOGLE'S DEVELOPING
A PARTICULAR WILL PRODUCE MORE
THAN ONE BILLION DOLLARS IN
PUBLIC BENEFITS INCLUDING AN
UNPRECEDENTED. TWEET TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLAR FUNDING
FOR ANTI DISPLACEMENT JOB
TRAINING EDUCATION AND
HOMELESSNESS SOLUTIONS WE HOPE
THAT WITH LEGISLATIVE APPROVAL
THAT PARTICULAR VEHICLE THIS
COMMITTEE WILL BE ABLE TO GET
SHOVELS IN THE GROUND. AFTER MY
CITY COUNCIL'S APPROVAL ON MAY
TWENTY FIFTH SO THAT WE CAN
REALIZE THE MOST TRANSFORMATIVE
INVESTMENT IN THE HISTORY OF
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST
CITY ANSWER THAT MANY OTHER.
CITIES CAN GET THEIR AFFORDABLE
HOUSING PROJECT CAN AWAY AS
WELL. I DEEPLY PER YOUR TIME TO
CONSIDER MY- THANK YOU VENTURE.
THANK YOU AND THAT'S WITNESS.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRWOMAN RIVAS
MEMBERS AND STAFF THE NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE I'M RON
MILLER EXECUTIVE SECRETARY OF
THE L. A. ORANGE COUNTY
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES COUNCIL. WE REPRESENT
OVER A HUNDRED FORTY THOUSAND
SKILLED AND TRAINED MEN AND
WOMEN WITHIN FORTY EIGHT LOCAL
UNIONS AND DISTRICT COUNCILS.
TODAY I COME TO YOU ON BEHALF
OF THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
AND IT'S HALF A MILLION MEMBERS.
RIGHT MANY OF THESE CRAFT
WORKERS ARE YOUR CONSTITUENTS.
I COME BEFORE YOU TODAY IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN I COULD
TALK TO YOU ABOUT ALL THE GOOD
THINGS IT DOES FOR WORKING MEN
AND WOMEN IN THE CONSTRUCTION
TRADES BUT I THINK YOU'RE AWARE
OF THOSE BENEFITS. THIS BILL
WOULD REAUTHORIZE AND EXTEND
THE JOBS AND ECONOMIC IT
IMPROVEMENT THROUGH
ENVIRONMENTAL LEADERSHIP ACT OF
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. WHICH IS
LED TO THE DEVELOPMENT OF
NEARLY TWENTY PROJECTS SINCE
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN. MANY OF
WHICH INCLUDED A HOUSING
COMPONENT. WHILE PROVIDING WORK
OPPORTUNITIES FOR THOUSANDS OF
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS. WITH THE
POLICIES AND PROCEDURES IN
PLACE IN CITIES UP AND DOWN THE
STATE IT TAKES FOREVER TO GET
PROJECT ENTITLED. AND READY TO
CONSTRUCT. WITH THAT BEINGSAID
WE HAVE QUITE A FEW PROJECTS
THAT ARE IN NEED OF THIS BILL
GETTING PASSED TO CONTINUE
THEIR ENTITLEMENT PROCESS. WITH
THE CURRENT CODE PANDEMIC.
ELEMENTA CONSTRUCTION IS WE
KNOW IT HAS BEEN DECIMATED AND
HAD A DIRECT EFFECT ON THE
ECONOMY UP AND DOWN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA AND NOT THAT WE
DIDN'T ALREADY HAVE A HOUSING
CRISIS BEFORE THE PANDEMIC BUT
THE HOUSING CRISIS HAS GOTTEN
MUCH MUCH WORSE THAN THE
PROJECT IN THE QUEUE IN FUTURE
PROJECTS THAT ARE PROPOSED.
WILL HAVE THE ABILITY TO
CONTRIBUTE RELIEF TO THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CRISIS AT A
TIME CREATING A PATHWAY FOR
ENTRY INTO APPRENTICESHIP IN
THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES WOULD
PROVIDE GOOD MIDDLE CLASS
CAREERS FOR FUTURE SKILLED AND
TRAINED MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY. WHICH
ALL THE WHILE DRIVING THE
ECONOMY STATEWIDE. WHICH IS
GOOD BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE
LEARNED. WHEN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY THRIVES THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
PROSPER. THANK YOU AND I MOVED
TO A- HOPE THAT YOU APPROVED
THIS BILL THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE. WHAT ONE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION- GREG WITH MEN FROM
STOP THE MILLENNIUM HOLLYWOOD
DOT COM. MODERATOR KEY PLEASE
OPEN UP THE LINE FOR A WITNESS.
THANK YOU YOUR HONOR WILL
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. YEP
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS
GREGORY WHITMAN OF THE
SILVERSTEIN LAW FIRM SPEAKING
FOR STOP THE MILLENNIUM
HOLLYWOOD DOT COM IN OPPOSITION
OF IT TO SB SEVEN FIRST SB
SEVEN INDISCRIMINATELY ACCORDS
RETROACTIVE ENVIRONMENTAL
LEADERSHIP DEVELOPMENT PROJECTS
STATUS WORK EARLIER GUILTY
PLEAS TAX STATUS HAD EXPIRED
REGARDLESS OF NEW FACTS THAT
MAY HAVE ARISEN. SINCE THE TIME
OF THE ORIGINAL DEAL DEEPLY
APPROVAL THE POSTER CHILD FOR
THIS RECKLESSNESS OF THE
HOLLYWOOD CENTER PROJECT THAT
PROJECT PROPOSES TO HIGH RISE
TOWERS ATOP THE SEVEN POINT OH
MAGNITUDE HOLLYWOOD EARTHQUAKE
FAULT. THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
GEOLOGICAL SURVEY HAS
OFFICIALLY MAPPED THE ACTIVE
HOLLYWOOD EARTHQUAKE FAULT
UNDER THIS SITE IN HOLLYWOOD A
MASSIVE NEW STUDY FROM THE
UNITED STATES GEOLOGICAL SURVEY
AS OF MAY TWENTY TWENTY SHOWS
THAT THE ACTIVE HOLLYWOOD
EARTHQUAKE FAULT RUNS DIRECTLY
UNDER BOTH PROPOSED SKYSCRAPERS
AND RISK CATASTROPHIC BUILDING
FAILURE IT WOULD BE
UNCONSCIONABLE FOR THE STATE TO
THE SPORTS SPECIAL PRIVILEGES
TO A PROJECT WHILE THE STATE.
OWNED PROFESSIONAL GEOLOGISTS
ARE SOUNDING THE ALARM THAT
LIVES ARE AT RISK WE ALSO NOTE
THAT MILLENNIUM PARTNERS IS A
MAJOR PROPONENT OF SB SEVEN AND
ITS FAILED PREDECESSOR LAST
YEAR EIGHTY TWO NINE NINE ONE
MILLENNIUMPARTNERS IS ALSO THE
DEVELOPER OF THE LEANING AND
SINKING POWER OF SAN FRANCISCO.
SECOND SB SEVEN INDISCRIMINATE
RETROACTIVE REVIVAL OF THE L.
D. P. IS ALSO TROUBLING BECAUSE
IT ALLOWS AN ALTERNATIVE TO
RECEIVE THIS SPECIAL BENEFIT SB
SEVEN NOTHING COURAGE'S
DEVELOPERS TO PROPOSE A RED
HERRING PROJECTS WHILE
ATTENDING APPROVAL FOR LITTLE
STUDIED ALTERNATIVE FOR EXAMPLE
A PRIMARILY OFFICE AND HOTEL
TENTATIVE THAT IS PURSUED FOR
HOLLYWOOD CENTER. PROPOSED CUTS
THE SIZE OF THE SO CALLED
SENIOR PORTABLE UNITS BY ALMOST
50% THE PROVISION OF A TOKEN
AMOUNT OF AFFORDABLE UNITS IS
TRULY OUTRAGEOUS CONSIDERING
THAT THE AVERAGE MARKET RATE
AND THE PROJECT WOULD HAVE A
BALCONY AS LARGE AS THE SO
CALLED AFFORDABLE UNITS. AND OF
COURSE THIS COMMITTEE SHOULD
NOT SUPPORT A BILL WITH FURTHER
ENABLE DEVELOPER COMPLEXITY
AIRPORT ANY UNIT ON TOP OF AN
EARTHQUAKE FAULT LINE SB SEVEN
URGENTLY CLOSER CHRIS SITE THE
NEED FOR HOUSING DEVELOPMENT
BUT IT'S CONNECTION TO HAPPEN
PRODUCTION THE TENUOUS MOST
PROJECTS. ARE STADIUMS OR REINA.
THANK YOU FOR. ACROSS OKAY.
THANK YOU- NEXT WILL. WELL HERE
WITNESSES IN HEARING ROOM SINCE
I SEE THAT WE HAVE SOME. PLEASE
REMEMBER TO STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL. ERIN LEHANE ON BEHALF OF
THE HALF A MILLION MEMBERS OF
THE STATE BUILDING TRADES
INCLUDING SIXTY EIGHT THOUSAND
APPRENTICES IN ENTHUSIASTIC
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
MY QUEST ON BEHALF THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF PAINTERS
AND ALLIED TRADES WE SELL THE
BUILDING TRADES ALSO IN SUPPORT.
RAYMOND DAVIS IRON WORKERS
LOCAL ONE EIGHTEEN STRONGLY
SUPPORT. MARKER DRAWING
BOILERMAKER FIVE FORTY NINE OF
PITTSBURG CALIFORNIA WE STAND
SOLIDARITY BUILDING TRADES AND
WE SUPPORT THIS BILL ALONG WITH
ALL OF CALIFORNIA'S
BOILERMAKERS STATEWIDE. GOOD
AFTERNOON GLENN LEVEL
IRONWORKERS UNION LOCAL THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES IN STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON TOM MAIDEN
PLUMBERS AND PIPEFITTERS LOCAL
FOUR FOUR SEVEN SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA STANDING IN SUPPORT
WITH THE STATE BUILDING TRADES.
AND IN SUPPORT OF SB. SEVEN
GOOD AFTERNOON RENDON DISCOUNT
SIXTEEN PAINTERS AND ALLIED
TRADES WE STAND WITH THE
BUILDING TRADES IN SUPPORT OF
SB SEVEN THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON TO THE JEFFREY
BOILERMAKER STANDING SUPPORT
OF- SB SEVEN THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES. ON. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS ROB STOKER
AND ON BEHALF OF THE OVER TEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS A SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND STUFF IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN. RMANDO
GUERRERO WITH THE SHEET METAL
WORKERS LOCAL ONE OH FOUR IN
SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON OUT OF EL CHOI
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN.
MORGAN NOLTING PRESIDENT OF
WESTERN REGIONAL DISTRICT
COUNCIL REFERS WATER PREFERS IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU. GOOD
AFTERNOON DEANA BRILL WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL SHEET METAL
WORKERS STRONG SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU NEXT WILL
OPEN UP THE PHONE LINES FOR
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OR
OPPOSITION- PLEASE REMEMBER TO
JUST STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION AND POSITION ON THE
BILL- WE WILL BE LIMITING THE
PHONE LINES TO FIVE MINUTES
MODERATOR Q. PLEASE OPEN UP THE
LINES. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH TO
SPEAK ADDRESS THE SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE ABOUT THIRTY
IN Q. WILL WATCH ONE ONE
NINETEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. SOME
WOMEN SAN DIEGO BUILDING TRADES
AND ENTHUSIASTIC SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL THANK YOU. THANK YOU
I'M THREE THIRTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
MATT BROUGHT ON BEHALF OF THE
TEAMSTERS AND SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU I'M THREE NINETEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
NOT A NOT LIKE HOW PUBLIC
AFFAIRS CALLING ON BEHALF OF.
CALIFORNIA YIMBY STAND HELP HIM
TO PARTNERS THE COUNCILS INSULT
ELDERS AND THE THING WAS WE AND
URBAN RESEARCH ASSOCIATION. ALL
INSTRUCTORS WORK. THANK YOU
RYAN SIXTY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. CHARLES RIGHT ON BEHALF
OF MILLION IN STRONG SUPPORT
AND SENATE BILL. FIVE THANK YOU
I'M THREE TWENTY PLEASE GO
AHEAD. JUST HIGHER ON BEHALF OF
THE SILICON VALLEY LEADERSHIP
GROUP AND WE ARE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THE BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT THREE TWENTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. SURE
MEMBERS NOT CLUB IN PHOENIX
CALIFORNIA VISORS ON BEHALF OF
JELLO IN SUPPORT. FIVE THREE
TWENTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
UNDER MURDER COULD NOT BE TOLD
BEGINNING IN STRONG SUPPORT.
FIVE THREE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. IT MIGHT BRING YOU
WITH THIS- CAL SIXTEEN PAINTERS
KNOWLEDGE TRADING WITHOUT THE
STATE BUILDING TRADES SINCE
AUGUST THE SEVENTH. THANK YOU I
AM TO FORTY TO PLEASE CALL HAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS STEVE ALONG
WITH DISCOUNT OF SIXTEEN
PAINTERS AND ALLIED TRADES AND
WE STAND WITH THE BUILDING
TRADES SUPPORT OF SB SEVEN.
THANK YOU NINE TWENTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. I WOULD NEED
TO BE INVOLVED WITH SMART SHEET
METAL WORKERS LOCAL ONE ZERO
FIVE BEGIN WITH THE BUILDING
TRADE IN SUPPORT. FIVE THREE
THIRTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
YOU'RE GOING ON BEHALF OF
SILICON VALLEY AT HOME IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU NINE
THREE THIRTY EIGHT PLEASE CALL
I HAD. MEDICARE MEMBERS JOE
CRUZ SOMEBODY AT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE COUNCIL LABORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN. FIVE THREE
ELEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THIS IS ED EVANS WITH
CARPENTERS LOCAL TWO SEVENTEEN
IN SAN MATEO COUNTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF SENATE BILL SEVEN.
RIGHT THREE THIRTY NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO THANK YOU FOR
OUR IN BEHALF OF FACEBOOK IN
SUPPORT. FIVE THREE FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. DOCUMENTUM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
ADAM RACKLEY WITH THE
CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF COMMERCE
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ARE THREE TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
CALL HAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
NUMBER THANK YOU DON'T ON
BEHALF OF THE CITY OF BEVERLY
HILLS AND RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION
TO AFTERTHOUGHT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ARE THREE FORTY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS MY NAME IS
TOM SPAULDING REPRESENTED THE
CURRENT IN YOUR MODEL COUNTY
BUILDING TRADES COUNCIL AND WE
STAND WITH THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES IN THEIR SUPPORT- SB
SEVEN. THANK YOU HE THANK YOU
ARE THREE THIRTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. COULD NOT MID AFTERNOON
CHAIRWOMAN COMMITTEE WELL MY
NAME IS TOMMY PAUL VIA
REPRESENT IDW'S LOCAL ELEVEN
LOS ANGELES COUNTY AND WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT SB SEVEN
THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE UP
ONE NINETY THREE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. ONE NINE THREE. ONE ONE
FOURTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I
CAN'T BELIEVE THIS USER
REPRESENTING LOCAL SIXTEEN HEAT
ACROSS INSULATORS NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA AND HERE IN STRONG
SUPPORT SB SEVEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT NINETY ONE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
THIS IS MARK BELL B. HE CROSSES
PLAYERS LOCAL SIXTEEN SENDING A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB. SEVEN
CLICK. FIVE THIRTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RIGHT. THREE SEVEN.
DEMICHELIS IN YOUR BILL
REPRESENTED FOR CARPENTERS
LOCAL SEVEN FIFTY ONE AND
THIRTY FIVE COVER IN MARIN
SONOMA NAPA LAKE MENDOCINO DEL
NORTON HUMBOLDT COUNTY AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN. THANK YOU VERY THREE
FIFTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. READ
AND SHARE MEMBERS MIKE BONTA
GOING TO BE OUT THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF ELECTRICAL
WORKERS IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
SEVEN THANK YOU. THANK YOU LINE
TO TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
DOCTORS REPRESENTING THE
INTERNATIONAL UNION OF
OPERATING ENGINEERS LOCAL
TWELVE AND WE STAND IN SUPPORT-
WITH THE- STATE BUILDING TRADE
AND SUPPORT SKEWS ME- SB SEVEN.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT FORTY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. FOUR ZERO.
RIGHT TO EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON LEON YOU
TACK IT ON BEHALF OF TECH NOT
IMPORT. NINE THREE TWENTY EIGHT
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
JOHN ROBERTS WITH KP PUBLIC
AFFAIRS HERE FOR GOOGLE IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU I'M THREE
THIRTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YES GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS ALL POWER ON BEHALF
OF THE ONE HIGHWAY ONE PROJECT
USING DIEGO IN SUPPORT OF.
SENATE BILL SEVEN THANK YOU.
MODERATOR WE ARE AT FIVE
MINUTES. I'M IN I JUST WANNA
REMIND ANYONE THAT MAY STILL BE
ON THE LINES THAT WE WILL
ACCEPT ADDITIONAL TESTIMONY OF
ANY LANE- YOU CAN SUBMIT IT VIA
OUR COMMITTEE WEBSITE. I JUST
WANT TO THANK EVERYONE- FOR
CALLING MEN AND THE WITNESSES
THAT WERE PRESENT HERE. DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR MEMBERS.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
INTO THE MEMBERS I KNOW IT'S
BEEN A LONG DAY SO VERY
GRATEFUL TO BE ABLE TO HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IN FRONT OF YOU THE
ONE ITEM I THAT WOULD LIKE TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS AND I THINK
IT'S ONE OF THE MOST ELEGANT
PARTS OF SB SEVEN. THIS BILL
DOES NOT AFFECT ENVIRONMENTAL
MITIGATION UNDERSEA QUOTE THAT
ONE DAY- IT DOESN'T AFFECT THE
RIGHTS OF PETITIONS TO
CHALLENGE INADEQUATE
ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORTS AT
THE SEEKER REVIEW IN THIS BILL
ISN'T TOUGH ISN'T TOUCHED IT
REMAINS FIRMLY INTACT. THE
LEGISLATION SIMPLY SPEEDS UP
THE JUDICIAL PROCESS TO IT AND
SEVEN DAY JUDICIAL REVIEW IF AN
EARTHQUAKE RISK IS IDENTIFIED%
IN ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT REPORT.
THEN IT WOULDN'T BE SENT BACK
TO THE CITY COUNCIL OR THE BOOT
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS WHO COULD
THEN REMEDY THAT POTENTIAL
IMPACT OR REJECT THE PROJECT
BOTTOM LINE FULL STOP ON THIS
BILL IN SIMILAR LEGISLATION
RECEIVED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT ON
THE ASSEMBLY FLOOR WAS SIXTY
VOTES AND AGAIN MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU FOR YOUR ENGAGEMENT.
LEADERSHIP TO THIS COMMITTEE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME TODAY
WERE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
IPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER
MCGUIRE- I KNOW I HAD A MOTION
I BELIEVE IT WAS. MISTER WIDE
SECONDED BY MR MATHIS THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS- ON SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ON ITEM
TWENTY THREE SB SEVEN BY
SENATOR ATKINS THE MOTION IS TO
PASS REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEMBERS RIVAS HI
RIVERSIDE FLORA FLORA I'D CHAU
CHAU HI FRIEDMAN. FRIEDMAN AYE
GARCIA. MATHIS. MATHIS FIVE
GARCIA. MCCARTY THE READING
ROUTE TO TREAT. I WROTE TO G.
RSA ARCHER THEY ARE T<c.cyan> STONE</c>
STONE NO WOULD. WOOD I. EIGHT
ONE EIGHT ONE THAT FILLS OUT
THINKING. HELLO WE STILL HAVE A
FEW BILLS ON CALL AND I KNOW
SOME MEMBERS HAVE TO ADD ON BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT I WANT TO
THANK- ALL THE MEMBERS FOR
JOINING ME AN HOUR EARLIER
TODAY SO THAT WE CAN GET
THROUGH THIS HEARING AND HEAR
ALL OF THE BILLS TODAY I THANK
YOU TO THE COMMITTEE STAFF AND
TO THE ROOM THE TEAM THAT MAKES
THIS POSSIBLE BY SETTING UP
THIS ROOM. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
FOR ALL YOUR SUPPORT. WE HAVE I
BELIEVE TWO BILLS ON CALL BUT
WE'RE WE NEED WHAT MR MCCARTY.
THE ITEM. FOR CONTACT. ONE ITEM
FOR AB THIRTEEN NINETY TO PASS
REFERRED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CURRENT VOTE EIGHT
ZERO WITH THE CHAIR VOTING II
ABSENT MEMBERS FLORA. MATHIS.
MATHIS FIVE MCCARTY. NINE ZERO
NINE ZERO. THAT'S CORRECT. YEAH
I'M I JUST TEXTED- MISTER
MCCARTY. I THINK WHO IS SO
MESSED GARCIA NEEDS TO ADD ON.
MISTER MURATSUCHI DO YOU NEED
TO. ARE YOU COVERED OKAY.
PROBABLY LET ME YEAH. I THINK A
MAJORITY IS MCCARTY AND MISS
GARCIA THAT NEED TO ADD. ON
HE'S GOT MISTER MCCARTY IS ON
HIS WAY IF MISS GARCIA DOESN'T
MIND. OKAY THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
OKAY. NINE YEAH. THE. THANK.
THE PEOPLE. YEAH. YOUR THIS IS.
YOU YEAH ARE. THIRTY RIGHT RATE
MISTER MCCARTY. IS HERE. YEAH
THAT'S RIGHT. RIGHT READY. ALL
PEOPLE ALL- YEAH- YEAH THERE'S
A DUAL. YEAH I BELIEVE THE
FIRST TWO BILLS ARE ON CALL
RIGHT I DON'T WANT INTO. YEAH
OKAY.
VERY LITTLE. ANALYSTS.
RIGHT. MISTER MCCARTY MISTER
SEA ARE YOU READY YEAH OKAY.
LIFTING THE CALL ON ITEM ONE AB
FIVE HUNDRED BY WARD MOTION TO
PASS REFER TO HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE WAS FIVE TO THREE
WITH THE CHAIR VOTING I. ABSENT
MEMBER GARCIA. HI GARCIA I
MCCARTY MCCARTY I. SEVEN THREE
SEVEN THREE THAT BILL IS OUT.
ON ITEM TWO AB THIRTEEN FORTY
FOUR MEMBER OF ABA THE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED REFERRED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TO FOUR WITH
THE CHURCH. AFTER YEAH GARCIA I.
SIX TO FOUR SIX TO FOR THAT
BILL IS OUT. ON ITEM THREE AB
THIRTEEN FORTY SIX. CURRENT
VOTE FORTY THREE WITH HER
VOTING I ABSENT MEMBERS CHAU.
CHAU I. AND WOOD. SEVEN THREE
SEVEN THREE. I DON'T FOR A BI
THIRTEEN NINETY. ABSENT MEMBERS
FLORA. MCCARTY MCCARTY I TEND.
ZERO TEN ZERO. I DON'T FIVE
EIGHTY SIX EIGHTY. ABSENT
MEMBERS. MCCARTY MCCARTY I
THINK ARSIA GARCIA I. EIGHT
ZERO. IDM SIX AB TWELVE SIXTY
ABSENT MEMBERS TARSIA. GARCIA
NOT VOTING MCCARTY MCCARTY I.
EIGHT TWO. WITH ITEM SEVEN AB
FIVE TWENTY FIVE ABSENT MEMBER
MCCARTY. MCCARTY II. ELEVEN
ZERO. I ITEM EIGHT A. B. TEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. ABSENT MEMBER
MCCARTY. MCCARTY II. EIGHT
THREE. FIFTH ITEM NINE EIGHTY
NINE NINETY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS
GARCIA GARCIA I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE. ELEVEN ZERO FOR
ITEM TEN AB THREE FIFTY FOUR
ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA. GARCIA
I'D MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE ELEVEN
ZERO. HEIDEMANN LEVIN AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY ONE ABSENT
MEMBERS GARCIA. GARCIA I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE. ELEVEN
ZERO. I AM TWELVE AB NINE SIXTY
TWO ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA
GARCIA I MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE.
ELEVEN ZERO. HI ADAM THIRTEEN
AB NINE SIXTY THREE ABSENT
MEMBERS GARCIA GARCIA I'D
MCCARTY. MCCARTY AYE. ELEVEN
ZERO. I DON'T FOURTEEN AB THREE
TWENTY TWO ABSENT MEMBERS
GARCIA. GARCIA I. MCCARTY
MCCARTY I. TEN ZERO. IT'S ITEM
FIFTEEN AB SIX NINETY NINE
ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA GARCIA I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE ELEVEN
ZERO. FILE ITEM SIXTEEN AB
SEVEN THIRTEEN ABSENT MEMBERS
MCCARTY. MCCARTY II. TEN ZERO.
THE ITEM EIGHTEEN AB FIVE
SEVENTY NINE ABSENT MEMBERS
GARCIA. GARCIA I MCCARTY
MCCARTY I LEVEL. ZERO HI ADAM
NINETEEN SB SEVEN NINETY TWO
ABSENT MEMBERS GARCIA. GARCIA I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE ELEVEN
ZERO. HI ADAM TWENTY AB NINE
TWENTY SIX ABSENT MEMBERS
GARCIA. RCI MCCARTY MCCARTY I A
LEVIN ZERO. FOR ITEM TWENTY ONE
AB THIRTEEN NINETY FIVE ABSENT
MEMBERS GARCIA. GARCIA I
MCCARTY MCCARTY AYE. EIGHT